UTILITIES AND COMMUNICATIONS
WILL KNOCK ON THE BORDER. GOOD
MORNING EVERYBODY IN RESPONSE
TO THE CALVET NINETEEN
EMERGENCY AND TO PROTECT THE
PUBLIC. SENATORS STAFF WE MUST
LIMIT NONESSENTIAL GATHERINGS
AND IT HERE TO SOCIAL
DISTANCING. IN COMPLIANCE WITH
THESE ORDERS THE SENATE WILL BE
HOLDING AN ESSENTIAL HEARING
AND HAS MADE NECESSARY
ADJUSTMENTS. TO NORMALIZE
PRACTICE IN ORDER TO ENSURE.
THAT THE PUBLIC CONTINUES TO
HAVE ACESS TO THE LEGISLATIVE
PROCESS WHILE ALSO CONDUCTING
THE HEARING IN A WAY THAT
PROTECTS THE HEALTH AND SAFETY
OF THE PUBLIC AND OUR
EMPLOYEES. AS WE COMPLY WITH
THOSE ORDERS WE ARE HOLDING OUR
COMMITTEE HEARINGS HERE IN THE
CAPITAL WITH SOME OF OUR
COMMITTEE MEMBERS. AND ALL OUR
PANELISTS AND THOSE WITH THE
UC. PUBLIC ADVOCATE'S OFFICE
AND THE THREE ELECTRIC
UTILITIES PARTICIPATING
REMOTELY WITH THE USE OF A
VIDEO CONFERENCE SYSTEM. FOR
MEMBERS AND PRESENTERS. THOSE
WHO WILL BE ATTENDING REMOTELY
TODAY PLEASE MUTE YOUR PHONES
OR COMPUTERS. THIS WILL GREATLY
AID IN THE ELIMINATE EVEN OF
ANY ACOUSTIC FEEDBACK I ALSO
ASKED THAT EVERY TIME YOU HAVE
A COMMENT OR QUESTION. YOU USE
THE RAISE YOUR HAND FEATURE ON
THE PROGRAM EACH TIME YOU ARE
ACKNOWLEDGED TO SPEAK A POP UP
WINDOW WILL APPEAR ASKING YOU
IF YOU WOULD LIKE TO ON MUTE.
PLEASE SELECT A COMMUTE BEFORE
YOU BEGIN SPEAKING. ALL WERE IT
PERSONNEL WILL PUT YOU BACK ON
ME YOU WHEN YOU ARE DONE. ONCE
RATE NICE TO SPEAK STATE YOUR
NAME AND ORGANIZATION. TO
ACCESS ANY PRESENTATION PLEASE
VISIT OUR COMMITTEE WEBSITE TO
ALLOW THE PUBLIC ACCESS WE HAVE
ADMITTED MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC.
TO TWO HEARING ROOMS TO THE
EXTENT THE SOCIAL DISTANCING
REQUIREMENTS ALLOW AND WILL BE
USING A TELECONFERENCE SERVICE
FOR THOSE INDIVIDUALS WHO WE-
TO TESTIFY. TODAY TOLL FREE
NUMBER AND ACCESS CODE IS
POSTED ON OUR COMMITTEE WEBSITE
IT WILL BE DISPLAYED ON THE
SCREEN WILL ANNOUNCE. HERE IN A
MOMENT SO GET YOUR PEN AND
PAPER READY TODAY'S PART TO
SUBMIT PUT. TODAY'S PARTICIPANT
NUMBER IS ONE EIGHT EIGHT I'M
SORRY ONCE AGAIN THE
PARTICIPANT NUMBER IS ONE.
EIGHT FOUR FOUR TWO NINE ONE
SIX THREE SIX FOUR AND THE
ACCESS CODE IS SEVEN EIGHT.
THREE SIX SEVEN FOUR FIVE. WHEN
WE MOVED TO PUBLIC COMMENT A
MODERATOR WILL IDENTIFY YOU
INDIVIDUALLY OPEN YOUR LINE AND
AT THAT TIME YOU MAY ADDRESS
THE COMMITTEE PLEASE NOTE THAT
IN ORDER FOR US TO HEAR YOU
CLEARLY AND TO AVOID ACOUSTIC
FEEDBACK YOU MUST MEET THE
DEVICE YOU ARE WATCHING. OR
HEARING. ON PRIOR TO GIVING
TESTIMONY OVER THE PHONE IT IS
IMPORTANT THAT WE HEAR FROM
YOU. AND WE THANK YOU FOR YOUR
PATIENCE. ALSO WE ASK THAT FOR
THOSE ON THE TELEPHONE THAT DAY.
LISTEN TO INSTRUCTIONS ON THE
PHONE AND NOT ON THE DEVICE
THAT YOU'RE LISTENING WITH
WHETHER VIA COMPUTER OR ANOTHER
DEVICE. SO PLEASE LISTEN TO
RESTRICTIONS ON THE PHONE AS WE
MAY HAVE. A TIME- THE- DELAY I
WOMAN MAINTAIN DECORUM DURING
THE HEARING AS IS CUSTOMARY AND
ANY IT INDIVIDUALS. WHO ARE
DISRUPTIVE MAY BE REMOVED FROM
THE REMOTE MEDIAN SERVICE FOR
HAVE THEIR COULDN'T CONNECTIONS
MUTED. WHILE EVERY EFFORT HAS
BEEN MADE TO STREAMLINE THE
HEARING PROCESS AND CONDUCT OUR
HEARING AIDS IN IN AS CLOSE TO
THE SAME MANNER AS CUSTOMARY.
THERE IS TIMES SEVEN FOR
JUSTIN'S FOR JUSTIN TO USE. OR
OUR NEW ONLINE TOOLS FOR
TECHNOLOGIES PLEASE BE
RESPECTFUL AND PATIENT SO ALL
INTERESTED PARTIES CAN BE HEARD.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. ON
NOVEMBER EIGHTEENTH TWENTY
NINETEEN THIS COMMITTEE HELD AN
EIGHT HOUR OVERSIGHT HEARING TO
BETTER UNDERSTAND WHAT EXACTLY
TRANSPIRED IN OCTOBER TWENTY
NINETEEN FOR THE USE OF
PROACTIVE POWER SHUT OFF EVENTS
RESULTED IN WIDESPREAD LOSS OF
POWER AFFECTING FORTY OF THE
STATE'S FIFTY EIGHT COUNTIES
THAT MORE THAN TWO MILLION
CUSTOMERS. THESE EVENTS
OCCURRED AFTER TWO DEVASTATING
YEARS OF WILDFIRES INCLUDING
FIRES IGNITED BY YOU TO
ELECTRIC UTILITY INFRASTRUCTURE
AND EQUIPMENT MOST NOTABLY THE
CAMPFIRE IN PARADISE. AT THE
NOVEMBER TWENTY NINETEEN
HEARING. FAR COMMITTEE HEARD
FROM THE STATE'S THREE LARGEST
ELECTRIC UTILITIES FROM WROTE
RELEVANT STATE AGENCIES FROM
AFFECT THE RESIDENCES
BUSINESSES DOWNSTREAM SERVICE
PROVIDERS AND CRITICAL
FACILITIES AMONG OTHERS. THE
HEARING FOCUSED ON LESSONS
LEARNED AND AREAS THAT MERIT
ADDITIONAL ATTENTION. NOW OVER
SIX MONTHS SINCE THE NOVEMBER%
HEARING AND ON THE CUSP OF THIS
YEAR'S WILDFIR SEASON THE NEED
TO ENSURE THE ELECTRIC
UTILITIES ARE BETTER PREPARED
FOR THE WILDFIRE SEASON IS EVEN
MORE CRITICALLY IMPORTANT. AND
SHELTERING IN PLACE ORDERS
WHICH HAVE LIMITED MOBILITY IN
ACTIVITY IN THE STATE DUE TO
CALL THE NINETEEN. GLOBAL
PANDEMIC. TODAY'S HEARING WILL
ALLOW MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE
TO RECEIVE AN UPDATE FROM THE
CALIFORNIA PUBLIC UTILITIES
COMMISSION ON SPECIFIC ACTIONS
TAKEN SINCE LAST FALL TO
IMPROVE THE ELECTRIC YOU TOO
CHILE'S PLANS AND OPERATIONS
INCLUDING THE RECENT REVIEW OF
THE UTILITIES WILDFIRE
MITIGATION PLANS. AND UPDATED
PROTOCOLS FOR USING PROACTIVE
POWER SHUT OUT POINT PUBLIC
SAFETY POWER SHOPS P. S. P. S.
ADDITIONALLY THE MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE WILL HEAR DIRECTLY
FROM THE THREE ELECTRIC
UTILITIES ABOUT THE STATUS. OF
THE IMPLEMENTATION OF THEIR
WELFARE MITIGATION PLANS AND
THE NEW GUIDELINES ON POWER
SHUT OFFS AS WELL AS HOW THE
UTILITIES ARE JUST TO THEIR
PLANS IN LIGHT OF THE COVERT
NINETEEN GLOBAL HEALTH
PANDEMICS. THE UPDATES PROVIDED
AT THE HEARING OR INTENDED TO
INFORM THE COMMITTEE MEMBERS
ABOUT THEM WHAT MIGHT BE
EXPECTED IN THIS YEAR'S
WILDFIRE SEASON AS COMPARED. TO
PAST YEARS TEND TO ENSURE WE
ARE APPLYING THE LESSON LEARNED
FROM THE RECENT PREVIOUS YEARS
EXPERIENCES. GIVEN THE
UNCERTAINTIES OF THE GLOBAL
PANDEMIC AND THE CONTINUED NEED
TO LIMIT SOCIAL CONGREGATING.
THE COMMITTEE WILL ALSO HEAR
FROM THE PUBLIC ADVOCATE'S
OFFICE OF THE CPUC IN
FULFILLMENT OF STATUTORY
REQUIRED ANNUAL UPDATE TO THIS
COMMITTEE. I WANT TO
ACKNOWLEDGE THAT WE HAVE TO
OVER MEMBERS JOIN A JOINING US
REMOTELY- WE HAVE SENATOR HILL
AND I BELIEVE SENATOR SKINNER.
US NOT YET CENTERS SKINNER IN
ADDITION TO THE MEMBERS HERE
PRESENT. IN THE CHAMBERS. SO
THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR
ALLOWING ME THIS INTRODUCTION
NOW- LET'S BEGIN WITH THE
PRESENTERS IF NOBODY HAS ANY
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS. I SHOULD
NOTE THAT- ALL THE PRISONERS
ARE PARTICIPATING REMOTELY AND
WE MAY BE ABLE TO OBSERVETHEM
ON THE SCREEN FOR FROM WHAT I
UNDERSTAND. WE WILL BEGIN WITH
THE CALIFORNIA PUBLIC UTILITIES
COMMISSION WE HAVE WITH US- THE
CPUC PRESIDENT BERUBAH MARABLE
BADGER. WE HAVE CAROLINE TIMES
JAKE JACOBS WHO IS THE DIRECTOR
OF THE WILD SAFETY DIVISION
WILD FIRE SAFETY DIVISION. AND
RACHEL PETERSON THE DEPUTY
EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR FOR SAFETY
ENFORCEMENT AND POLICY WELCOME
COMMISSIONER AND MEMBERS OF THE
P. IS SAFE THANK YOU FOR
JOINING US TODAY. AND LEASE-
BEGIN WITH A PRESENTATION. AND
SENATORS THANK YOU FOR INVITING
ME HERE TODAY. TO PARTICIPATE
IN THIS ANNUAL REPORT TO THE
LEGISLATURE AS STATED MY NAME
IS VERY WELL THAT YOU'RE AND I
SERVICE THE PRESIDENT OF THE
CALIFORNIA PUBLIC UTILITIES
COMMISSION. I AM JOINED TODAY
AS YOU MENTIONED MISTER CHAIR
BY MY COLLEAGUES CAROLINE
THOMAS JENKINS DIRECTOR WELFARE
SAFETY DIVISION RACHEL PETERSON
DIRECTOR EXPECT THAT MAKES
ACTIVE DIRECTOR FOR SAFETY
ENFORCEMENT POLICY EDWARD
RANDALL. DEPUTY EXECUTIVE
DIRECTOR FOR ENERGY AND CLIMATE
POLICY AND ROBERT OSBORNE
DIRECTOR OF COMMUNICATIONS
DIVISION. FIRST YOUR WAY SO I
WOULD LIKE TO THANK YOU THE
COMMITTEE MEMBERS AND THE
COMMITTEE STAFFER SUGGESTING WE
PURPOSE THIS REPORT ON THE
ISSUES THAT REQUIRE OUR MOST
IMMEDIATE ATTENTION GIVEN THE
CURRENT PANDEMIC. ECONOMIC
DESTRUCTION. AND THE UPCOMING
WILDFIRE SEASON. I WANTED
ASSURING MEMBERS THAT WE REMAIN
COMMITTED TO MOVING FORWARD ON
ISSUES THAT ARE CRITICAL TO THE
STATE. AS WE HAVE FAST TRACKED
EXIST ESTABLISHING NEW WELFARE
RELATED RULES AND ACTED TO
PROTECT CUSTOMERS THE FINANCIAL
IMPACTS OF THE PANDEMIC WE HAVE
CONTINUED OUR WORK ON
MAINTAINING ENERGY SYSTEM
RELIABILITY ENHANCING OUR
CLIMATE GOALS IN ON LET TRICITY
SECTOR. AND MANAGING THE
DECENTRALIZATION OF ELECTRICITY.
AND STILL THE ENHANCED
AUTHORITY TO REGULATE
COMMUNICATIONS SERVICE
PROVIDERS. BUT THAT WILL BEGIN
MY PRESENTATION THE ECONOMIC
DAMAGE BY COVE IN NINETEEN AND
THE SOCIAL INEQUITIES IT HAS
HIGHLIGHTED AS REQUIRED FOCUSED
AND TIMELY ACTION TO SUPPORT
THE FINANCIAL STABILITY OF
HOUSEHOLDS ACROSS OUR STATE. IT
HAS CALLED UPON US TO MOVE
QUICKLY TO MAINTAIN AND
INCREASE ACCESS TO UTILITIES
SERVICES THAT IT BECOMES MORE
ESSENTIAL DURING THE CURRENT
PUBLIC HEALTH CRISIS AS
FAMILIES MOVED TO SHELTER WORK
AND LEARN FROM HOME. IS
UNDERSTANDING LED TO OUR
PLACING AN IMMEDIATE MORATORIUM
ON ELECTRIC GAS COMMUNICATIONS
AND WATER AND SEWAGE
DISCONNECTIONS UNTIL APRIL
TWENTY TWENTY ONE. WE HAVE A WE
ALSO HAD A PROPOSED DECISION
REGARDING JUST CONNECTIONS ON
OUR JUNE ELEVENTH VOTING MEDIAN
AGENDA THAT WOULD OFFER
ADDITIONAL LONG TERM CUSTOMER
PROTECTION. AND IN AN EFFORT TO
PROTECT CUSTOMERS FROM HIGHER
BILLS YEAH INCREASED DEPENDENCY
AND USE OF CERTAIN UTILITIES
THE CDC HAS SOUGHT RATE RELIEF.
EASE OF MEASURES FOR INSTANCE
IN ORDER TO REDUCE SEASONAL
BILL UNTIL TODAY SDG AT EACH
CUSTOMER'S THE SEASONAL
DIFFERENTIAL HAS BEEN REMOVED
FROM THE RESIDENTIAL TIERED
RATES WE ALSO MADE ADJUSTMENTS
TO THE CALIFORNIA CLIMATE
CREDIT TO MINIMIZE THE RATE
SHOCK TO REPAIRS FOR THEIR
INCREASED ENERGY USE BY MOVING
CREDIT FOR P. JEANNIE AND SEP
FROMOCTOBER TO MAY AND JUNE.
WITH RESPECT TO THE CALIFORNIA
ALTERNATE RATES FOR ENERGY CARE
FAMILY ELECTRIC RATE ASSISTANCE
CHERUB PROGRAMS WE PROVIDED
DIRECTION TO THE UTILITIES ON
INCREASING OUTRAGE ON
ENROLLMENT AND OUR STAFF IS
WORKING WITH THE STATE AGENCIES
TO COORDINATE OUTRAGE WITH
PUBLIC BENEFIT PROGRAMS SUCH AS
CAL FRESH. IN A RELATED EFFORT
WE HAVE SOUGHT TO MAINTAIN WORK
FOR STABILITY I DIRECTED THE
UTILITIES TO MAKE ADVANCE.
PAYMENTS TO CONTRACTORS. ENERGY
IS UPGRADES AS OF THE ENERGY
SAY ASSISTANCE. IN THE AREA OF
COMMUNICATIONS WE HAVE ALSO
ACTED QUICKLY TO EXPAND ACCESS
TO SERVICES AND TECHNOLOGIES.
IN COLLABORATION WITH THE
GOVERNOR AND THE DEPARTMENT OF
EDUCATION WE ARE SUPPORTING K.
THROUGH TWELVE STUDENTS BY
PROVIDING FIVE MILLION FROM
DOLLARS FROM THE CALIFORNIA
ADVANCED SERVICES FUND TO HELP
COVER THE COST OF COMPUTING AND
HOT SPOT DEVICES. ALSO
PROVIDING TWENTY FIVE MILLION
FROM THE CALIFORNIA TELL
CONNECT FUND FOR HOT SPOTS IN
INTERNET SERVICE FOR STUDENTS
HOUSEHOLDS. THE CPUS ALSO
WORKING TO MAKE THE LIFELINE
PROGRAM MORE ACCESSIBLE BY
CONNECTING PROVIDERS WITH
VULNERABLE POPULATIONS AND
MAKING IT EASIER TO STAY ON BY
SUSPENDING PROGRAM RE
CERTIFICATIONS FOR NINETY DAYS.
I ALSO WANT TO HIGHLIGHT OUR
ENCOURAGEMENT OF THE VOLUNTARY
ACTIONS ON ISSUES CRITICAL TO
CUSTOMERS WE ASKED WIRELESS
CARRIERS AND INTERNET SERVICE
PROVIDERS TO ELIMINATE DATA
CAPS AND COVERAGE CHARGES.
EXCUSE ME OVERAGE CHARGES AS
WELL AS ENCOURAGE THE
AVAILABILITY OF LOW INCOME
BROADBAND SERVICE. BUILDING
NINETEEN HAS ALSO IMPACTED
OVERALL ENERGY USE WHICH WILL
ULTIMATELY HAVE AN IMPACT ON
RATES I WILL COVER THIS LATER
IN THE PRESENTATION. NOW I'D
LIKE TO TURN TO THE WORK WE'VE
DONE CAME OUT OF THE LAST HOUR
FIND LAST FALL'S WILDFIRE
SEASON AND THE UTILITIES USE OF
POWER SHUT US. DELIBERATE
ACTION RESULTED IN POWER BEING
MORE THAN. EXCUSE ME I JUST
LOST MY PLACE- LET ME BEGIN
AGAIN. NOW I'D LIKE TO TURN TO
THE POWER SHUT US AND ABOUT HER
SEASON IS THEN EIGHT MONTHS
MISTER CHAIR AS YOU HAD
MENTIONED SINCE THE GENIE
INITIATED THE LARGEST EVER
POWER SAFETY OUR SHOP YES YES
IN CALIFORNIA. P. GENIES
DELIBERATE ACTIONS RESULT IN
POWER BEING SHUT OFF TO MORE
THAN SEVEN HUNDRED CUSTOMERS
CENTER THOUSAND CUSTOMER
ACCOUNTS. WHICH IMPACTED MORE
THAN TWO MILLION PEOPLE AS YOU
NOTED MISTER CHAIR AFTER THAT
UNDER GATED CATASTROPHE MY
FELLOW COMMISSIONERS AND COMMIT
TO SUCH EVENTS NOT BECOMING THE
NEW NORMAL. MY COLLEAGUES
RACHEL PETERSON AND CAROLINE
THOMAS JACOBS WILL SPEAK TO THE
DETAILS OF THE VARIOUS MEASURES
WE HAVE TAKEN SINCE LAST
OCTOBER HOWEVER I'D LIKE TO
WALK YOU THROUGH SOME OF THEM
QUICKLY. ON MAY TWENTY EIGHTH
THE COMMISSION OF. NEW MAY THAT
WE THE TO BETTER. WITH IMPACTED
COMMUNITIES IN ADVANCE OF THE
TWENTY TWENTY WELL FIRST SEASON%
AND TO MINIMIZE THE DURATION
AND IMPACT OF THE P. S. P. S.
EVENTS WHEN CALLED. THE CIVIC
LIKE WE ARE REQUIRING UTILITIES
IF IT IS SAFE TO DO SO TO
RESTORE POWER AS SOON AS
POSSIBLE AND NO LONGER THAN
TWENTY FOUR HOURS. FOLLOWING
THE CONCLUSION OF THE P. S. TS
OF THAT. OUR ALSO REQUIRED TO
CONVENE REGIONAL ALLIES WORKING
GROUP'S WITH TRIBAL AND LOCAL
GOVERNMENT ENTITIES AND PUBLIC
SAFETY PARTNERS AND TO COURT
THANK ADVISORY. PUBLIC SAFETY
PARTNERS LOCAL AND TRIBAL
GOVERNMENT OFFICIALS BUSINESS
GROUP GROUPS NON PROFITS AND
ACADEMIC ORGANIZATIONS. THE
UTILITIES WILL ALSO CONDUCT PS
PS EXERCISES WITH PUBLIC SAFETY
AGENCIES INCLUDING CAL FIRE AND
CAL YES. THESE GUIDELINES ARE
NOW IN EFFECT AND REQUIRE
PROGRAMS SUPPORT FOR THE
UTILITIES WITHIN TWO MONTHS A
CRITICAL REQUIREMENT GIVEN THE
CONSIDERATION OF THE CURRENT
COLLUDED NINETEEN ENDEMIC.
AFTER CALLING IN COMMUNICATION
SERVICE PROVIDERS LAST NOVEMBER
TO QUESTION THEIR PERFORMANCE
DURING LAST OCTOBER'S PS PS
AGAINST WE INITIATED A
PROCEEDING TO IMPROVE THEIR
RESILIENCY PLANNING. ON MARCH
SIX I PROPOSED SEVERAL NEW
REQUIREMENTS AMONG THEM A
REQUIREMENT ON SITE FOR ON SITE
EMERGENCY BACKUP POWER TO
SUPPORT ALL ESSENTIAL
COMMUNICATIONS EQUIPMENT
NECESSARY TO MAINTAIN SERVICE
FOR A MINIMUM. OF SEVENTY TWO
HOURS IMMEDIATELY FOLLOWING A
POWER OUTAGE. IN ADDITION
PROVIDERS WOULD BE REQUIRED TO
SUBMIT EMERGENCY OPERATIONS
PLAN OUTLINED THE NECESSARY
STEPS TO PREPARE FOR A DISASTER
AND TO COMMUNICATE CRITICAL.
INFORMATION TO EMERGENCY
RESPONDERS AND TO THE PUBLIC
THE COMMISSION IS EXPECTED TO
VOTE ON THIS DECISION IN EARLY
JULY. ALSO DUE TO LAST
OCTOBER'S PS PS AGAINST OUR
MICROGRAMS PROCEEDING WAS RE
SCUTTLED LAST DECEMBER TO
INCLUDE WILDFIRE RESILIENCY AND
WAS FAST TRACKED. ON APRIL
TWENTY NINTH A PROPOSED
DECISION WAS ISSUE THAT
REQUIRES UTILITIES TO FURTHER
STANDARDIZE APPLICATIONS AND
EXPEDITE PROCESSES FOR PROJECT
APPROVALS. ACCELERATE
INTERCONNECTIONS OF PROJECTS
FOR KEY LOCATION CUSTOMERS AND
DISABILITIES. AND JUST TERRACE
TO BETTER VALUE RESILIENCY AND
ENHANCE COLLABORATION AND
COORDINATION WITH LOCAL AND
TRIBAL GOVERNMENTS. THIS
PROPOSAL IS EXPECTED TO BE
VOTED ON BY THE COMMISSION JUNE
ELEVENTH. LASTLY ON THE SUBJECT
I'D LIKE TO MENTION THAT ON
JANUARY SIXTEENTH WE APPROVED
EXPANSION OF THE SELF
GENERATION INCENTIVE PROGRAM
EXT YET YOUR BY DIRECT FUNDING
FOR BATTERY BACKUP SYSTEMS WITH
A FOCUS ON ACT RESPECTFUL
ASIANS AND CRITICAL COMMUNITY
FACILITIES. IN AREAS. LIKE TO
TALK ABOUT ELECTRICITY RATES
AND IDENTIFY A NUMBER OF
FACTORS THAT WE PROJECT WILL
INCREASE RATES ON A PASTOR
TRAJECTORY THAN IN THE PAST.
HISTORICALLY RATE INCREASES
HAVE TRACKED VERY CLOSELY WITH
THE RATE OF INFLATION FOR P.
JEANNIE AND SEP BUT THE TREND
HAS NOT HELD TRUE FOR S. D. G.
ET. IN RECENT YEARS SEG ANY
RATES ROSE WHAT ABOUT THE OTHER
UTILITIES DUE TO A NUMBER OF
FACTORS INCLUDING SDG IS A
ROBUST INVESTMENT IN WELFARE
MITIGATION AFTER THE TWO
THOUSAND SEVEN WILDFIRES IN ITS
SERVICE TERRITORY. WE EXPECT TO
SEE SOMEONE TRENDS WITH ALL THE
UTILITIES AS THEYHAVE PROPOSED
INVESTING MORE THAN FIFTEEN
MILLION DOLLARS IN WELFARE
MITIGATION EVERS BETWEEN TWENTY
TWENTY AND TWENTY TWENTY THREE.
OUR CALCULATIONS ESTIMATE THAT
FOR EVERY BILLION DOLLARS IN
WELFARE MITIGATION SPENDING
FIVE P. GINNY FOR EXAMPLE WE
CAN EXPECT A 728% INCREASE IN
RESIDENTIAL CUSTOMER BILLS.
WHICH IS EQUIVALENT TO ABOUT A
NINETY DOLLAR INCREASE IN
CUSTOMERS ANNUAL ANNUAL BILLS
STARTING TWENTY TWENTY ONE. FOR
S. C. E. IT WOULD BE THE COLOR
OF SEVENTY DOLLARS PER YEAR
INCREASED AND FOR S. T. G. E.
THE EQUIVALENT OF TWENTY FOUR
DOLLARS PER YEAR INCREASE.
WHILE THEIR MEDICATION COSTS
ARE NOT THE ONLY FACTOR HOWEVER
THAT WE PROJECTED PUT FORWARD
PRESSURE ON. ON CUSTOMER BILLS.
THE TAX CODE WITH NINETEEN ARMY
ECONOMY AND ON CALIFORNIA'S
FINANCIAL STABILITY IS ALSO
LIKELY TO HAVE AN IMPACT. WELL
WE ARE STILL EARLY IN
UNDERSTANDING THE IMPACTS OUR
ENERGY DIVISION IS WORKING WITH
UTILITIES TO UNDERSTAND THE
POTENTIAL SIZE OF THE IMPACT.
WELL RESIDENTIAL CUSTOMERS ARE
USING MORE ENERGY WORKING AND
LEARNING FROM HOME THAN BEFORE
CO HEAD NINETEENTH OVERALL
DEMAND FOR ELECTRICITY IS DOWN
AND UTILITIES ARE NOT
COLLECTING THE REVENUE THEY
NEED TO COVER THEIR COSTS.
EARLY ESTIMATES SHOW THAT THE
UTILITIES ARE COLLECTING
BETWEEN TEN AND 20% LESS THAN
WHAT THEY HAD PREVIOUSLY.
FORECAST IT. WHEN YOU. AFTER
THE COVER THIS UNDER THROUGH
RAY SO UNDER COLLECTION INTO
TWENTY COULD BE RECOVERED TO
INCREASES IN RATES IN TWENTY
TWENTY ONE AND TWENTY TWENTY
TWO FOR UNDER COLLECTIONS DUE
TO PAY BILLS WE DO NOT YET HAVE
A CLEAR PICTURE OF THE
POTENTIAL AS OF THE STATE. WE
DO HOWEVER HAVE A PROCESS FOR
HANDLING YOU ARE GENERAL RATE
CASE PROCESS. THE C. P. U. C.
COULD REDUCE THE IMPACTS OF THE
COSTS OF THE PANDEMIC BY
ADVERTISING A COLLECTION OF
THESE COSTS OVER LONG PERIODS
OF TIME BUT THESE ACTIONS WILL
LIKELY HAVE THE IMPACT OF
INCREASING THE UTILITIES THAT.
AND THEIR COST TO BORROW MONEY
WHICH IN THE END RESULT IN EVEN
BIGGER RATE INCREASES. FINALLY
I'D LIKE TO ADDRESS THE CBC'S
ROLE IN THE P. GENIES
BANKRUPTCY CASE. HOWEVER SINCE
ALL OF THIS INFORMATION IS
PUBLIC I WILL KEEP MY REMARKS
VERY BRIEF. PURSUANT TO A. B.
TEN FIFTY FOUR THE CPUC ADOPTED
AND DECISION APPROVING WITH
CONDITIONS HE GINNY'S PLAN OF
REORGANIZATION LAST THURSDAY
MAY TWENTY EIGHT. IN ADOPTING
THE DECISION THE CBC'S FOCUS
WAS INSURING THAT WHILE FIRE
VICTIMS ARE COMPENSATED. THAT
THE PLAN IS A RATE PAYER NEW.
AND THE P. GENIES CUSTOMERS
RECEIVE SAFE. RELIABLE SERVICE
AT REASONABLE RATES CONSISTENT
WITH CALIFORNIA'S CLIMATE GOALS.
I WOULD LIKE TO BRIEFLY TOUCH
ON THE MAIN ELEMENTS OF THE
DECISION THAT ARE FOCUSED ON
IMPROVING SAFETY AND
ACCOUNTABILITY. THE DECISION
REQUIRES CHANGES IN P. GENIES
GOVERNANCE MANDATES REGIONAL
RESTRUCTURING AND A LOCAL
OPERATING REGION'S. PUTS IN
PLACE AN INDEPENDENT MONITOR
THE REPORTS DIRECTLY TO THE CDC
AND PUTS IN PLACE AN ENHANCED
OVERSIGHT PROCESS THAT DEFINES
ENFORCEMENT ACTIONS TAKEN.
INDICATION OF THE P. GENIES
AUTHORITY TO OPERATE. IT ALSO
MAKES DETERMINATIONS TO PROTECT
RATE PAYERS FIVE FUND FINDING
THAT P. GINNY'S PLAN OF
REORGANIZATION IS RIGHT NEUTRAL
ON AVERAGE AND REQUIRES P.
GINNY TO HONOR ITS COMMITMENT
TO NOT BURDEN RATE PAYERS WAS
COST FROM PRE TWENTY NINE. OH
HIRES. THE DECISION DOES NOT
MARK THE END OF OUR WORK TO
PUSH P. GINNY TO MAKE
SIGNIFICANT IMPROVEMENTS IN HOW
IT PRIORITIZES CUSTOMERS AND
SAFETY. WORK WILL BE ON GOING
IN OUR SAFETY CULTURE
PROCEEDING AND OTHER NEW
PROCEEDINGS TO FURTHER DEVELOP
SAFETY AND OPERATIONAL MAT
MATRIX AMONG OTHERS. WITH
MISTER CHAIR AND SENATORS I'D
LIKE TO THANK YOU AGAIN FOR THE
INVITATION TO SPEAK TODAY AND
ALLOW ME TO ADDRESS WHAT ARE
JUST A SUBSET OF THE CRITICAL
ISSUES THE CDC IS CURRENTLY
ADDRESSING. AND OF COURSE I'M
TO TAKE YOUR QUESTIONS. I THINK
THIS PETERSON IS NEXT ON THE
AGENDA. THANK YOU VERY MUCH I
WANT TO ASK OKAY SHE'S GONNA
PICTURES AND GO AHEAD. I'LL GO
AHEAD SENATOR KERRY CAN- TO SEE
IF ANYONE HAS QUESTIONS FOR THE
PRESIDENT. YES SO WE HAVE WE
WILL HAVE QUESTIONS AND PRETTY
SURE I KNOW I DO I WANTED TO
ASK A- DISPATCHER. IN
PARTICULAR RELATED TO THE
UTILITIES AND THE FIRES. AND
THE SHOT OFFICE- OR OR THE
ELECTRIC UTILITIES ESPECIALLY
PGA ANY ADEQUATELY PREPARED.
FOR THIS YEAR'S WILDFIRE SEASON
WHAT- CAN WE EXPECT THIS YEAR.
COMPARED TO THE PAST YEARS.
MISTER CHAIRMAN- BOTH MISS
PETERSON AND HIS TIMES JACOBS
HAVE IN THERE- PRESENTATIONS
WILL BE MORE WILL CERTAINLY GO
THROUGH WHAT THE PS PS- LOOKS
LIKE FOR THE THREE UTILITIES
RIGHT NOW AS WELL AS ALLOW HER
MITIGATION PLAN. SO WE'RE GONNA
MAYBE THAT ALL OF YOU CAN MAKE
YOUR PRESENTATIONS AND THEN
WE'LL COME BACK TO DO QUESTIONS
A SHARE AND MAYBE YOU CAN COVER
THAT IN AND YOUR PRESENTATION
IT COMES. ALL RIGHT VERY. THANK
YOU DR AND THANK YOU CHAIR
HUESO AND MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE. MY NAME IS RACHEL
PETERSON I'M THE DEPUTY
EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR FOR SAFETY
ENFORCEMENT AND POLICY AT THIS
YOU SEE. AND TODAY I WOULD LIKE
TO ADDRESS OUR ACTIONS SINCE
LAST FALL INTO QUESTIONS OF. IN
THIS FOR PUBLIC SAFETY SET US
THIS YEAR. EVEN AS WE DISCUSS
READY MISS I WANT TO BE VERY
CLEAR ABOUT THAT DOWN AT THE
DYNAMIC THE CDC IS THE
REGULATOR OF THE UTILITIES. WE
SET THE RULES AND STANDARDS
THAT THEY MUST MEET. ELECTRIC
UTILITIES ARE THE OPERATORS OF
THEIR SYSTEMS THEY KNOW OUR
RULES AND STANDARDS AND IT IS
UP TO THEM TO ACHIEVE READING
THISBEFORE THEY CHOOSE TO
CONDUCT THE FIRST P. S. F.
LANCE OF TWENTY TWENTY. ACTIVE
TERRITORY. IT'S ALL UP TO THE
TO MAKE SAFE OPERATE DECISIONS
BEFORE DURING AND AFTER THE
EVENTS. FIRST A LITTLE BIT
ABOUT OUR OVERSIGHT ACTION SO
FAR IN THE PAST SEVERAL MONTHS-
SINCE FEBRUARY WE HAVE MET
WEEKLY IN DETAIL MEETINGS WITH
P. JEANNIE IN PARTICULAR ABOUT
THE PROGRESS UNDER THEIR
CORRECTIVE ACTION PLANS. THERE
BY REPORTS ARE ON OUR TO SEE IF
UC'S WEBSITE FOR ANYONE TO VIEW.
WITH CAL FIRE AND CAL- YES
WE'VE ALSO HELD A DETAILED
BRIEFINGS FROM THE OTHER FIVE
ELECTRIC UTILITIES. SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA EDISON SDG AND E.
BEAR VALLEY PACIFICORP AND
LIBERTY ABOUT THEIR BE AS
PRETTY AS **** PREPARATIONS.
INCLUDING. HOW THEY ADJUSTED
FOR KOBE NINETEEN. I WANT. THE
THREE LARGE U. STATE OF
READINESS. HE JENNY AS OF TODAY
MY OBSERVATION IS THAT P. GENIE
IS MAKING PROGRESS TOWARDS
READINESS WE HAVE SOME MAJOR IF.
THE VERY BIGGEST QUESTION WILL
BE WHETHER THE COMPANY CAN
BRING ALL OF THEIR LINES OF
EFFORT TOGETHER INTO A SMART
AND COMPETENT EXT IN THIS YEAR.
FIRST I WANT TO TOUCH ON THEIR
COMMUNITY AND PUBLIC SAFETY
PARTNER OUTREACH NOTIFICATION
AND ENGAGEMENT. HE JENNY HAS
HELD TWENTY SIX BRIEFING
SESSIONS ONLINE WITH COUNTY
LOCAL AND TRIBAL GOVERNMENT
REPRESENTATIVES OUT OF THE
FORTY SEVEN COUNTIES IN THEIR
SERVICE TERRITORY. ADDRESSING
ELEMENTS OF READING THIS IN
EACH COUNTY OUR STAFF HAS
MONITORED ALL TWENTY SIX
SESSIONS TO DATE AND WILL
CONTINUE TO DO SO. HE JENY IS
THING A PUBLIC SAFETY
SPECIALIST IN EACH COUNTY. THIS
WAS A HUGE PAIN POINT FOR
COUNTIES IN TWENTY NINETEEN
BECAUSE THE INDIVIDUALS THEN
DEDICATED. COULD NOT MEANING
FULLY COMMUNICATE WITH P.
GENIES EMERGENCY OPERATIONS
CENTER. THE COMPANY INTENDS TO
TRAIN THE PUBLIC SAFETY
SPECIALIST AS EMERGENCY
MANAGEMENT IS ON. HOWEVER THEY
ARE STILL IN THE PROCESS OF
BEING HIRED AND SO THEIR
TRAINING AND PERFORMANCE IS A
SIGNIFICANT IF. WE HAVE PUT YOU
NEED TO COMPLETE THEIR USABLE
LIST OF CRITICAL FACILITIES AND
MEDICAL BASELINE CUSTOMERS.
THEIR DATA PORTAL JUST BECAME
LIVE RECENT WEEKS AFTER SOME
TECHNICAL DELAYS. THIS IS AN
AREA IN WHICH- BECAUSE OF THOSE
DELAYS HE JENNY CANNOT AFFORD
TO LOSE ANY FURTHER TIME. THE
COMPANY HAS IMPROVED ITS
WEBSITE CAPACITY SINCE TWENTY
NINETEEN. THE CALIFORNIA
DEPARTMENT OF TECHNOLOGY IS
CONDUCTING A FINAL WORD VIEW OF
THEIR DESIGN AND CAPACITY
TOMORROW JUNE FIFTH AND WE WILL
BE PART OF THAT REVIEW. AS TO
KEEP THE RESOURCES RESOURCE
CENTERS HE JENNY IS WORKING ON
PARALLEL PLANS FOR HARD DECIDED
C. R. C.'S. AS WELL AS OPEN AIR
TENDS AND BANDS GIVEN THE
CONTINUED PRESENCE OF CODE
NINETEEN. AND DIFFERENT PHASES
OF RE OPENING IN DIFFERENT
COUNTIES. AS OF MAY TWENTY SIX
THE COMPANY REPORTED THAT IT
HAS FIVE HARD SIDED SITES EVEN
READY OUT OF ONE HUNDRED AND
TWELVE THAT IT IS TARGETING TO
COMPLETE. SO CLEARLY THE
COMPANY STILL HAS A LOT OF WORK
TO DO. AT THE SAME TIME THEY
HAVE CONTRACTED WITH THIRTY
BANDS WHICH COULD PROVIDE SOME
RELIEF. IF THEY CALL A P. S. P.
S. EVENT IN THE NEAR FUTURE.
SECOND I'LL TOUCH ON THEIR
GREED IMPROVEMENTS AND
SITUATIONAL AWARENESS. THEY'RE
TARGETING INSTALLATION OF FIVE
HUNDRED AND NINETY TWO
SEXUALIZED DEVICES BY SEPTEMBER
FIRST. THEY DID FALL BEHIND IN
THIS EFFORT AND YET IF THEY
CONTINUE TO MEET MONTHLY
TARGETS THEY SHOULD HAVE THOSE
DEVICES INSTALLED BY SEPTEMBER
ONE. THEY'VE CONTRACTED WITH
SEVERAL PROVIDERS A BACKUP
GENERATION FOR DEPLOYMENT AT
SUBSTATIONS AND C. R. C.'S SO
THAT TARGETED PROCUREMENT IS
COMPLETE. HOWEVER AS OF TODAY
NONE OF THE BACK OF UNITS ARE
OPERATIONALLY READY. HERRING TO
RELIEVE BUT CANNOT LOSE TIME
THAT EFFORT. THEY HAVE EXCEEDED
THEIR ORIGINAL TARGET OF TWENTY
THREE TRANSMISSIONS. WITH
TWENTY SEVEN INSTALLED TODAY IF
PROPERLY DEPLOYED THOSE
SWITCHES SHOULD REDUCE THE
SCOPE OF YES YES. SO IN SOME I
WOULD OBSERVE AGAIN THAT P.
GENIE IS MAKING PROGRESS TOWARD
READY NEST WITH SOME MAJOR IFS
AND THE BIGGEST QUESTION WILL
BE WHETHER THEY CAN BRING ALL
OF THEIR LINES OF EFFORT
TOGETHER INTO A SMART AND
COMPETENT EXECUTION. I'LL TALK
ABOUT SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA
EDISON. ON MAY TWENTY FIFTH
LAST WEEK EDISON NOTED THE CPU
NOTIFIED THE SEE IF YOU SEE
AFTER PUBLIC SAFETY PARTNERS
OTHER POTENTIAL P. S. P. AS A
VENDOR ON SATURDAY MAY TWENTY
NINTH AFFECTING A POTENTIAL
FOUR THOUSAND SIX HUNDRED
CUSTOMERS. I PARTICIPATED IN
DAILY THINGS- WITH THE COMPANY
AND CAN REPORT THAT THEIR
NOTIFICATIONS AND BRIEFINGS TO
PUBLIC SAFETY PARTNERS OCCURRED
AT THE REQUIRED CADENCE AND
WERE INFORMATIVE THEY
IDENTIFIED AND CONFIRMED
CONTACT WITH SEVENTEEN MEDICAL
FLIGHT CUSTOMERS THEY CONSULTED
WITH THEIR COUNTY EMERGENCY
MANAGERS FROM MONO INYO COUNTY.
YET THE CASE. THERE CAN
RESOURCE VAN. AND THEY USE NEXT
FACEBOOK AND THEIR WEBSITE FOR
NOTIFICATIONS THAT INCLUDED
MESSAGING- INCLUDED MESSAGING
ABOUT SOCIAL DISTANCING. THERE
WAS NO DE ENERGIES ASIAN IN THE
END OF LAST WEEKEND AND SINCE
IT TURNED OUT TO BE A TRIAL
EVENT IT ALLOWED US TO OBSERVE
THEIR STATE OF READINESS WELL
THEY DIDN'T DEMONSTRATE READING
AS LAST WEEK WE ARE TRACKING
THE COMPANY FOR OVER
NOTIFICATIONS WHICH WAS A
SIGNIFICANT PROBLEM IN THEIR
EXECUTION IN TWENTY NINETEEN.
WE'RE ALSO IN THE GYM WITH THEM
IN DISCUSSIONS ALONG WITH CAL
FIRE AND CAL- YES. ABOUT THE
COMPANY'S THRESHOLD FOR CALLING
A PSP AS EVENT REMEMBERING THE
THESE ARE MEANTTO BE ADVANCE
OF LAST RESORT. LAUGHTER TURNED
AS THE GENIE. THIS COMPANY
BECAUSE OF THAT- WILDFIRES
STARTING IN TWO THOUSAND SEVEN.
HAS THE MOST YEARS OF
EXPERIENCE WITH PS PS. AT
PRESENT THEIR PLANS AND THEIR
SITUATIONAL AWARENESS AND THEIR
TECHNOLOGY ADVANCEMENT ALL
APPEARS SOLID AND THEY APPEAR
READY AGAIN EXECUTIONS WILL BE
THE TRUE TEST. WE WILL BE
CONTINUING DISCUSSIONS WITH SDG
IN THE TO ENSURE THAT THEIR
DECISION MAKING AS WELL ABOUT
WHEN TO CALL A PS PS EVENT
REMAINS FOCUSED ON USING IT AS
A LAST RESORT. AND CONSIDERING
ALL OTHER ALTERNATIVES FIRST.
THAT CONCLUDES MY REMARKS AND-
EITHER HAPPY TO ANSWER
QUESTIONS OR TURN IT TO
CAROLINE THOMAS JACOBS THANK
YOU. YES REMOTE OVER TO A
CAROLINE I'M SORRY TO RICHARD
PETERSON. RIGHT YEAH. OKAY
SORRY UNTIL THE LINE THOMAS
SORRY. THANK YOU THANK YOU
DEPUTY DIRECTOR DIRECTOR
PEARSON AND GOOD MORNING CHAIR
AND COMMITTEE MEMBERS I
APPRECIATE THE OPPORTUNITY TO
HAVE A CHANCE TO BRIEF YOU ON
OUR PROGRESS ESTABLISHING WATER
PARKS EACH DIVISION IN OUR
MISSION TO DRIVE REDUCTION IN
UTILITY RELATED WILDFIRE RISK.
BUILDING UPON IS PETERSON'S
TESTIMONY AND THE EFFORTS UNDER
WAY TO ENSURE UTILITIES
MINIMIZE OUR USE OF PUBLIC
SAFETY POWER SHUT OFF AND THE
WILD CARDS THE DIVISIONS
PURPOSE TO ENSURE UTILITIES
DEVELOP AND IMPLEMENT A LONG
TERM STRATEGY TO REDUCE OUR
RISK OUR PRIMARY VEHICLE TO
DRIVE THIS UTILITIES LONG TERM
PLANNING IS OUR OVERSIGHT OF
THE WATER MITIGATION PLANS. YOU
KNOW THAT IF IT IS THE MANDATED
A ONE ELEVEN AB TEN FIFTY FOUR
AND WE ARE STATUTORILY REQUIRED
TO PERFORM SEVERAL CORE
FUNCTIONS. NEYVELI EVALUATION-
FOR AN APPROVAL OR DENIAL OF
THE CORPORATIONS. WHILE
PERMITTING ASIAN PLANS
INSURANCE CLIENTS TO THOSE
PLANS. REVIEWING IN ISSUING
SUBSEQUENT SAY TO CERTIFICATES.
AS WELL AS SEVERAL OTHER
SUPPORTING RESPONSIBILITIES. WE
WERE ESTABLISHED AS OF JANUARY
ONE OF THIS YEAR. AND TODAY WE
HAVE HIRED AN EQUIPPED OUR
DIVISION STAFF AND CONTINUE TO
RECRUIT FOR THE REMAINING OPEN
POSITIONS. WE RELEASED NEW
TWENTY TWENTY WHAT FAR
MITIGATION PLANNING GUIDELINES
THAT SIGNIFICANTLY RAISE THE
EXPECTATIONS ON THE UTILITIES
FOR THE LEVEL OF DETAIL IN THE
JUSTIFICATION WITHIN THEIR
PLANS. ON MAY SEVENTH WE
RELEASED OUR DRAFT EVALUATIONS
OF THE TWENTY TWENTY PLANS.
SUBMITTED BY THE EIGHT INVESTOR
OWNED UTILITIES WE'RE REVIEWING
POP. ASIANS WILL BE ISSUING OUR
FINAL DETERMINATIONS BY JUNE
TENTH. IN ORDER TERMINATION
WILL BE PUT BEFORE THE
COMMISSION FOR RATIFICATION ON
JUNE ELEVENTH. AS I MENTIONED
EARLIER WE MADE SIGNIFICANT
ENHANCEMENTS TO HOW WE
STRUCTURE THE WATER MITIGATION
PLAN GUIDELINES THIS YEAR TO
DRIVE DEVELOPMENT PLANS THAT
INCLUDE RISK AND DATA INFORM
JUSTIFICATION. OUR OBJECTIVES
FOR THE NEW GUIDELINES WERE TO
INCREASE STANDARDIZATION.
IMPROVE OBJECTIVITY AND FRAME
OF FORWARD LOOKING FOCUS
pWHILE APARTMENT MITIGATION.
MATURITY MODEL TO DRIVE
UTILITIES TO BUILD AN EFFECTIVE
RISK REDUCTION CAPABILITIES AND
TRACK THE IMPROVEMENT OF THOSE
CAPABILITIES OVER TIME. WHEN
EVALUATING THE PLANS THAT
DIDN'T CONSIDER FOUR FACTORS
COMPLETENESS. TECHNICAL
FEASIBILITY EFFECTIVENESS BUT
USE THE RESOURCES AND FORWARD
LOOKING GROWTH. THE DIVISION
ISSUE DRAFT ACTION STATEMENTS
APPROVING THE EIGHT ELECTRICAL
CORPORATION PLANS SIX OF THOSE
APPROVALS ARE CONDITION ON THE
UTILITY RESOLVING A NUMBER OF
DEFICIENCIES WITHIN THEIR CLASS.
BEFORE I GET INTO THE
ASSESSMENT ABOUT PLANS I WOULD
LIKE TO MENTION THE BACK IN
MARCH GIVEN THE POPE IN
NINETEEN IMPACTS TO OUR
COMMUNITIES. WE RECOGNIZE WE
COULD NOT LET ONE DISASTER
DISTRACT US FROM PREPARING FOR
ANOTHER. SPECIFICALLY PREPARED
FOR WILDFIRES. ON MARCH TWENTY
SEVENTH WEEK ISSUED A JOINT
LETTER TO THE UTILITIES ALONG
WITH CALLAWAY GAS AND CAL FIRE
IN WHICH WE STATE OUR
EXPECTATIONS. THAT THE THAT THE
UTILITIES CONTINUE TO
PRIORITIZE A CENTRAL WILDFIRE
SEE IF YOU WORK WHILE
MINIMIZING THE IMPACT OF OUT
HIS ON CUSTOMERS. WHO WERE NOW
WORKING AND LEARNING FROM HOME.
AND WHILE THE DELICATE BALANCE
WE'VE ENSURE THE UTILITIES
CONTINUE EXECUTING ON THEIR
PROJECTS TO REDUCE WILDFIRE
RISK FOR THIS YEAR. AS FOR OUR
ASSESSMENT OF THE PLANS ALL OF
THE TWENTY TWENTY PLANS GIVEN
THE NEW GUIDELINES WERE
STRONGER THAN THEIR TWENTY
NINETEEN PLANTS. AND ARTICULATE
A THREE YEAR DIRECTIONALLY
FOCUSED STRATEGY TO YOU REDUCE
UTILITY RELATED WILDFIRE RISK.
WITH THE NEW GUIDELINES EACH OF
THE UTILITIES SUBMITTED DATA
DEMONSTRATING THAT THEY HAVE AN
UNDERSTANDING OF THEIR TOP
IGNITION DRIVERS AND ARTICULATE
THE MADE MITIGATION STRATEGIES
AND INITIATIVES. THEY HAVE OR
ARE DEVELOPING TO ADDRESS THOSE
IGNITION DRIVERS. FOR EXAMPLE
P. JEANNIE OUTLINED INITIATIVES
THAT ARE FOCUSED ON REDUCING
THEIR TOP TWO IGNITION DRIVERS
WHICH ARE CONTACT FROM OBJECT
AT 56% AND EQUIPMENT FAILURE AT
37% THE P. GENIES ADDRESS IN
CONTACT WITH COVERED CONDUCTOR
ENHANCE VEGETATION MANAGEMENT
PROTOCOLS AND A NUMBER OF
SYSTEM HARDENING EFFORTS SUCH
AS REPLACING POLES PARK AND
TARGETED UNDER RUNNING. I LIVE
THIS TUESDAY IN THEIR ENHANCE
VEGETATION MANAGEMENT PROGRAM
P. JEANNIE REPORTED THEY'VE
COMPLETED FIVE HUNDRED AND
FIFTY NINE MILES OF THEIR PLAN
EIGHTEEN HUNDRED MILES FOR
CLEARING THE ADDITIONAL TWELVE
FOOT RADIUS. THEY'RE ALSO
INSTALLING AS MS PETERSON
MENTIONED FIVE HUNDRED NINETY
TWO SEXUALIZED AND DEVICES AND
HAVE- COMPLETED TODAY TWENTY
SEVEN TRANSMISSION LINES WHICH
IS WHICH WILL LESSEN THE IMPACT
OF POTENTIAL OUT OF. ON
CUSTOMERS. AS FOR SAN DIEGO GAS
ELECTRIC IN SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA
EDISON. THEY ALSO OUTLINED WILD
FIRE MITIGATION PROGRAMS THAT
ADDRESS THEIR MAJOR RISK
DRIVERS IN THEIR SERVICE
ALLOCATED OVER 40% OF THEIR
PLAN SPEND TO COVER CONDUCTOR.
AND IS DEPLOYING SEVEN HUNDRED
CIRCUIT MILES OF CUT IT COVERED
CONDUCTOR IN TWENTY TWENTY WITH
THE TARGET OF FORTY FIVE
HUNDRED CIRCUIT MILES BY THE
END OF TWENTY TWENTY TWO INTO
THE THREE YEAR PLAN. HER EYES
AND- DUE TO THIS LARGE
INVESTMENT WE HAVE ASKED FOR
MORE JUSTIFICATION WITHIN ONE
OF THEIR DEFICIENCIES. THEY'RE
ALSO ADDING FIRE RESIST WRAPS
TO PROTECT POLLS. INSTALLING
COMPOSITE POLES AND EXPANDING
THEIR FUTURE PLACEMENT
CENTRALIZATION EFFORTS. SAN
DIEGO CONTINUES TO EXPLORE NEW
EMERGING TECHNOLOGIES INCLUDING
AN LP E. INSTALLING AN LTE
COMMUNICATION NETWORK THAT WILL
ENABLE AUTOMATIC AND REMOTE
CONTROL THEIR GRADING IS ADDING
THIRTY MORE SEXUALIZED DEVICES
AND TWENTY SEVEN WEATHER
STATIONS. AND HAS A NEW
SATELLITE BASED HOT SPOT
ALERTING CAPABILITY THAT
ENABLES QUICK IDENTIFICATION
AND RESPONSE TO PUT FIRES OUT
BEFORE THEY GET BIG. ALL OF
THIS WORK WILL DRIVE DOWN OUR
SHARED UTILITY WILDFIRE RISK
THERE REMAIN HOWEVER HOWEVER A
SIGNIFICANT NUMBER OF
DEFICIENCIES IN THEIR WATER
MITIGATION PLANS THAT MUST BE
ADDRESSED BEFORE WE HAVE FULL
CONFIDENCE THE PLANS ARE TO
KELLY. PRIORITIZED WILDFIRE
MITIGATION INVESTMENTS THAT BY
DOWN THE MOST REX. COMMON
DEFICIENCIES INCLUDED RISK
ASSESSMENTS THERE'S A LITTLE
DISCUSSION ON HOW THE RISK
MODELS ASSESSED CONSEQUENCES OF
A GIVEN IGNITION. ALSO
EQUIVOCATING LANGUAGE THE ARE
YOU OFTEN AVOIDED MAKING
QUANTIFIABLE MEASURABLE AND
VERIFIABLE COMMITMENTS TO
SPECIFIC MISSION IS A SPECIAL
OUTCOME METRICS. IN TOTAL WE
IDENTIFIED A HUNDRED AND FIVE
EFFICIENCIES ACROSS THE
UTILITIES INCLUDING TWENTY NINE
PER P. JEANNIE TWENTY TWO FOR
CALIFORNIA EDISON AND SIXTEEN
FOR SAN DIEGO GAS ELECTRIC. I
ALSO FOUND TWELVE DEFICIENCIES
THAT APPLY ACROSS THE
UTILITIES. FOR EACH OF THESE
DEFICIENCIES WE HAVE PLACED A
CONDITION ON THE UTILITY TO
RESOLVE THE DEFICIENCY WITHIN A
SPECIFIC AMOUNT OF TIME. BUT
THE PLANS ARE JUST ABOUT A
PLAN. THE TRUE REDUCTION RISK
WILL COME FROM THE EXECUTION OF
THESE PLANS WHICH WE WILL HOLD
THEM ACCOUNTABLE TO THROUGH OUR
COMPLIANCE ACTIVITIES. HE
WATER SAFETY DIVISION
COMPLIANCE BRANDS HAS AS A
BURLY MAY BE GONE PROACTIVE
FIELD INSPECTIONS ON WATER
MITIGATION ACTIVITIES. WITH A
PRIORITY ON SYSTEM HARDENING
VEGETATION MANAGEMENT AND PS PS
REDUCTION INSPECTIONS. WE'VE
COMPLETED FIVE HUNDRED NINE
INSPECTIONS TO DATE. AND ON
TRACK TO COMPLETE MORE THAN TWO
THOUSAND INSPECTIONS BY THE END
OF THIS YEAR. THROUGH THESE
INSTRUCTIONS WE FOUND SIXTEEN
THE FAX INCLUDING HAZARD TREES
WITHIN CONTACT RANGE OF WIRES
BUT IF YOU CAN CONTACT ON GUY
WIRES AND EXTENSIVE WOODPECKER
DAMAGE ON POLLS. WE HAVE
NOTIFIED THE UTILITY OF THESE
DEFECTS AND WILL HOLD THEM
ACCOUNTABLE TO RESULTING IN A
TIMELY MANNER. INCLUDING THE
TWENTY TWENTY WATER MITIGATION
PLANS AND THE ASSOCIATED DATA
WE REQUIRED WITH THEM ARE A
MARKED IMPROVEMENT. OVER LAST
YEAR. THE VAST AMOUNT OF DATA
PROVIDED BY THE UTILITIES IS
ENABLING US TO DIG INTO THE
DETAIL AND PUSH THEM. INTO THE
DETAILS ON WHY HOW AND WHERE
THEY NEED TO FOCUS THEIR TIME
AND RESOURCES TO DRIVE
REDUCTION IN WALL VIRUS. AS
WITH MOST THINGS HOWEVER THE
MORE WE HAVE ASKED FOR THE MORE
WE FIND THAT WE NEED TO PUSH
THE UTILITIES TO ENSURE THEY
ARE ASKING THE RIGHT QUESTIONS
AND TAKING THE TIME TO
STRATEGICALLY THINK THROUGH.
HOW BEST TO INVEST THE
RESOURCES TO REDUCE WILDFIRE
RISK. OUR INTENT GOING FORWARD
IS TO PUT CONTINUE TO PUSH THE
UTILITIES. TO PROVE THEIR
CAPABILITIES. TO UNDERSTAND AND
MITIGATE THAT RISK AND BUILD
OUR OWN CAPABILITIES WITHIN THE
WALLS. OF OUR CITY DIVISION TO
ENSURE WE ARE PROP WE CAN
PROPERLY ASSESS AND HOLD THE
UTILITIES ACCOUNTABLE TO
MEETING THEIR COMMITMENTS. TO
REDUCING WILD VIRUS THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH AND- I HAD
QUESTIONS RELATED TO. ONGOING
IMPROVEMENTS DURING THE
PANDEMIC IN THAT QUESTION WAS
ANSWERED ANSWERED I ALSO HAD.
BUT THE QUESTION REGARDING TO
IMPLEMENTING- THE PROGRAMS UP
PRIOR TO THE FIRE SEASON AND
YOU ANSWERED THAT AS WELL YOU
TO HANDLE A LOT OF US I MEAN. A
LOT LOTS OF WORK HAS BEEN DONE
RELATED TO THE WILDFIRES AND I
APPRECIATE EVERYTHING THAT
YOU'VE DONE AND ALL THE
ATTENTION YOU PUT TO THIS ISSUE
AND- ALSO RELATED TO P. GINNY'S
BANKRUPTCY AND- PUTS A- PC WAS
VERY INVOLVED IN THAT PROCESS
NOT SEEMS TO BE COMING TO A
CLOSE VERY SOON BUT THERE ARE
OTHER. PROGRAMS THAT SERVE
COURSE IN THE IN THE-
THROUGHOUT THIS PROCESS SERVER
WE'VE HAD WE'VE SEEN
INTERRUPTIONS AND REVIEWING
RATE CASES WE'VE SEEN DELAYS.
AND REVIEWING- YOU KNOW OTHER
PROGRAMS THAT NEED TO BE
EVALUATED- IN THE CPUC NAM TWO
POINT NO DECISION THAT HAPPENED
A IN TWENTY SIXTEEN THAT THE
COMMISSION NOTED BACK THEN THAT
THEY WOULD REVIEW THE ISSUE
AGAIN IN TWENTY NINETEEN. WE
KNOW THE TWENTY NINETY CAME AND
WENT AND- THERE WAS NO REVIEW
OF THAT ISSUE. CAN YOU TELL US
WHAT THE COMMISSION'S PLANS ARE
ON ON REVIEWING THE NET AND
ENERGY METERING PROGRAM SUCH AS
PARTICULAR- YOU DON'T HAVE AN
INTEREST IN SUPPORTING- BROADER
UP. PUBLIC PURPOSE PROGRAMS
LIKE A THE CARE PROGRAM. AND OF.
YOU KNOW WE KNOW THAT WITHIN
THOSE PROGRAMS ARE ARE CERTAIN
INEQUITIES THAT NEED TO BE
ADDRESSED AND I JUST WANTED ASK
YOUR THOUGHTS IF YOU HAVE THAT
SOMETHING THAT YOU'VE BEEN
CONTEMPLATING AT LEAST FOR THIS
YEAR. OR IN THE NEAR FUURE. AS
A SOMETHING WE CAN. TELL THE
PUBLIC CAN EXPECT FOR THE PC TO
TAKE UP ANY TIME SOON. MISTER
SHARON- THIS IS MERRY BILL THE
COMMISSION CREATED THE NAM.
I'LL TAKE UP THE NAME FIRST
PLEASE. THE COMMISSION CREATED
THE CURRENT NAME TERRA KNOWN AS
NINE TWO POINT OH PURSUANT TO
AB THREE TO SEVEN. IN TWENTY
SIXTEEN AT THAT TIME THE
COMMISSION STATED ITS INTENTION
TO REVISIT THE TERRAPINS YOU
JUST STATED MISTER CHAIR AGAIN
IN TWENTY NINETEEN TO CONSIDER
THE COSTS AND BENEFITS OF THE
PROGRAM. TO ALL CUSTOMERS AND
THE GRID THE COMMISSION MAKE UP
AT THE TIME HAD ORIGINALLY
IDENTIFIED TWENTY NINETEEN AS A
GOOD TIME TO REVISIT THE
PROGRAM. BECAUSE THAT WAS WHEN
THEY HAD EXPECTED DEFAULT TIME
OF USE RATES TWO BILLION IS FOR
ALL RESIDENTS UTILITY CUSTOMERS
AND HAVING THAT RATE TRANSITION
COMPLETED AND UNDERSTOOD WOULD
BE VALUABLE FOR THE VISIT IN
TERMS OF AND- THEN THE COST
BENEFITS AND WOOD ENERGY LESS
UNCERTAINTY FOR THE CUSTOMERS.
I. ROLL OUT. THEN ON A LONGER
SKI LET'S AND TWENTY SIXTY RPG
IN AND AS AND SIR CAN HELD OFF
ON INITIATING THE NAM REVISIT
IN TWENTY NINETEEN DUE TO THE
ONGOING DELAY WE ARE
CONSIDERING MOVING AHEAD WITH
INITIATING THE REVISIT
PROCEEDINGS LATER THIS SUMMER.
ANYTHING WE WOULD INITIATE THIS
SUMMER WOULD LIKELY TAKE UP TO
PRESS ME EIGHTEEN MONTHS TO
COME TO A CONCLUSION AT WHICH
POINT THE RESIDENTIAL CUSTOMER
RATE TRANSITIONS WILL HAVE
ALREADY TAKEN PLACE. WHILE NOT
IDEAL THE COMMISSION SIMILARLY
DEALT WITH SOME GREAT
UNCERTAINTY WHEN LOOKING AT
THEM IN THE PAST AND IT IS
DOABLE TO PROVIDE THE PUBLIC
AND COMMISSION WITH A MORE
COMPLETE PICTURE OF THE NUMBER
PROGRAM WE HIRED A CONSULTANT
IN TWENTY NINETEEN TO COMPLETE
AN EVALUATION OF NAM TWO POINT
OH WHICH WILL BE REPLACED.
AFTER THE NUMBER TWO POINT OH
STUDIES RELEASED WE WILL
EXAMINE POTENTIALLY PLACEMENT
THEM TERRACE WHICH IN THE NEW
WE VISITED PROCEEDINGS. OF THE
DELAY WAS DUE TO. TIME ETERNAL
USE- AND- DELAYS THAT WE
EXPERIENCED WITH P. JEANNIE AND
SCP IT TOOK CARE. AND IN TERMS
OF THE CARE AND FAIR PROGRAMS-
YES INDEED WE DO WE DO HAVE. A
RE LOOK HOWEVER WE HAVE JUST
HELD ON A ALL PARTY MEETING
WITH- THE UTILITIES. TO GO OVER
OUR TO HEAR FROM THEM WHAT THEY
WERE DOING WHAT THEY ARE DOING
TO FURTHER COMMUNICATE. AT
OUTREACH TO COMMUNITIES-
REGARDING CARE AND WHAT THEY'RE
DOING TO MAKE. CARE AND- SO.
MUCH EASY. AND MUCH MORE
STREAMLINED FOR THE CUSTOMERS
WE HEARD FROM THE THREE MAJOR
UTILITIES AND I FEEL THAT ALL
OF THEM ARE MAKING PROGRESS IN
THEIR COMMUNICATIONS AND
OUTRAGE AGAIN PERHAPS ON AS AS
QUICKLY AS WAIT WE WOULD LIKE
GIVEN THE- DIFFICULTY THAT
THEIR CUSTOMERS ARE
EXPERIENCING BECAUSE OF THE
ECONOMIC SITUATION. BROUGHT ON
BY CO IN NINETEEN. SO YES THERE
ARE THERE ARE. IS BEING MADE
THERE. WELL I APPRECIATE THAT
VERY THOROUGH RESPONSE OF VERY
VERY MUCH THANK YOU FOR THAT
ALSO I WANT TO TALK ABOUT- THE
BIO GAS AND RENEWABLE BIOGAS.
IMPLEMENTATION CAN YOU HEAR ME
THERE IS ONE OF THEM YES CANCER
WE HAD A LITTLE INSTRUCTION
HERE- AS YOU KNOW WHY AUTHORED
SP FOURTEEN FORTY A COUPLE
YEARS AGO. AND I'VE BEEN MY
OFFICE HAVE BEEN SENDING
LETTERS. REGARDING THE
IMPLEMENTATION OF THIS PROGRAM
TO THE COMMISSION WITH YOU
WE'VE BEEN EXCHANGING-
COMMUNICATIONS ON THIS I ALSO
INTRODUCE SB THIRTEEN FIFTY TWO
THIS YEAR WHICH IS. WE DECIDED
TO PUT OVER BECAUSE OF AS A
RESULT OF THE- CURRENT PANDEMIC
AND THE- BUT THE REDUCED
ACTIVITY HERE IN THE
LEGISLATURE BUT I'M STILL
INTERESTED IN THE STATUS. OF
THE CPU SEES EFFORTS TO DEVELOP
A RENEWABLE CAST STANDARD. AND
WHERE IS THAT IN YOUR TIMELINE
OR IS SUCH. ALSO ON YOUR LIST
OF ON YOUR TO DO LIST. YES IT
IS SIR I'M ASK FOURTEEN FORTY
IS BEING IMPLEMENTED THROUGH
OUR BIO METHANE PROCEEDING. WE
ARE ACTIVELY COLLABORATING WITH
THE CALIFORNIA AIR RESOURCES
BOARD ON A PROPOSAL THAT
CONSIDERS ADOPTING MY MESSING
PROCUREMENT TARGETS AS DIRECTED
OF COURSE BY SB FOURTEEN FORTY.
PRESS BEING KERR SB FOURTEEN
FORTY THAT PROPOSAL MUST
DETERMINE THAT THE APPROACH IS
COST EFFECTIVE AND COMPLIANCE
WITH STATE LAW. AS THIS TO BE
USED SEE STAFF HELD AN
IMPLEMENTATION WORKSHOP THIS
PAST WINTER WAS IN DECEMBER OF
TWENTY NINETEEN. AND
SUBSEQUENTLY. THE STUDY
OUTLINED WHICH WE HAVE SHARED
WITHCAR TO BE UC'S STAFF HAVE
BEEN CLOSELY WORKING WITH KERR
THROUGHOUT THE SPRING AND JUST
HAVING A FINAL COURT IN THE
THIRD QUARTER. OF THIS YEAR I'M
GOING TO TURN TO. AT RANDOM
POLICE ARE ENERGY DIVISION C.
LIKE LEFT ANYTHING OUT THERE'S
ANOTHER UPDATE. MORE BUT ALONE
OKAY THANK YOU THAT. IS IT
GOING TO BE. OKAY I DON'T THINK
THEY DID I'M SORRY. AND AGAIN I
DID NOT HAVE ANY FURTHER UPDATE
I'M SORRY MISTER CHAIR IF HE
DID NOT HEAR THAT WE'RE GOOD HE
WAS GOING TO SPEAK OKAY VERY
WELL WILL THAT WILL TURN TO
MEMBERS. WE HAVE SENATOR HILL
ON THE LINE IF WE CAN QUEUE
AND- CENTER HILL SO WE CAN ASK
US QUESTIONS. EIGHT THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR I APPRECIATED AND-
IF YOU COULD WORK WE'RE DOING
TODAY TO. THIS HEARING THANK
YOU FOR CALLING THAT- INTO-
PRESIDENT BOETTCHER AND IN YOUR
YOUR STAFF TEAM THANK YOU FOR
THE- HARD WORK. ESPECIALLY IN
THE ENORMITY OF THE TASK BEFORE
YOU TODAY I YOU TO INCREDIBLE
SET. TO JUST ENVISIONED THE
AMOUNT OF WORK IN THE- THE
SCOPE OF IT AND HOW TO USE
INCREASING AND ESPECIALLY THE
CHALLENGES THAT YOU'RE FACED
WITH SO THANK YOU FOR THAT. I
HAVE JUST A FEW QUESTIONS
MISTER CHAIR IF I COULD ONE TWO
A PRESIDENT THAT YOU'RE IN AND
TO- IS PETERSON- IF YOU WOULD
AT YOUR OPTIONS CONCERNED ABOUT
THE STRUCTURAL REFORM. AND I
KNOW THAT'S A BIG FOCUS OF
YOURS PRESIDENT BOETTCHER AND-
THERE HAVE BEEN IMPLEMENTED
IT'S COMMITTEE. OF AND AS YOU.
THE INTEREST IN THE- OF SAFETY
STAFF AT THE DURING THE
COMMISSION INTO COMMISSION
ADDITIONAL. TO THE OFFICE OF
SAFETY ADVOCATES I SEE THE
GREASE OF THE STATE. POLICY
DEBATE. WHAT'S THE VISION OF
THE STATE POLICY GOOD VISION
AND- AND HOW DO YOU SEE ITS
ROLE DIFFERING FROM OSA.
ADDITIONALLY HOW DO YOU SEE THE
ROLES AND RESPONSIBILITIES OF
THE S. P. E. N. AS TO BE
DIFFERENT- AS IT MOVES FORWARD.
THANK YOU SENATOR THANK YOU
VERY MUCH FOR YOUR YOUR
COMPLIMENTARY COMMENTS ABOUT
THE AMOUNT OF WORK WE'VE DONE
I'M QUITE PROUD OF. THAT WE
HAVE TACKLED SO MANY
PROCEEDINGS SINCE OCTOBER AND
WE'RE COMPLETING MOST OF THEM
NOW IN THE TIME FRAME. PRIOR TO
THE WELL HIGHER SEASON AND ALL
THE WHILE WE WERE DOING
BANKRUPTCY. OF P. JEANNIE SO I
APPRECIATE THOSE COMMENTS VERY
MUCH. THIS CITY POLICY IS
EXTRAORDINARILY IMPORTANT SO WE
HAVE- WE HAVE DONE EVERY
ORGANIZATION AND A
RESTRUCTURING- TO MAKE SURE
THAT WE ARE TAKING CARE OF THAT
THE IMPORTANCE OF SAFETY
POLICY. WITHIN THE P. YOU SEE
I'M GOING TO. TURN TO MISS
PETERSON SO SHE CAN DESCRIBE
THE VISION OF THE SAFETY
POLICY- AND- SAFETY ENFORCEMENT
DIVISION- SHE JUST GOT HER JOB
AND IS A 100% SWING ALL THE WAY
OUT OF. MORE SENATOR THANK YOU
FOR THE QUOTE. WE APPRECIATE IN
WORKING WITH YOUR STAFF OVER
THE YEARS ON SAFETY MATTERS AT
THE P. C. SO THE SAFETY POLICY
DIVISION IS INTENDED TO PROVIDE
THAT ESSENTIAL POLICY ANALYSIS
AND ADVISING TO THE
COMMISSIONERS. AND TO THE ALE
JAY'S AND OTHER HIGH LEVEL
DECISION MAKERS AT THE
COMMISSION WHAT WE NOTICED IS
THAT WELL WE HAVE A VERY STRONG
IN FORCE PRO. I'M IS YOU GO WE
HAD LACK SOME OF THE OVER
ARCHING POLICY VIEW POINTS THAT
TIME. SO IN MATTERS SUCH AS THE
SAFE TRANSITION OF THE NATURAL
GAS INFRASTRUCTURE AS
CALIFORNIA MOVES TOWARDS ITS
CLEAN ENERGY GOALS. MATTERS
SUCH AS CLIMATE CHANGE
ADAPTATION WHICH ALSO IMPACTS
UTILITY INFRASTRUCTURE
DECISIONS. WE WITHIN
ENFORCEMENT POINT OF VIEW WE
DON'T NECESSARILY HAVE A GROUP
OF PEOPLE WHO TAKE A LONGER
POLICY BASED ANALYTICAL TYPE OF
VIEW. AND THAT WAS WHY THE
DIVISION WAS CREATED- NOTED
BELIEVE THE FORMER ALL STATE TO
GET ADVOCATE STAFF. ARE FOLDED
INTO SAFETY POLICY DIVISION AND
SO THEY HAVE ALREADY BROUGHT
THEIR SKILLS AND KNOWLEDGE TO
BEAR ON CASES SUCH AS THE P.
JEANNIE BANKRUPTCY- THE P. S.
TS WORK THAT I'VE BEEN
DESCRIBING. IT DECEMBER AND SO
CAL GAS CITY CULTURE PRECEDING
INVESTIGATION WE'VE OPENED. NOW
TO YOUR QUESTION ABOUT. WHAT WE
NO LONGER HAVE OR WHAT WE
MIGHT. WHAT WE NEED TO MAKE UP
FOR WITH THE DISSOLUTION OF THE
OFFICES SAFETY ADVOCATES I DO
THINK THAT THEY PLAYED A VERY
IMPORTANT ROLE N ADVOCACY IN
CERTAIN PROCEEDINGS AND MY
INTENTION SINCE I HAVE BOTH
ENFORCEMENT AND POLICY UNDER
ME. IT'S TO BUILD UP THE
ADVOCACY PORTION WITHIN SCTV SO
THAT THEY CAN- ADDRESS SAFETY
CULTURE AND SOME OF THOSE OTHER
TOPICS THAT ALWAYS SAY FORMERLY
ADDRESSED. AND IS THERE A
DIFFERENCE IN THE- A
DISTINCTION BETWEEN ADVISORY
AND THE TORY STAFF IN IN IN
SOME OF THIS HAVE YOU NOTICED
OR IS THAT PART OF THE PLAN
GOING FORWARD TO- IN IS THERE
GOING TO BE A CONTINUED FIRE
WALL BETWEEN THEM. YES THERE IS
A VERY CLEAR FIRE WALL IN PART
BECAUSE COMMON LAW IN
CALIFORNIA LAW REQUIRES DOWN
THE SEPARATION OF FUNCTIONS
THAT'S ONLY APPROPRIATE- AND
REQUIRED UNDER THE LAW SO THERE
IS A VERY CLEAR DISTINCTION OF
FUNCTION YES. THANK YOU AND ONE
QUESTION DO IT CAROLINE
PALMISTRY IF I COULD- I'M
CURIOUS WHO IS OVERSEEING THE
TRANSITION AS WE KNOW FROM THE
WILD FIRE SAFETY DIVISION TO
THE NATURAL RESOURCES AGENCY
TO. HELP OUR ALONG ARE YOU IN
ENSURING THAT THE TRANSITION
WILL BE MUCH HAPPENED HOPEFULLY
SEAMLESSLY BUT BEFORE A JULY
TWENTY TWENTY ONE. THANK YOU
FOR THE QUESTION SENATOR SO I
WOULD SAY WE STARTED THINKING
ABOUT TRANSITION FROM THE
MOMENT WE STOOD UP THE
DIVISION. SO HOW FAR ALONG ARE
I WOULD SAY BROKEN UP INTO IT
WAS ABOUT EIGHTEEN MONTHS
TIMELINE WHEN WE NEED TO BE
ABLE TO BE TRANSITION BY JULY
ONE OF NEXT YEAR. SO THE FIRST
SIX MONTHS WE'VE TAKEN ON AS ON
BUILDING THE DIVISION WHICH
WHEN I BILL THE DIVISION I LOOK
AT IT AND THREE. MILLION
TRUNCHEONS PEOPLE PROCESS
SEASON AND TECHNOLOGY YOUR
TOOLS THAT WE NEED. SO AS WE'RE
BUILDING EACH OF THOSE.
EVERYTHING I'M DOING LOOKING
TOWARD WITH AN EYE TOWARDS OKAY
HOW DO I GET UP AND RUNNING
TODAY COM ARMY. BUT ALSO I
WOULD LOOK LIKE. TO RESEARCH.
IT. WHAT WE'RE THAT IS OKAY
WITH ME IGHT THEY CAN GETCOME
STRAIGHT OR IS AN EQUIVALENT
OVER THERE CONTROL OF A PROP OR
AND THEN IF THERE'S NOT
SOMETHING OVER THERE WOULD BE
SOMETHING IN TO BUILD WITH
RESOURCES TO FILL THAT GAP SO
ALL OF THIS IS BEGUN FROM DAY
ONE THE TWELVE MONTHS FOR ME IS
ABOUT. IN THE FIRST TEST OF
THIS YEAR IT'S ABOUT BUILDING A
DECENT PLAN- SO THAT THAT
ACTUALLY THAT PLAN IN THE FIRST
HALF OF NEXT YEAR THE TREND. BY
THE JULY WILL TWENTY TWO ONE.
COME STARTED WITH NATURAL
RESOURCES AS WELL FROM DAY ONE-
I WAS BROUGHT ON AT THE VERY
END OF OCTOBER AND WE HAD
MEETINGS WITH NATURAL RESOURCES
AT THE END OF LAST YEAR. AND
WE'VE NOW IT'S ESTABLISHED. YOU
ARE MEETINGS WITH RESOURCES TO
START ANSWERING ALL OF THOSE
SPECIFIC QUESTIONS SO THAT WE
CAN BE. FULLY TRANSFER BY JULY
ONE NEXT YEAR. WELL THAT'S
THAT'S EXCITING AND- IN IN VERY
COMPLIMENTARY I THINK IN TERMS
OF THE GREAT WORK THAT YOU'VE
DONE THE TERM. TRANSITION ND
BEING REALLY ON SCHEDULE I
THINK TO. GETTING THERE BY THAT
TIME SO THANK YOU FOR THAT THAT
UPDATE ONE FINAL QUESTION THE
PRESIDENT BETTER- HE THE H. YOU
KNOW WITH THEIR PERMISSION CARE
IF I COULD ON PAGE FORTY SEVEN
OF YOUR ANNUAL REPORT. THIS IT
THE CPUC NOTES IN IN ITS
ACCOMPLISHMENTS AND KEY
STATISTICS IN THAT PART OF THE
REPORT. UNDER THE ITEM NATURAL
GAS PIPELINE INSPECTIONS- THE
TO TWENTY NINETEEN TOTAL IS
ZERO- KIND OF A BIGDAY- CAN
YOU HELP ME UNDERSTAND THAT
NUMBER PLEASE WHAT DOES THAT
MEAN THERE WERE NO INSPECTIONS
OR- BY IS THERE A COMPLETE LACK
OF. ANY LISTED IN THIS. I MEAN
IT TURNED OUT MY COLLEAGUE I
KNOW FAMILIAR WITH THAT
STATISTIC AND I DON'T HAVE THE
REPORT I APOLOGIZE. PAGE FORTY
SEVEN IN FRONT OF ME THEY TURN
TO EITHER- AT YEAH I WOULD HAVE
TO APOLOGIZE AS WELL SENATOR I
CAN CERTAINLY- CONTACT PEOPLE-GET BACK TO YOU ON THAT. IT
WOULD BE HELPFUL IT AND I PO
FOR CANNIBAL LINE STARTING WITH
THAT QUESTION BECAUSE IT REALLY
WAS I AND OUR INTENT AND- BUT I
KNOW- IN THE REPORT WE ALWAYS
LOOK AT IT EVERY YEAR BEFORE
THE- THE- THE HERE. GOING TO GO
OVER THAT IN THIS KIND OF STUCK
OUT IS SOMETHING THAT SEEMED
QUITE UNUSUAL SO IF YOU COULD
GET BACK ON THE ENDS AND THE
COMMITTEE WITH THAT THAT BE
HELPFUL THANK YOU. YES WE WILL
IMMEDIATELY GET BACK TO THANK
YOU FOR THIS FOR THE QUESTION
I'M SORRY. EVENT THANK YOU VERY
MUCH THANK YOU APPRECIATE IT ON
A PROBLEM THANK THANK YOU FOR
YOUR PARTICIPATION THE
QUESTIONS ARE. AND I WILL GO TO
DOLLY. THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIRMAN- AGAIN A COUPLE
QUESTIONS ONE COULD YOU I THINK
THIS BY FOR THE PRESIDENT. WHAT
IS THE COSTS TO RATEPAYERS BEEN
TO HARDEN OUR- INFRASTRUCTURE.
WELL AS I MENTIONED IN MY
REMARKS AND WE BELIEVE THAT THE
COST AN ESTIMATION IS. FOR
EVERY BILLION DOLLAR OF WELFARE
MITIGATION IT IS EQUIVALENT TO
A- CENTER EACH INCREASE I
BELIEVE IT'S BETWEEN SEVEN AND
8% AND ESSENTIALLY THAT'S
THAT'S AN ESTIMATED COST- AS I
MENTIONED IN MY EARLIER REMARKS
AND WHAT THE EQUIVALENT OF THAT
WOULD BE ON THE ANNUAL BILL FOR
P. JEANNIE CUSTOMERS WELL.
ANDERSON AND SAN DIEGO AFTER A
MINUTE TURN AND SEE IF YOU WANT
TO MAKE ANY FURTHER COMMENTS
ABOUT THE WIDE WHILE PLAYING
MITIGATION EFFORTS AND WHAT
IMPACT. THANK YOU PRESIDENT
BADGER YEAH- THE PRESIDENT
BADGERS ESTIMATES ON. THE
IMPACT ON RATES FOR EVERY
BILLION DOLLARS- SPENT- IS AT
THIS POINT WE FIND THE BEST WAY
TO LOOK AT THAT AS WE LOOK AT
THE WALL FOR MANY. IMPLANTS FOR
THEIR MOM WALTER MITIGATION
PLANS WERE FILED TWENTY TWENTY
USING P. JEANNIE JUST AS THE
EXAMPLE- THERE TWENTY TWENTY
WILD FOR MITIGATION PLANTS
CONTEMPLATE. PROXIMITY NINE
BILLION DOLLAR INVESTMENT OVER
THE COURSE OF ABOUT THREE
YEARS- AND ALSO TO RAISE IN
THOSE FIRST THREE YEARS- MY
SMALLER NUMBER. THAT 7% HE GETS.
ACT OUT THERE AND THEN THE
PREVIOUS FALL FOR ME. FOR P.
ANY WE'RE ABOUT TWO BILLION
DOLLARS OVER A SIMILAR TIME.
UTILITIES ARE SUBSTANTIALLY.
YEAH ON OUT HEALTHCARE BUT OF.
STATE ON THIS AND- LAWLER LEVEL
MAGNITUDE AND THEN SAVE YOUR
GAS ELECTRIC AND A
SIGNIFICANTLY SMALLER OF THIS
LEVEL OF MAGNITUDE GOING
FORWARD- BUT THAT TAKES INTO
ACCOUNT A LOT OF WILD FOR
MITIGATION EFFORTS INVESTMENT
THEY'VE MADE OVER THE YEARS AND
THERE ARE READY YOU SLICE IT IN
THERE RIGHT AND IT'S PRESIDENT
TRUMAN. YOU SEEN. THE KILLINGS
RACE TRACK AND PLACE FAIRLY.
UNTIL STARTING OUT A FEW YEARS
AGO WERE SAN DIEGO'S RATES IT
START THE TRACK ABOUT
PLAYSTATION FAIRLY
SUBSTANTIALLY- IN WE NOW
FORECAST FOR THE UTILITIES THAT
THEIR RATE. PLACE IN IS
ESSENTIALLY NOT EXT BUT SCARY
LARGELY BY THE INVESTMENTS
FALTERED IT SHOULD. SO I
UNDERSTAND SO THAT I WOULD TAKE
THEM TO DO THE MATH AND IF IT
WAS NINE BILLION SPREAD OUT
OVER TIME I WOULD EQUATE THAT
TO SEVEN TO EIGHT SECONDS FOR
EACH BILLION. THAT WHAT I HEARD.
THAT'S CORRECT YEAH- I MEAN IT
I LOOKING AT SOME RATE FORECAST
THAT WE HAVE NOW AND AGAIN- WE
WOULD HAVE TO BREAK OUT- SOME
OTHER ELEMENTS THAT ARE DRIVING
IT BUT A LARGE ELEMENT DRIVING
THAT RIGHT NOW. IS IF YOU WERE
TO LOOK P. GENIES RIPS ARE
ACTUALLY LOOKING AT BILLS ARE
AVERAGE HOUSEHOLD BILLS- THIS
YEAR- THEY STARTED OUT THE
YEAR. APPROXIMATELY A HUNDRED
TWO DOLLARS MONTHS- BUT AS WE
LOOK AT THE TREND OVER THE
NEXT- THREE YEARS BY TWENTY
TWENTY THREE. AT THE END OF THE
YEAR THEY WOULD BE A HUNDRED
AND EIGHTEEN DOLLARS- AVERAGE
HOUSEHOLD BILL THAT'S AN
INCREASE OF ABOUT A HUNDRED
NINETY FIVE DOLLARS PER YEAR
PER CUSTOMER- IS WORTH NOTING
THAT ACTUALLY- THIS IS THAT.
THERE'S A SUBSTANTIAL INCREASE
IN RATES FOR CASTING FOR P.
JEANNIE AND THE TWENTY TWENTY
ONE TIME. THAT GOES BACK DOWN
BY TWENTY TWENTY THREE SO FROM
THE P. JEANNIE STANDPOINT YOU
ACTUALLY SEE THOSE CUSTOMERS
SEEN A HIGHER PER MONTHLY BILL
INCREASED. AND TWENTY TWENTY
ONE OF TWENTY TWENTY TWO AGAIN
NOT EXCLUSIVELY BUT LARGELY
DRIVEN. OUR OFFICE. THANK YOU
SO LIKE I HAVE TWO MORE
QUESTIONS ONE I THINK THIS
ONE'S FOR RACHEL FROM. TO HONOR
THE SAFETY PART OF IT. WHO'S
ACTUALLY TRACKING IN GIVING US-
OF GOING OUT ON THE GROUND IN
ACTUALLY SEEING. WHAT THE
PROGRESSES SO THAT WE KNOW THAT
IS ACTUALLY BEING DONE I KNOW
LAST YEAR- BEFORE THE P. S.
P.'S THERE WAS. NO SO MUCH WORK
IT WAS SUPPOSED TO BE DONE IT
WASN'T MEETING THE TIME FRAMES
A TO GET DONE SO WHO'S TRACKING
THAT AND- IS THAT SOMETHING
THAT WE AS LEGISLATORS CAN'T.
GET A REPORT LIKE EVERY MAYBE
SIX MONTHS OR OR SO OFTEN. SO
ACTUALLY THE BEST PERSON TO
ANSWER THAT IS CAROLINE BECAUSE
HER DIVISION IS ON THE GROUND.
YEAH THANK YOU SENATOR SO-
WITHIN THIS ONE OF OUR SAFETY
DIVISION WE HAVE RESPONSIBILITY
TO ENSURE COMPLIANCE TO ALL
THEIR ACTIVITIES WITHIN THE
WATER MITIGATION PLANS. WHICH
IS INCLUSIVE OF. AND YES YES-
OBLIGATIONS AS WELL SO TO DATE
WE'VE UP OUR COMPLIANCE BRANCH
I'VE GOT HALF OF THE STAFF THE
FIRE ON MY STAFF WE ALSO HAVE A
CONTRACT THAT'S BEEN EXECUTED
AUGMENTS THE STAFF TO BE ABLE
TO PROVIDE A STATEWIDE
COVERAGE. TODAY WE'VE COMPLETED
FIVE HUNDRED WE STARTED FIELD
INSPECTIONS WE GOT THE TEAM OF
THE STAFF AND EQUIPPED- OUT IN
THE FIELD BY EARLY MAY SO IN
THE FIRST FOUR WEEKS- WE DON'T
I WONDER NINE INSPECTIONS AND
THEIR INSPECTION ACTIVITIES WE
AVERAGE ABOUT. AN INSPECTION
ACTIVITIES HEARD IT IN ACTION
DAY THAT WERE OUT THERE ONCE WE
HAVE THE CONTRACTOR FULLY
ONBOARDING THEY SORT OF
INSPECTION LAST WEEK- AND THEIR
FULL RANGE. OF WE- HAVE TO
THOUSAND ACTIONS DONE BY THE
END OF THIS YEAR ASSURING
EXACTLY WHAT YOU JUST ASK. THAT
THE UTILITIES ARE ACTUALLY
DOING WHAT THEY SAID DO YOU
PLAN. THE NEW. GUY I. IS THAT
THEY TO PROVIDE AT THE DATA TO
SHOW WHAT THEY'D DONE IN WHAT
THEY'RE PLANNING ON DOING SO
THAT WE THEN SURE THERE ARE
DOING WITH THE PLAN DO AND SO
THEY WERE TO DO BASED ON DATA
WELL. PERFECT THANK YOU SO MY
LAST QUESTION I DON'T KNOW WHO
THIS IS FOR. BUT TO A COUPLE
YEARS AGO WE PASSED A- THE BILL
THIS IS IT FOR
TELECOMMUNICATIONS I KNOW THAT
WE'RE FOCUSED ON WILDFIRE BUT-
IT TIES TOGETHER SO- WE HAVE.
WE HAD A BILL AB SIXTEEN SIXTY
FIVE WHICH EXTENDED THE CAST OF
FUNDS- FOR UNDERSERVED AREAS
FOR- TELUGU FOR BROADBAND. AND
I KNOW THAT IT TOOK AWHILE FOR
THE FUNDS TO BE GATHERED AND-
LIKE TO KNOW. FOR MY DISTRICT
WHERE IT'S VERY RULE WE HAVE
PEOPLE WHO HAVE NO SERVICE. OR
VERY LITTLE SERVICE- WE AND NOW
THAT WE'RE TRYING TO DO-
LEARNING FROM HOME- THE THOSE
COMMUNITIES ARE VERY MUCH
DISADVANTAGED IN THE ABILITY TO
BE ABLE TO COMMUNICATE WITH
THEIR SCHOOLS- BECAUSE THEY
JUST DON'T HAVE THE
INFRASTRUCTURE AVAILABLE TO
THEM. SO HOW MANY GRANT
APPLICATIONS I KNOW FRONT TEAR
IN MY DISTRICT HAS APPLIED FOR
A GRANT BUT COULD YOU TELL ME.
HOW MANY GRANTS HAVE BEEN
APPLIED FOR AND WHAT THE
PROGRESS IS MOVING TO GET. THE
INFRASTRUCTURE PUT IN PLACE SO
OUR HOSPITALS ARE LIBRARIES IN
OUR SCHOOLS AND THOSE
DISADVANTAGED COMMUNITIES IN
THE ROLE AREAS- CAN GET SERVICE
SO THEY CAN ACTUALLY LEARN AND
UNDER COVE IT- THE ABILITY TO
BE ABLE TO. KICK COMMUNICATED
BEEN VERY DIFFICULT. THANK YOU
CENTER IF I'M GONNA ASK ROB US
FOR WHO IS OUR DIRECTOR OF
COMMUNICATIONS DIVISION TO
ANSWER THAT QUESTION. THANK YOU
SIR FOR YOUR QUESTION SO THE
CALIFORNIA MAN SERVICES FUND-
AS YOU SAID UNDER AB SIXTY
SIXTY FIVE HUNDRED ADDITIONAL
MONEY ADDED TO IT. AND IT
EXTENDED THE DEADLINE FOR-
WOULD DEPLOYING BROADBAND
INFRASTRUCTURE 298% OF THE
CONSORTIUM REGIONS ACROSS THE
STATE- AT BY TWENTY TWENTY TWO-
AS OF- MAY WE HAVE A NEW
APPLICATION WINDOW COMING AND I
WERE WE THE FIFTY FOUR.
OCCASIONS OVER A HUNDRED
DOLLARS OF INFRASTRUCTURE. THE
FUND ITSELF HAS RIGHT NOW ABOUT
TWO HUNDRED MILLION LEFT TO
ALLOCATE TO GRANTS- WE'RE GOING
TO HAVE TO FIGURE OUT HOW TO
PRIORITIZE THOSE- GRANT
APPLICATIONS- AND WE'RE ALSO IN
THE PROCESS NOW TRYING TO
FIGURE OUT HOW TO. INCORPORATE
OF THE FEDERAL STATE THERE'S
DIGITAL OPPORTUNITY FIND WHICH
IS A- FCC. REVERSE REVERSE
AUCTION WILL BE COMING ONLINE
IN OCTOBER THIS YEAR. SO WE'RE
WE'RE IN THE PROCESS NOW OF
TRYING TO FIGURE OUT OF THOSE
FIFTY FOUR APPLICATIONS HOW
MANY OF THEM HAVE- ELIGIBLE
LOCATIONS UNDER THE FEDERAL
PROBE AND HOW CAN WE
INCENTIVIZE OUR- APPLICANTS TO
APPLY FOR THOSE THOSE MONEY.
WAIT TO SCHOOL ACCESS MOST
SCHOOLS HAVE RATED TO- HIGH
SPEED INTERNET THE SPEED OF NO
GIGABIT SPEEDS THERE ARE STILL
SOME SCHOOLS THAT DO NOT HAVE
THAT PROBLEM AND WE HAVE WORKED
WITH THE CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT
OF EDUCATION AND FIGURING OUT
WHERE THOSE SCHOOLS ARE AND
FIGURING OUT. HARD TO ACCESS
YOU KNOW HOW TO CLOSE THAT GAP-
SPECIFICALLY- WITH AS PRESENT
ACTUALLY MENTIONED THE
CALIFORNIA TELEKINETIC FUND WE
PROVIDED TWENTY FIVE MILLION TO
OFFER HOT SPOT FUNDING TO THE
HOT SPOT DEVICES TO SCHOOL AGE
CHILDREN. THROUGH THE END OF
THE SCHOOL YEAR AND POSSIBLE
THROUGH THE END OF SUMMER- THAT
MONEY IS LIMITED BECAUSE WE
CAN'T FIND THESE HOT SPOTS FOR
A LONG PERIOD OF TIME- IT'S A
LIMITED AMOUNT OF MONEY TO.
HAVE EVERY YEAR TO SPEND- BUT
WE ARE LOOKING AT WAYS TO
TRANSFER IS THAT MONEY FURTHER.
THROUGH ADICIONAL-
OPPORTUNITIES WITH OTHER
SCHOOLS NOT JUST RURAL AND
SMALL BUT ALSO MID SIZE AND
URBAN. BUT THAT IS ALL GENERAL-
PRETTY RECENT BECAUSE OF THE
KOBE CRISIS- BUT WE'RE TRYING
TO MAKE. AVAILABLE TO AS MANY
SCHOOLS AS POSSIBLE. THE SO ONE
SORRY HAVE ONE FONT THEN HOW
HOW WE TO. HOW DO YOU KNOW TO
APPLY FOR THAT HOT SPOT. DID
YOU NOTIFY SCHOOLS HOW HOW DID
YOU DO IT. YES SO WE PARTNER
WITH THE CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT
OF EDUCATION AND THEY DID OUT
REACH WITH ALL THE SCHOOL
DISTRICTS IN CALIFORNIA AND
BECAUSE OF THE LIMITED AMOUNT
OF MONEY WE CAN'T PROVIDE HOT
SPOTS FOR EVERY SCHOOL DISTRICT
IN THE STATE GIVE AND WE ONLY
HAVE TWENTY FIVE MILLION
DOLLARS- BUT WE DIDN'T AS THE
HEALTH OF ALL THE MAJOR.
SERVICE PROVIDERS AND THEY HAVE
OFFERED. UNDER THAT PROGRAM. SO
THE DEPARTMENT OF EDUCATION HAS
WORKED WITH US TO FIGURE OUT
WHICH SCHOOLS ARE WOULD BE
ELIGIBLE GIVEN THAT LIMITED
AMOUNT OF MONEY. BUT BASICALLY
DEPARTMENT OF EDUCATION HAS
BEEN TAKING THE LEAD ON-
COORDINATING AND GETTING OUT
THE NOTICE UP TO SCHOOLS. OKAY
TAKE YOU WANT ONE SORRY MISTER
CHAIR BUT- DIGITAL TO NINETY
NINE WHICH WAS A BILL THAT-
ASSEMBLY MEMBER WOOD AND I DID
A COUPLE YEARS BACK. AND IT
WAS- SUPPOSED TO BE THE
CONTRACT WAS SUPPOSED TO BE LET
IN I'VE BEEN FOLLOWING UP ON
THAT HAPPENS A LOT OF MOVEMENT
I KNOW THAT THERE WAS
COMMUNITIES ALONG THE WAY. THAT
WE'RE SUPPOSED TO BE CONNECTED
MAINLY IN HIS DISTRICT BUT IT
DID DID STARTED MY DISTRICT
COULD YOU GIVE ME AN. UPDATE ON
A DIGITAL TO NINETY AS WELL.
YES SIR. CENTER DIGITAL TO AND
APPLY FOR CAL. BASS SERVICES
GRANT FUNDING WE DID. THAT
PRIVATE HOW. SINCE THE TWO THAT
WE- THAT BACK IN TWENTY. THEY
SAID HAVE SINCE COME BACK FOR
ADDITIONAL MONEY- I BELIEVE
MORE THAN 50% MORE AND- THAT
WAS DRIVEN MAINLY. BY THE FACT
THAT THEY WERE UNABLE TO ACCESS
CALTRANS RIGHT AWAY THAT WERE
ORIGINALLY PLANNED. STATE HAD
TO REDESIGN THE ROUTE WHICH IS.
FAIRLY CLOSE TRACKING ALONG THE
HIGHWAY TO NINETY NINE
CORRIDOR. BUT IT BECAUSE IT'S
DIFFERENT- THEY NEED TO GO
THROUGH A WHOLE SEPARATE
PROCESS. THE COMMISSION RIGHT
NOW HAS THAT APPLICATION FOR
IT. AND WE'RE IN THE PROCESS OF
REVIEWING THAT SO. I EXPECT
THAT WE SHOULD BE- TAKING
ACTION ON THAT WITHIN THE NEXT
MONTH OR TWO. THANK YOU. THANK
YOU AND. SENATE ALL THE I
INTRODUCED A BILL THAT WOULD
ASSN TO- COMMUNICATIONS TO
PROVIDE A- OF AFFORDABLE OR OR-
GREATLY REDUCED BROADBAND
SERVICE TO FAMILIES LOW INCOME
FAMILIES DURING THE COVERT
PANDEMIC ONLY. SO THAT IT'S AN
URGENCY BILL AND HOPEFULLY
YOU'LL SUPPORT IT'LL IT'LL
SOLVE THAT PROBLEM OF GETTING.
A BROADBAND TO THE PEOPLE
ESPECIALLY THE KIDS ARE IN
SCHOOL SO I JUST WANTED TO. LET
YOU KNOW THAT THAT'S ALSO IN
THE WORKS AND THAT'S IN
RESPONSE TO YOUR QUESTIONS.
WE'LL GO NOW TO SENATOR RUBIO
CENTER. THANK YOU HAVE FIRST
TIME I WON ALL FULL COMMAND TO
EVERYONE HERE TODAY FOR YOUR
PRESENTATION AND ALL THE WORK
THAT'S GONE INTO. OF COURSE
MAKING THINGS BETTER BUT I WANT
TO GO BACK TO SOME OF THE
COMMENTS THAT WERE MADE I
THERE'S A LOT OF COMFORT IN
TERMS OF ALL THE PROGRESS WE'VE
MADE. BUT I ALSO HAVE SOME
EXTREME CONCERNS. AND DIE GIVEN
THAT WERE INTRIGUING WILDFIRE
SEASON. AND WE KNOW IN
PARTICULAR THIS YEAR IS A
LITTLE BIT CHALLENGING BECAUSE
OF THE SHELTER IN PLACE. I KNOW
FAMILIES ARE BUYING WAY MORE
FOOD THAN THEY NORMALLY DO SO
THEY DON'T HAVE TO GO OUT AS
MUCH. AND OTHERS A COMMENT
MADE- HERE TODAY THAT STATED P.
GENIE IS MAKING SIGNIFICANT
PROGRESS. BUT I ALSO KNOW IT
WAS STRONG HIGHLIGHTED HOW MANY
IF THEY WERE IN THIS SITUATION.
AS A PERTAINS TO MAYBE NOT
WORKING. SO I WANT TO KNOW WE
ALL OF A BACK UP PLAN THE
BACKUP PLAN. JUST IN CASE IT
DOESN'T WORK OUT AS A PERTAINS
TO THE LOSS OF FOOD FOR
FAMILIES OR WONDERFUL.
INDIVIDUALS HOW ARE WE HOLDING
P. JEANNIE ACCOUNTABLE. IN CASE
THINGS DON'T WORK. SURE THANK
YOU. FOR THE QUEST THIS
REGIONAL. AGAIN BUT DO. P. S.
P. AT THE BACK AS A LAST RESORT
PARDON ME. AND THAT THEY
CONSIDER AND JUSTIFIABLE OTHER
ALTERNATIVES THAT THEY MIGHT
HAVE USED INSTEAD- AS TO THE
QUESTION OF. A BACK UP PLAN TO
THE BACK UP PLAN. I THINK I
WOULD SAY THAT OUR EFFORTS ARE
TO INSURE THAT THE UTILITY IS
READY IN THE FIRST INSTANCE. I
DO KNOW THAT THE COMPANY IS
CONSIDERING- THINGS LIKE
COMPENSATION TO PEOPLE FOR LOST
FOOD AND OTHER ON BOXES DURING
A PS YES AGAINST- I WILL
CERTAINLY TAKE THAT QUESTION TO
THEM- AND IN THEIR PANEL- IT
WOULD BE INTERESTING TO HEAR
FROM THEM ON THAT. AS WELL. HE.
THANK THANK YOU VERY MUCH
ANOTHER CLOSE TO CENTER MCGUIRE.
THANK YOU SO MUCH AT MISTER
CHAIR PRECEDED AND WANT TO SAY
HOW GRATEFUL I AM FOR THE CHAIR
FOR HOLDING THIS IMPORTANT
HEARING TODAY- IN IT SO
CRITICAL AS WE ENTER THIS FIRE
SEASON POTENTIAL FIRE- POWER
SHUT OFF SEASON AS WELL AS
MISTER CHAR THANK YOU SO MUCH.
FOR YOUR FOCUS ON THIS ON THE
FIRST QUESTION WILL BE DIRECTED
TO IT THROUGH THE CHAIR
OBVIOUSLY TO PRESIDENT PATTERN
GOOD MORNING MADAM PRESIDENT
APPRECIATE YOUR WORK IN YOUR
TEENS WORK FAT AND I WANNA. GO
OFF OF WHAT CENTER RUBIO WAS
JUST TALKING ABOUT AND THAT IS
THE ISSUE AND THE WORD OF IF SO
LOOK AT THE BOTTOM LINE IS YOU
ARE ON THE FRONT LINES P.
GENIES GONNA COME IN FRONT OF
THIS COMMITTEE TODAY. SAY THAT
THEY BELIEVE THEY'RE GOING TO
HIT THE 33% TARGET BUT I WANNA
GET YOUR TAKE ON IS THAT TRUE
YOU IT OR 30% TARGET WILL OPT
FOR THE YEAR AND THEN HAVE A
QUICK FOLLOW UP MADAM PRESIDENT.
HIS WIRED FOR I THINK I WOULD
ECHO WHAT MY- THINGS. HAS
PRESENT ALREADY. I THAT JEANNIE
IS. AHEAD OF WHERE THEY WERE IN
TWENTY NINETEEN OR THE SPRING
OF TWENTY NINETEEN PRIOR TO MY
COMING ON BOARD. IN TERMS OF
THE LESSONS LEARNED WHAT
THEY'RE DOING TO HARDEN THEIR
SYSTEM AND BE BETTER PREPARED
COMMUNICATING WITH THE- LOCAL-
GOVERNMENTS AND THE COUNTIES
AND THE CITY SO FAR. HOWEVER AS
MY COLLEAGUES STATED- AND YOU
YOU MENTIONED GOT IT SENATORS
THAT YEAH. THIS IS ABOUT
EXECUTION. HAND THEY BETWEEN
NOW AND IMMEDIATELY. AS WE ARE
IN WHILE FIRES CAN MAKE WELFARE
SEASON NOW CAN NAY COMPLETE
SOME OF THE THINGS THAT HAVE
BEEN OUTLINED BY. MS PETERSON.
AND CAN THEY REALLY DRAW ALL
THESE LINES TOGETHER AND
PROPERLY EXECUTE. I DON'T KNOW-
WE HAVE PUSH THEM VERY HARD-
WE'VE BEEN NEEDING EIGHT YOU
KNOW ABOUT THE EMERGENCY
MEETING I HAD LAST FALL AND ALL
THE THINGS THAT WE DID TO
FOLLOW UP FROM THAT EMERGENCY
MEETING. I WASN'T HAPPY IN
JANUARY AT ALL WHAT PROGRESS
THEY WERE MAKING OR BETTER NOT
NOT MAKING SO I DEPLOYED IF YOU
WILL- BOTH CAROLINE AND RACHEL
AND A COUPLE OF OUR OTHER
SENIOR EXECUTIVES TO MEET WITH
THEM LITERALLY DAYS WITH
LITERALLY WEEKLY. AND NOT JUST
LISTEN TO WHAT THEY SAID THEY
WERE GOING TO DO OR WHAT THEY
SAID THEY PLANNED ON WE
LITERALLY WERE MEETING WITH
THEM TO FIND OUT SHOW US WHEN
IS IT HOW IS IT WHAT IS THE
DATE IF WE DIDN'T THINK THE
DATE WAS OF APPROPRIATE IN
OTHER WORDS IT WASN'T GONNA GET
COMPLETED BEFORE I'LL SEASON
WELL LAST SEASON. THEN WE ALTER
THE DATE WITH THEM. SO I THINK
WE HAVE. PUSH HARD. BUT WE CAN
EXECUTE FOR THEM I CAN'T
OPERATE THEIR SYSTEM FOR WE CAN
HOLD THEM ACCOUNTABLE AND WE
WILL. BUT WE HAVE TRIED VERY
HARD TO HOLD THEM ACCOUNTABLE
IF YOU WILL DURING THE
PREPARATION PERIOD AND- SUBMIT
A PRESS AND I WILL BE VERY
INTERESTED TO HEAR WHAT THEY
SAY TO YOU THIS AFTERNOON IN
TERMS OF WHAT THEY THINK THEIR-
THEIR PREPARATION IS. SO WOULD
IT BE FAIR TO SAY THAT A
PRESIDENT YOU'RE SKEPTICAL. I
DON'T KNOW THAT I USE THE WORD
SKEPTICAL SENATOR. AND I AND.
I'M OPTIMISTIC BUT THE OPTIMISM
IS INFORMED. BY SOME SIR. AND I
AM EXTREMELY HOPEFUL AND I FEEL
LIKE THE PC HAS. HAS ASKED THE
RIGHT QUESTIONS AT THE RIGHT
TIME OF THE RIGHT PEOPLE. BUT
MY OBSERVATION IN GOING TO THE
BANKRUPTCY PROCEEDING AND OTHER
PROCEEDINGS OF P. GINNY IS.
MANAGEMENT OF THE OF THE
COMPANY IS SOMEWHAT. CONCERNING
TO ME AND I DO BELIEVE THAT
THAT THINGS THAT ARE AT THE TOP
OF THAT COMPANY SOMEHOW DON'T
ALWAYS GET TO THE Z. IN THE
IMPLEMENTATION. PEOPLE IT IS
THAT HEARD THAT THERE IS SORT
OF A FROZEN MIDDLE IF YOU WILL
OF P. JEANNIE- SO I'M HOPING
THAT ALL THAT WE HAVE DONE ALL
THAT YOU ALL HAVE DONE THE
PUBLIC NOTICE OF HOW POORLY
THEY DID- WITH PSP AS THE LIVES
THAT WERE IN DANGER BY WELFARE
AS WELL AS PS YES THEY HAVE
HEARD AND THEY HAVE LEARNED
THAT THE EXPECTATION IS HIGH.
YOU DEVON A PRESIDENT I'M GOING
TO THROUGH TWO C<c.cyan> IN SICK AT</c>
YOURSELF. MISS PETERSON AND
THEN I'LL CONCLUDE. FIRST OF
ALL STATEMENT MISTER MISS
PETERSON YOU SAID THAT IT IS A
LAST RESORT. BUT TO BE ABLE TO
USE THESE POWER SHUT OFFS
CANDIDLY THERE IS NO OTHER
TOOL. BUT THEY HAD LAST YEAR
BECAUSE THEY'RE SO FAR BEHIND
WHETHER IT'S ACTUALIZATION
VEGETATION MANAGEMENT OF.
TEMPORARY MARKER WOODS GRADES
NO OTHER TOOL TO BE ABLE TO
UTILIZE IT WAS USE WITH BLUNT
FORCE. SO I'D LIKE TO BE ABLE
TO GET YOUR- BELIEF ON. THOSE
FORTY ODD THE HARDEST HIT SAID
STATIONS THAT YOU WOULD SAID
THAT THOSE GENERATORS WERE NOT
HOOKED UP THEY'RE NOT PREPARED.
CAN YOU GIVE THIS A GO LIVE
DATE WHAT YOU BELIEVE- EACH
YOU'RE GONNA SEE DO YOU BELIEVE
THAT THEY'RE GOING TO. BE ABLE
TO GET THOSE TEMPORARY MARKER
RATES UP AND RUNNING. AT FROM
THE IN IN PRESS ABOUT YOUR
ABOUT YOUR- CAN. FOR THIS YEAR.
AND IN FINALLY ON THIS YEAR THE
COMMUTER RESOURCE CENTERS. SO
HOW WAS YOUR DISCUSSION CHANGE
IN THIS AREA OF THE CORONA
VIRUS- AND ARE YOU ARE THESE
HUNDRED AND TWELVE- CENTERS
FRIDAY NEEDED PRIOR TO THE
VIRUS OR WAS SOCIAL DISTANCING.
DO YOU BELIEVE YOU'RE GONNA
NEED MORE IF YOU DON'T MIND IT
KNOWS IN OF CONCLUDING TURNED
BACK TO THE CHAIR. ALRIGHT
SENATOR- ALL START WITH THE
SUBSTATIONS AND- TESTING AND
COMMISSIONING RELEASING. RIGHT
NOW THE COMPANY'S PLAN IS TO-
TESTING RELEASED ALL OF THE
BACK OF GENERATION AT THE GVEN
SUBSTATIONS- SIMILAR TO WHAT
PRESIDENT BADGER SAID NOT ONLY
HAVE ARE WE MEETING WITH SYSTEM
PRACTICALLY MORE THAN WEEKLY.
AND WE WILL CONTINUE TO DO THAT
ALL THE WAY THROUGH THE REST OF
TWENTY TWENTY I BELIEVE. AND SO
WE ARE ASKING EVERY BE NEARLY
EVERY WEEK OR EVEN MORE
FREQUENTLY. WHERE THEIR
PROGRESS IS ON- HOOKING UP
THOSE SYSTEMS. SO I KNOW THAT A
CERTAIN PERCENTAGE OF THEM ARE
ALREADY STAGED AT SUBSTATIONS
IT'S A MATTER OF ALSO HOOKING
THEM UP AND TEST CURRENT.
COMMISSION TO THE UTILITY WILL
ALSO BE ABLE TO. DO WITH MORE
INFORMATION MY QUESTION ONE BUT
MY QUESTION TO YOU WAS YOU DO
YOU BELIEVE THAT THEY'RE GOING
TO BE ABLE TO HIT THAT ARE
THEY- BELIEVE THAT THAT'S CAN
BE OF. ANY BY THE TIME THEY
NEED IT. NEXT BUS IS OFTEN ON
THAT POINT YES SENATOR OKAY
THANK YOU AND THEN YOU ABOUT C.
R. C.'S. THEY DID EXPERIENCE
SOME DELAYS BECAUSE OF KOBE IN
NINETEEN TO SET UP A HARD SIDED
C. R. C. THAT IS COMPLY WITH
ALL LOCAL PERMITTING AN EIGHTY
YEAR REQUIREMENTS REQUIRES MORE
IN PERSON CONTACT AND WHAT'S
POSSIBLE UNDER THE STAY AT HOME
ORDERS SO FOR THAT REASON. BE
HARD SIDED- SITES ARE
DEFINITELY WELL BEHIND THEY DID
THEY HAVE SET UP A PARALLEL
PLAN AND DO HAVE A CONTRACT TO
MOVE- MOBILE VANS THROUGHOUT
THEIR SERVICE TERRITORY ON AN
AS NEEDED BASIS. WHICH IS WHAT
I MENTIONED ALREADY- SO I THINK
MY- HOPE WOULD BE THAT THIS
YEAR WE THAT WE SEE THEM USING.
AND COMPETENTLY EXECUTING A
COMBINATION OF BOTH FURTHER
PROGRESS ON THE HARD SIDED
SITES PLUS THE- MOBILE UNITS.
THANK YOU IN SERBO DO YOU
BELIEVE THE HUNDRED AND TWELVE
IS WHAT THEY NEED TO WITH THE
VIRUS AND SOCIAL DISTANCE
SENIOR DO YOU BELIEVE THEY NEED
NOW THAT WE HAVE TO DO TO
SOCIAL DISTANCING. SO THE DR
LAST THURSDAY REQUIRES THEM TO
SUBMIT A C. OR C. PLAN WITHIN
SIXTY DAYS SINCE THEY'VE
ALREADY BEEN IN PROGRESS ALL
THREE THE UTILITIES ON WORKING
ON C. R. C.'S I EXPECT TO SEE
IN THEIR PLAN A DETERMINATION
OF WHERE THEY THINK THAT THOSE-
HUNDRED AND TWELVE LOCATIONS
SHOULD BE- LOCATED FOR THE
REPETITION- BUT IN ADDITION
THEY ARE THERE OUR GUIDELINES
STATE THAT THEY ARE MEANT TO
CONSULT WITH COUNTY'S EMERGENCY
JERKS. AT LOCAL TRAVELING
REMAINS ON THE LOCATIONS OF
THIS YOUR SEATS SO IT'S NOT OUR
DETERMINATION IT'S THE UTILITY
WORKING WITH LOCALS TO DECIDE
WHICH ARE THE BEST SPOTS WHERE
THEY'RE SUFFICIENT EGRESS
ROUTES WHAT TYPE OF- SEER SKI
SHOULD BE AVAILABLE WE SET THE
GUIDELINES TO BE FAT IN
CONSULTATION AND WORKING WITH
LOCAL GOVERNMENT REPRESENTING
TURNED BACK TO THE CHAIR MY I
GUESS MY MAYBE NOT COMING
THROUGH CLEARLY. WITH WHAT THE
DISCUSSION HAS BEEN WITH THE
COMMISSION I GET IT THAT
THEY'RE GONNA BE WORKING WITH
THE COUNTY IS DIRECTLY BUT IN
THIS ERA OF CORONAVIRUS. YOU
HAVE TO BE A LOOK AT NEW
NUMBERS IS FOR DOING TRANSFER.
OUR CLASSROOMS SCHOOLS WE'RE
GONNA NEED TO DO I ASSUME WITH
COMMUNITY RESOURCE CENTERS
BECAUSE WE CAN'T PUT AS MANY
PEOPLE INTO ONE CENTER AS WHAT
WAS ONCE THOUGHT WITH SOCIAL
DISTANCING SIX FEET. SO MY
QUESTION WAS IS THAT I KNOW FOR
THIS NEW ERA THAT WE LIVE IN OR
DO YOU BELIEVE IT DOES THE
COMMISSION BELIEVE WE'RE GONNA
NEED TO LOOK AN EXPANDED
FOOTPRINT FOR THE SEARS SEES.
BASED OFF THE SIX FOOT SOCIAL
DISTANCING IN ART THANK YOU SO
MUCH FOR THE INTELLIGENCE
RESEARCHER. THE. NOW GO TO
SENATOR MORE LEVEL. THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR. PRESIDENT BADGER
GOT WELCOME POSITION I- HAVE A
COPY OF THE ANNUAL REPORT FOR
TWENTY NINETEEN WHICH WAS
PROVIDED TO ALL OF US ON OUR
DESKS WITHOUT. I UNDERSTAND IT.
YOU DON'T HAVE A COPY BEFORE
YOU. SO I JUST SOME SOME PARTS
OF FROM MY EXPERIENCE. OF BACK.
TWENTY FIVE TWENTY SIX YEARS
AGO THE COUNTY OF ORANGE FILED
FOR CHAPTER NINE BANKRUPTCY AND-
AS A RESULT THAT WE MADE A LOT
OF CHANGES TO HOW WE REPORTED
OF FOR EVERY DEPARTMENT AND IN
ONE OF THOSE PROCEDURES WAS
CALLED A- RESULTS ORIENTED
GOVERNMENT R. O. G. AND SO THE
REPORT. DOT BE A BUSINESS PLAN
IT WOULD INCLUDE. WHAT YOU
ACCOMPLISHED THE LAST YEAR
WHICH IS IN THIS REPORT. BUT
WHAT YOU ALSO PLAN ON
ACCOMPLISHING THE NEXT YEAR SO
WITH THAT JUST SOME SOME PARTS
OF THAT BACKGROUND- FIRST IS
YOU PROVIDE THE BUDGET ON ON
PAGE FORTY BUTIT'S VERY SPARSE
AND IT DOESN'T SHOW. BUDGET TO
ACTUAL- IT DOESN'T SHOW FOR OUR
YOUR CURRENT YEAR. MAYBE MAYBE
JUST AN IDEA THAT WE COULD IF
WE COULD PROVIDE MORE DATA
THERE- ALSO WITH THE PLANET
FROM PAGE EIGHTY SIX TO NINETY
NINE- ON PAGE FORTY SIX. YOU
YOU ACTUALLY AS AS SENATOR
HILLARY PLENTY THAT YOU ALREADY
HAVE DATA BUT WHAT WHAT YOU%
DON'T HAVE WITH WITH THE DATA
ON PAGE FORTY SIX IS WHAT WERE
YOU PLANNING TO ACHIEVE. A
USING THE EXAMPLE THAT SENATOR
HILL RAISED ON INSPECTIONS IF
THE COLUMN IN FRONT OF THE
TOTAL- WOULD HAVE SAID THAT YOU
EXPECTED TO DO NO- INSPECTIONS.
THEN YOU WOULD HAVE MET YOUR
TARGET OF ZERO- BUT THEN THE
NEXT CALL WOULD BE WHAT YOU
EXPECTED TO IN TWENTY TWENTY
HOW MANY INSPECTIONS WOULD BE
FIVE WOULD BE TEN. AND SO THEN
WE WOULD HAVE SOME PANIC
COMPARISON OF YOU ARE ARE ARE
THE SPECIFIC. GOALS BEING. MET
AT THIS REPORT ALTHOUGH
EXTREMELY THOROUGH MARGE
DOESN'T. IT DOESN'T GIVE ONE A
SENSE OF WHAT WHAT ARE YOU
SUPPOSED TO BE DOING IF YOU
HAD. COMPLAINTS THIRTY THREE
THIRTY SIX HOW MANY COMPLAIN
THREE ACTING FIFTY THOUSAND TEN
THOUSAND. EIGHT I'M JUST TRYING
TO FIND SOME CONTEXT- ALSO WE
JUST A THEM SOME SPECIFIC. ON
ON PAGES THIRTY TWO AND THIRTY
FOR YOUR HAVE THE
ORGANIZATIONAL CHART. AND NOW
THAT YOU ARE IN THIS POSITION I
JUST WANTED TO GET YOUR
REACTION AS TO HOW YOUR-
ACCLIMATING TO THE NEW
POSITION- HOW ARE YOU FEELING
ABOUT THE SIZE OF THE OF THE
UC. IS IT A TWO LARGES IT'S-
COVERING TOO MANY AREAS HOW ARE
YOU HANDLING ALL THE VARIOUS
DIVISIONS. AND JUST MAYBE JUST
GIVE A QUICK UPDATE ON HOW
YOU'RE DOING. WELL THANK YOU
SENATOR FOR THAT QUESTION. IS
SORT OF CHANGES DAY TODAY. IT
TRULY HAS BEEN- QUITE AN
EXPERIENCE THAT BASICALLY
STARTED LATE AUGUST EARLY
SEPTEMBER HERE AT THE UC AND-
WE ALL KNOW WHAT HAPPENED
AGAIN. IN OCTOBER AND SO IT
IT'S BEEN A LITTLE BIT TRIAL BY
FIRE AND TERMS OF THE WORK
BEFORE IT AND ALL THE WHILE AS
I MENTIONED EARLIER WE HAD SOME
VERY SERIOUS PROCEEDINGS BEFORE
AS- SPECIFICALLY. IN A
BANKRUPTCY PROCEEDING BUT WE
INITIATED SO MANY OTHER
IMPORTANT PROCEEDINGS ARE AND
OTHER ACTIVITIES AS A RESULT OF
THE WILDFIRE S. P. S. SOME OF
WHICH I MENTIONED IN MY
REMARKS. SO IT'S BEEN BUSY IT'S
BEEN EXTREMELY BUSY AND I
APPRECIATE VERY MUCH YOUR
INTEREST IN DATA IN THE REPORT
AND WE WILL GET BACK TO YOU ON
THE INSPECTION CAN AND I
APPRECIATE. THAT RESULTS AND WE
ALSO PERMIT IS HOW YOU MANAGE.
I IN IT ORANGE COUNTY AND HAVE
TO ANSWER GOVERNMENT OFFER I.
THAT VERY VERY MUCH GIVEN MANY.
THAT WE HAD TO IMPROVE.
GOVERNMENT AND IMPROVE- HOW
GOVERNMENT FUNCTION WHEN I
WASN'T AT SECOND HERE GOT LOST.
I'M FURTHER IN ANSWERING YOUR
QUESTION ABOUT IS SIZE
ADEQUATE. IS WHAT WE DO TOO
BROAD TOO MUCH. ON I'M A
GOVERNOR WHO GOVERN PURSE AND
SO WHEN YOU'RE ASKING GOVERNOR
PERSON ABOUT IT DO YOU HAVE
ENOUGH RESOURCES THE ANSWER IS
USUALLY NO WE DON'T HAVE ENOUGH
RESOURCES BUT I DON'T SAY THAT-
I THINK THAT WE WORK VERY HARD
AT THE PC I'VE BEEN
EXTRAORDINARILY. IMPRESSED WITH
THE DEPTH OF KNOWLEDGE AND
EXPERIENCE OF THE PEOPLE ARE
EMPLOYEDAT THE PC I'M
INCREDIBLY IMPRESSED EVERY DAY
WITH MY FELLOW COMMISSIONERS
AND THE WORKLOAD THAT THEY ALL
HAVE. AND ACCOMPLISH- AND
THEY'VE BEEN EXTREMELY KIND AND
GENEROUS TO ME AS I HAVE TAKEN
ON THIS ROLE AND HAD IN SOMERS
QUITE A LEARNING CURVE. SO I'VE
BEEN A VERY APPRECIATIVE OF.
HELL THEY HAVE LISTED AND THEN
AS A CERTAIN KIND TO ME. THERE
ARE WE DO DO A LOT OF THE PC WE
ARE SIGNED A LOT IN TERMS OF
BOTH OF THOSE THINGS THAT ARE
WITHIN THE CONSTITUTION AS WELL
AS THOSE STATUTORY-
RESPONSIBILITIES. I'M I HAVE
BEEN ASKED MORE THAN ONCE ABOUT
WHAT WHAT IF WE WERE TO SHED
BUT WOULD BE SHED. THAT'S
REALLYHARD FOR ME TO EVALUATE
PRECISELY WHAT DATA AT AS I
WOULD LIKE TO DO BUT THERE ARE
AREAS IN THE TRANSPORTATION
AREA SHOULD WE RE RE BE
REGULATING UBER AND LEFT FOR
EXAMPLE. YEAH NOT WHO SHOULD WE
DO IT ON THIS VEHICLES IF NOT
THEN YOU LOOK AT THE
TRANSPORTATION AGENCY LOOK AT
DIEM. ARE PEOPLE ASKED WHETHER
WE SHOULD BE DOING SAFETY I
THINK IT'S QUITE OBVIOUS THAT
WE HAVE A VERY ROLE WHEN IT
COMES TO SAFETY THIS WILL BE.
OUR ARE JUST TO TELL CHEESE ALL.
ARE OUR OB IN THIS AND SAFE
MANNER IN SO. THE SERVICES TO
CUSTOMERS. SO I DON'T HAVE A
FAVORITE. RIGHT NOW BUT I WOULD.
ADOPT OUT. BUT I DO THINK EVERY
AGENCY IN GOVERNMENT ALL USE
AND AFTER TO MAKE THEM MORE
EFFECTIVE. AND I DARE SAY THAT
IS TRUE ABOUT THE PC IS IT IS.
GOV OPS TRANSPORTATION HHS SO-
WE DO HAVE AYE WE DO HAVE AN
EFFORT TO REFORM OUR OWN
INTERNAL PROCESSES UNDER WAY-
AND I THINK THERE'S BETWEEN
TWENTY TWENTY FIVE. THE I IT
WITHIN OUR RULES OF PROCEDURE
THAT TO BE ECONOMIST IF YOU
WILL- WE ALSO WE'RE LOOKING AT
OTHER AREAS IN OUR PROCEEDINGS
THAT- ALSO COULD BE MORE
EFFECTIVE WITH SOME BUSINESS RE
ENGINEERING. AND WE'LL BE
TAKING THOSE WE ARE WELL UNDER
WAY IN THE REFORMS COMMISSIONER
WRECK SHAMANIC COMMISSIONER
RANDALL AND WORKING ON THAT FOR
TWO YEARS. AND WE'RE GOING TO
BE IMPLEMENTED BEFORE THE END
OF THE YEAR. AS I WILL BE WITH
SOME BUSINESS RE ENGINEERING
AND OTHER PARTS OF THE PC. THAT
WAS A LITTLE LONG WINDED I'M
SORRY SENATOR- I HOLDING CASH
ON THE PLACES YOU ASK. WE DID A
GREAT JOB THANK YOU VERY MUCH
I- APPRECIATE THE FACT THAT YOU
HAD TO JUMP IN- JUST BEFORE THE
MAJOR PS PS- EVENTS AND SO IT'S
BEEN A RATHER UNIQUE YEAR FOR.
US TO SENATORS AS WELL- THIS
YEAR AND DEALING WITH THE
COVERT NINETEEN. PANDEMIC AND
NOW THE RECENT DAYS DEALING
WITH- THE- LLOYD GEORGE
REVERBERATIONS ARE JUST A LOT
GOING ON. AND WITH THAT.
SHELTERING IN PLACE AND THE
REST WE REALIZE HOW DEPENDENT
WE ARE ON. THEY ARE OUR
ELECTRICITY- HAVING ACCESS TO
OUR TELEVISION TO OUR CELL
PHONE GETTING IT CHARGED EVERY
DAY- IN IN AND SO IT JUST
OCCURRED TO ME A I DON'T WANT
TO BE TOO NEGATIVE BUT- IF YOU
HAD A CHANCE TO LOOK AT THE
THIRTY THOUSAND FOOT LEVEL
WHAT. WHAT IF- AFTER PS PS
KNOWING WHAT HAPPENS WHEN
ELECTRICITY IS OUT FOR A WEEK
IN CERTAIN LOCATIONS OF WHAT IF
SOMETHING WERE TO HAPPEN TO ONE
OF OUR MAJOR- ELECTRICITY
GENERATING FACILITIES AND ALL
OF A SUDDEN. YOU KNOW OF A PART
OF THE STATE WAS WITHOUT
ELECTRICITY NOT FOR A FEW DAYS
BUT MAYBE A FEW WEEKS. DO WE
HAVE BEEN KIND OF EMERGENCY
PLANNERS BEING A PLACE FOR
SOMETHING OF THAT MAY. BUT WE
RE AT THE IT IS FOR AN. YOU'RE
ASKED TO STAY YOUR HOME AWHILE.
ARE YOU SAYING SENATOR IF OF
THE THESE WAS NOT ABLE TO AT
ALL I THEIR TIME SYSTEM WENT
DOWN. I'M IN FOR AN EXTREME
EMERGENCY A PLAN THAT NOW THAT
WE'VE BEEN KINDA NIBBLING AT
SOME PRETTY UNIQUE EXPERIENCES.
EACH OF THE UTILITIES HAS
EIGHTY- OPERATIONAL PLAN AND
MERCHANTS SEEK PLAN- I'M NOT
IN. SPECIFICALLY FAMILIAR WITH
ALL OF THAT THEY- THEY LIKE WE
IN GOVERNMENT HAVE TO HAVE.
OPERATIONAL PLANS AND WHAT
HAPPENS IF WE CANNOT FUNCTION
AS AN ENTITY- I'M GONNA ASK
CAROLINE WITH HER BACKGROUND IN
ON EMERGENCY MANAGEMENT IF
SHE'S MORE FAMILIAR THAN I AM
SPECIFIC PLANS OF THE UTILITIES
OUT HERE SO- SENATOR SO I CAN'T
SPEAK TO THAT. BUT BEYOND WHAT
THE PRESIDENT HAS MENTIONED
TERMS UTILITIES PLANS BUT I CAN
SAY FROM MY FORMER ROLE ON IN
STATE EMERGENCY MANAGEMNT THAT
WE DIDN'T DO EXERCISES FOR LONG
TERM POWER OUTAGES SO THAT
THERE WAS ANY STATE RESPONSE
PLAN. COORDINATED WITH THE
UTILITIES AND ALL THE
AFFILIATED PARTNERS ON- HOW TO
RESPOND TO A LONG TERM OUTRAGE
IN THE I CAN LONG TERM BEING
DEFINED WEEKS AS OPPOSED TO
DATE. AND THAT'S CAN BY THE
OFFICER. SERVICES UNDER
DIRECTOR. ALLEN DID SHE AND I
DON'T KNOW WHEN THE LAST
EXERCISE WAS CONDUCTED LAST
SUMMER WAS A LACK THEY MAY HAVE
DONE ONE SINCE I LEFT IT IN IN
SEPTEMBER OF LAST YEAR BUT
THERE WAS ONE IN THE SUMMER OF
TWO THOUSAND NINETEEN. AND THEY
HAVE BEEN ONE THAT PRIOR TO
SUMMER AS LONG TWO THOUSAND
EIGHTEEN GREAT THANK THANK YOU
I HAD PLENTY OF EXPERIENCE IS
PREPARING FOR SONGS WHICH IS
THE AND FREE NUCLEAR GENERATING
A PLANT- IN SAN DIEGO ON THE
MARCH TWENTY. SO WE HAD PLENTY
OF DRILLS WHILE I WAS A KID
SUPERVISOR BY A IN RECENT
MONTHS AFTER KIND OF
EXPERIENCING WHAT WE'VE BEEN
EXPERIENCING KIND OF WONDERFUL.
YOU KNOW IF YOU THINK THIS IS
BAD WHAT IF WE LOST OUR
ELECTRICITY SO I WILL ASK TO BE
A ABOVE THE THREE I COMPANIES
TODAY THAT QUESTION SO THANK
YOU VERY MUCH THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIRMAN THANK YOU- PRESIDENT
BACHELOR PARTY. YOUR CANDID
THAT'S- THANK YOU WILL CENTER
WIENER. BUT THANK YOU CHAIRMAN
OF COURSE FOR PRESIDENT OF
BACHELOR AND I APPRECIATE- YOU
AND YOUR TEAM UPDATING US TODAY
SO THANK YOU. THANK YOU FOR
YOUR- FOR- DURING- CREDIBLY
DIFFERENT DIFFICULT TIME PERIOD
I THINK WITH A- EVERYTHING IS
HAPPENING NOW WITH THE DAMAGE.
THE ROOM THE PROTESTS AROUND
POLICE VIOLENCE SOMETIMES YOU.
CAN BE TOO EASY TO FORGET THAT
WE ALSO HAVE A MAJOR INVESTOR
OWNED UTILITY AND BANKRUPTCY
TOTALLY UNSTABLE- UTILITY- AND
OF COURSE THE THREAT OF
WILDFIRES LATER THIS YEAR IT'S-
DEFINITELY A- CHALLENGING TIME
HERE IN THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA
FOR MANY REASONS. THANK YOU FOR
YOUR WORK IN YOUR LEADERSHIP ON
I HAVE  SPECIFIC QUESTION
ABOUT- THE AFTER PROGRAM. THE
US OF GENERATION INCENTIVE
PROGRAM AS CHIP- AS I KNOW YOU
KNOW- I AUTHORED LEGISLATION
THAT WAS PASSED AND SIGNED INTO
LAW IN TWENTY EIGHTEEN. WENT
INTO EFFECT IN TWENTY NINETEEN
SO WE'RE ABOUT A YEAR AND A
HALF AND- AS YOU KNOW I'VE HAD
SOME DISAGREEMENTS WITH- THE
COMMISSION ABOUT THE
IMPLEMENTATION. OF A CHIP THE
PURPOSE OF US TO OF COURSE IS
TO PROVIDE. FINANCIAL
INCENTIVES FOR PEOPLE TO
INSTALL- ENERGY STORAGE- FOR
SOLAR OR OTHER TECHNOLOGIES-
WHICH OF COURSE EXPANDS ARE
CLEAN ENERGY IN CALIFORNIA THIS
WINTER CLIMATE GOALS- AND ALSO.
INCREASE ENERGY RESILIENCE SO
THAT WE DO HAVE- VALUES ARE.
THE SHUTDOWNS OR TWO BLACKOUTS
BUT PEOPLE CAN GENERATE THEIR
OWN POWER IT ALSO REDUCES THE
NEED FOR ON AND THE EXPANSION
OF TRANSMISSION LINES. WHICH
HAVE BEEN EXPANDED SO
DRAMATICALLY IN THE LAST TWO
DECADES OFTEN THE WILDFIRES
OWNS. WHICH INCREASES THE RISK
OF WILDFIRE. WE PASSES LAW ON
IN MY DO RESPECTFULLY- THE
COMMISSION- ON. MULTIPLE
OCCASIONS HAS PROPOSED
IMPLEMENTATION OF THE LAW THAT
WOULD- STABILITY IMPLEMENTATION
ORIGINALLY. A STAFF MADE
PROPOSALS THAT WOULD HAVE MADE
OF YES SIR PROGRAM ALMOST
IMPOSSIBLE. TO IMPLEMENT
ULTIMATELY THEN THE COMMISSION
MADE PROPOSALS- THAT WOULD HAVE
DEBILITATED THE PROGRAM.
ULTIMATELY THE COMMISSION
ADOPTED. A IMPLEMENTATION PLAN.
WHICH WILL NOT TOTALLY
DEBILITATING THE PROGRAM
DRAMATICALLY RESTRICT SAID MORE
THAN SIXTY. A THE OFFICE OF
PRIME ON CAN. I AM ROLE HAVE TO
GO INTO A VERY VERY LIMITED
AREAS- THAT ARE BOTH HIGH WILD
FIRE RISK AND LOW INCOME- EVEN
THOUGH WE ALREADY SET ASIDE IN
THE STATUTE THIRTY PERCENT. OF
THE- AS TO FUNDS FOR- FIVE
ECONOMICALLY DISADVANTAGED
COMMUNITIES- SO MY QUESTION TO
YOU IS HOW'S IT GOING HOW'S THE
ROLL OUT. HOW MUCH MONEY HAS
GONE OUT FOR US TO- HEALTH
SUCCESSFUL IS ON THE ROLL OUT
BECAUSE I LOVE BEING PROVEN
WRONG- AND- ON THE ISSUE LIKE
THIS AND IF I'M WRONG AND OTHER
CITY UC'S. IMPLEMENTATION IS
GONE DYING BUSTERS ARE GOING
GREAT I WILL BE HAPPY TO
ACKNOWLEDGE THAT I'M WRONG BUT
I WAS WRONG- SO I'M JUST
CURIOUS TO KNOW WHERE WE ARE
THANK YOU. THANK YOU SO. YES
WELL AWARE AND RESPECTFUL. HAD
A ONE OF THE FIRST MEETING OF
THAT EXCHANGE ONE OF THE FIRST
MEANS I HAD AFTER RETURNING
AFTER BEING SWORN IN- WAS WAS
AND MEETING WITH YOU AND
SENATOR STERN REGARDING YOUR
YOUR CONCERNS ABOUT GENERATION
INCENTIVE PROGRAM TO ANSWER
HOW'S IT GOING AND IT IS JUST A
REMINDER- IMPLEMENT SEVEN SB
SEVEN SEVEN HUNDRED SKEWS ME
SHE YOU SEE ADDED EIGHT
HUNDRED. BUDGET PROGRAM AND
ALLOCATE FIVE UNDER TWELVE FOR
THE GLOBAL. RESIDENTS WHO ARE
MOST LIKELY TO BE IMPACTED BY
THE WELFARE UTILITY POWER SHOPS
AND STATE SENATOR YOU NOT IT.
THE. THEN THE NEW PROGRAM
OPERATIONS THAT- ON THAT WE'VE
MENTIONED FOR THE LONGER
CUSTOMERS OPEN IN MAY AND
DEMONSTRATED TREMENDOUS
INTEREST- NEARLY TWO THOUSAND
APPLICATIONS WERE SUBMITTED IN
THE FIRST WEEK WHICH ACTUALLY
EXHAUSTED THE HUNDRED MILLION
IN FUNDING. IN THE PGA ANY S.
T. E. N. S. T. G. ANY SERVICE
TERRITORIES. DID YOU DON'T
FUNDING THAT WAS APPROVED
PURSUANT TO SB SEVEN HUNDRED
WILL BE- RELEASED SHORTLY-
SHORTLY. SO WE'VE HEARD SOME
DOUBT FROM THE STORAGE INDUSTRY
ABOUT THE LIKELIHOOD OF THAT OF
A SUFFICIENT INTEREST IN THE
NEW PROGRAM AND FEARS ABOUT THE
FUNDING GETTING AN ALLEY GOING
ON ALLOCATED EXCUSE ME. I
ASSURE YOU THAT WE HAVE BUILT
IN THE NECESSARY PROGRAM TOOLS
TO REALLOCATE FUNDING IN A
TIMELY MANNER IF AND WHEN
NEEDED BUT OUR INITIAL SIGNALS
THIS MOST RECENT PROGRAM
OPENING. INTO A DENTIST
SIGNIFICANT INTEREST- MUCH
WE'RE STILL IS TO BE DONE TO
REDUCE THE IMPACTS OF THE
WILDFIRES AND THE- YEAH. I
COULDN'T BELIEVE IT. IS GOALS
SO I'M I THINK THAT FOR US TO A
VERY GOOD START AND WE WILL
DEFINITELY YOU IN YOUR OFFICE
INFORM CYNDER OF THE-
ADDITIONAL FUNDING AND THE
RELEASE THAT I SPOKE OF THAT
WILL HAPPEN SHORTLY. THANK
THANK YOU VERY MUCH- FOR THAT I
APPRECIATE IT AND- I GUESS I
WOULD REQUEST AND I'D
APPRECIATE IF WE COULD GET-
REGULAR EVEN IF IT'S EVERY TWO
OR THREE MONTHS- A REPORT ABOUT
HOW MUCH MONEY HAS GONE OUT HOW
THE PROGRAM IS GOING- THAT
WOULD BE HELPFUL. PERHAPS THE
SENDS ME OR OTHER MEMBERS OF
THIS. COMMITTEE SO THAT WOULD
BE A ABSOLUTELY THANK YOU.
PLEASE TO DO THAT. THANK YOU
KNOW WE'LL GO TO SENATOR
BRADFORD. THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR- MY QUESTIONS WERE
DIRECTED REGARDING AWHILE FIRE
SAFETY ADVISORY BOARD AND THERE
WAS. QUESTION WHETHER UTILITIES
ARE DEVELOPING ADEQUATE-
TRAINING PROGRAM TO DEAL WITH.
THIS VEGETATION WHILE FIRE
MITIGATION SO MY QUESTION IS
TRUE IS THERE ARE SIGNIFICANT
WORKFORCE ARE IN THAT AREA AND
ALSO ADDITIONAL ELECTRICAL
WORKERS THAT IT WAS SUGGESTED
IT ALSO STATED THE DIFFICULTY
THE DIFFICULTY AND FINDING
EXPERIENCED PERSONNEL TO DO THE
WORK SO I'M TRYING TO. FIND
DANCE IS THE QUESTION DOES
UTILITIES HAVE ADEQUATE
PERSONNEL TO DO THIS WORK AND
TOO IF NOT. WHAT ARE SOME OF
THE SUGGESTIONS TO THE PC HAVE
AND HELPING UTILITIES ADDRESS
THAT PERSONNEL SHORTFALL AND
FINALLY THERE'S BEEN A LOT OF
DEBATE AND CRITICISM I SHOULD
STAY. AS IT RELATES TO P. S. P.
S. DOT ESPECIALLY DIRECTED TO
THE UTILITIES- WHAT ROLE OUR
LOCAL RESPONSIBILITY SHOULD THE
LEGISLATURE TAKEN THIS AS WELL
AS THE P. YOU SEE BECAUSE IT
WAS THE LEGISLATURE WHO
DIRECTED THE UTILITIES THE USE
PS PS BUT WILL CONTINUE TO FALL
ON THE UTILITIES FOR DOING
EXACTLY WHAT WE ASK THEM TO DO
SO. I FIND IT A LITTLE BIT
IRONIC. I'M TO ADDRESS THOSE
OTHER GROUND AND THE LEVEL OF.
CAROLINE IN THEN I CAN ADD TO
IN TERMS OF. THOUGHTS ABOUT
WHETHER THEY HAVE ENOUGH
PERSONNEL OR NOT DO YOU WANT
TO. ON THE GROUND AND WHAT THE
IMPACTS ARE YEAH SO- THANK YOU
FOR THE QUESTION AND YOU
LITERALLY JUST ARTICULATED ONE
OF THE DEFICIENCIES THAT WE
FOUND IN THE OFFER MEDICATION
PLANS. BECAUSE THEY DID
IDENTIFY. POTENTIAL COUNTRY OF
WORKFORCE IT ABLE TO IMPLEMENT
SOME OF THEIR WATER MITIGATION
PLAN INITIATIVES- BUT WE DIDN'T
FEEL ARTICULATED. DETAIL DETAIL
TO GIVE US CONFIDENCE THEY HAVE
A PLAN TO BE ABLE TO ADDRESS
THOSE WORKFORCE SHORTAGES SO WE
ACTUALLY HAVE A HOME IN- BUT
YOU KNOW WHAT WE CALL OUR GUYS
RESOLUTION A COMMON DEFICIENCY.
THAT THEY ALL NEED TO BE ABLE
TO ARTICULATE. WHAT THOSE PLANS
ARE AND IF YOU. GIVE ME ONE
MINUTE I'LL FIND OUT WHETHER.
IN THAT CLASS THEIR CLASS BE
BUT IT THE CLASSIC ANY US WHAT
THE- IS WITH THE- BY DAYS IN
THE- CLASS. IT WOULD BE THEY
WOULD INTEREST TO US WITHIN.
DAY SO WHILE PRESIDENT BACK
INTO THE REMAINING ALL OF THAT
FOR YOU. SO THERE DIFFERENT.
CAMPS BOTH. FRANKLY WITHIN THE-
COURTS. AS WELL AS DISCUSSION
BUT YOU CAN ALLEGE. A HAD AND-
I'LL- THE- RESPONSE. OF THE
WELFARE MITIGATE. THERE AND
SAFETY DIVISION IN TERMS OF THE
ACTUAL BOOTS ON THE GROUND THAT
THE UTILITIES HAVE HIRED.
USUALLY CONTRACTED- AND THEN
AND THEN WHAT KIND OF QUALITY
ASSURANCE PLAN DO THEY HAVE TO
ALSO DOUBLE CHECK IF THE AND
EDUCATION PLANS THAT THEY ARE
IMPLEMENTING ARE EFFECTIVE AND
ARE THEY BEING DONE PROPERLY BY
THE BY THE CONTRACTORS.
RECENTLY THE FEDERAL CHEN AT
ONE OF THE FEDERAL JUDGES. IN
HEART. OF THE BANKRUPTCY
PROCEEDING HAD ON HAND INQUIRED
ABOUT WHETHER P. JEANNIE SHOULD
HIRE IN HOUSE- AND THOSE FOLKS
THAT WOULD BE DO WE NEED TO
EDUCATION REMOVAL AND ALSO THE
QUALITY ASSURANCE- I'LL LEAVE
THAT UP TO THE DISCUSSION AND
SPEND ON GOING IN THAT
PROCEEDING HOWEVER I THINK THAT
THE LABOR SHORTAGE HAS BEEN A
REAL ISSUE FOR THEM- NOW WITH
KOBE NINETEEN AND THE HORRIBLE
AND EMPLOYMENT THAT WE'RE
EXPERIENCING AS A COUNTRY MAYBE
THAT CHANGES HOWEVER. THERE IS
AN END OF. IT NEEDS TO GO ON
BECAUSE YOU CAN JUST. THROW
UNTRAINED PERSON OUT INTO THE
FIELD TO REMOVE. AND VEGETATION
AND BE DONE IT'S A IT'S A MUCH
MORE THOROUGH PROCESS AND THAT
THEY SHOULD BE I'M IMPLEMENTED.
SO I THINK THAT SOME OF THAT
THE LIMITATIONS THAT THEY'VE
EXPERIENCED AND I'M GONNA LET
CAROLINE GIVEN THE STATISTICS
THAT WE HAVE NOTED THAT YES
THEY DONE ON MANY OF THE ACRE
MILES THAT THEY TALKED ABOUT-
THAT BUT THE QUALITY ASSURANCE
IN THE CHECKING OUT THAT. HAS
MAYBE NOT BEEN IS COMPLETED
AND- AS AS HAS BEEN NEEDED. ANA
FOR THEIR SHARE US THAT. SO TO
FOLLOW UP ON THE SO WITH THE
CLASS THE EFFICIENCY IS WHAT WE
HI SO BASICALLY HAVE NINETY TO
US WHAT THEY WHAT THEY'RE GOING
TO INTERPRET IN TRAIN RESIDENT
BACK POINT. PERSONNEL OF OUR
KEY MOTIVATE HERE'S A WANNA
MAKE SURE THEY'RE NOT SO OF.
YOU KNOW ROBIN PETER ROB PETER
TO PAY PAUL AND OF THE MOVING
THIS. TO CROSS THE STATE. WE
WERE SURE THAT WHOLE LIST
APPROACH THAT THIS. INCREASES
THE CAPACITY BUT TO THE-
ADDITIONAL POINT THAT PRESIDENT
AFTER BROUGHT OUT. THERE WAS AN
ISSUE WITH. QUALITY OF THE
EDUCATION MANAGEMENT- IT LAST
YEAR SO IN ADDITION TO WHAT
WE'RE WHAT WE'RE WORKING ON
THIS YEAR IS TO ENSURE THAT
THEY HAVE THERE. THE. DID YOU.
THEIR OWN QUALITY ASSURE. ON
EDUCATION MANAGER. AND THEN
WE'RE COMING IN. IN CHECKING
THAT AS WELL. TO DO. THE TO THE-
OF THEIR MEDICATION MANAGEMENT
ACTIVITIES. VERY WELL WE'LL GO
NOW OUT IN THE STILL THAN
ADDRESS THE PS PS ISSUE AS IT
AS IT RELATES TO. SOME
OWNERSHIP. BOB THE LEGISLATURE
THE PC TO SO YOU JUST CAN'T
CONTINUE TO PILE ON THE UTILITY
FOR DOING WHAT WAS DIRECTED SO
I WOULD JUST LIKE TO SEE. OTHER
THOUGHTS ON THAT. WELL I WOULD.
HESITATE STRONGLY TO EVER
DIRECT THE LEGISLATURE AS TO
WHAT YOU SHOULD BE DOING OR NOT
DOING THAT WOULD BE. WELL OUT
OF MY ROLE AND INAPPROPRIATE
ACTUALLY IN MY OWN PERSONAL%
OPINION I THINK THAT THE
LEGISLATURE HAS DONE. SOME
INCREDIBLE WORK WHEN IT COMES
TO. ALLOW THEIR MEDICATION AND
I THINK THAT- CAN GET YOU FOR
AND NO ONE WERE CREDIBLE PIECES
OF LEGISLATION. AND WERE
ENACTED IN. AN UNBELIEVABLE
SHORT OF TIME. AND WE'RE SO
INCOME THE SAME AND- TO COME
FROM. GETTING THE SETTING THAT
SETTING DATES AND TIMEFRAMES
FOR THE BANKRUPTCY. EXCEPT AS
WELL AS ESTABLISHING AND
IMPORTANT ASPECTS OF SAFETY-
THE THESE WERE THESE WERE LARGE
LARGE PIECES OF- OF. OF
LEGISLATION FOR WHICH I THINK
THE LEGISLATURE SHOULD BE-
GREATLY- GREATLY THANKS BY THIS
IS OF. YEAH YEAH SO AND REALLY
NOW I KNOW IT CAN DO TO FOR WAS
SO OF AN AT AND ON GOING FROM
NINE NO WAY SO I WOULD LEAVE IT
SIR TO ALL TO WHAT STILL LEFT
ON THE TABLE IF YOU WILL TO BE
DONE IN THIS AREA BUT I THINK
INCREDIBLE PROGRESS. WORKING
UNDER BROWN AND THEN GOVERNOR
NEW SON- INCREDIBLE PROGRESSIVE.
THOUGHTFUL AND PROBABLY
IMPORTANT A LEGISLATION WHAT IS
WEST PASSED IN AND ENACTED. SO
IN TERMS OF OUR P. S. TS
RESPONSIBILITY I THINK WE
OUTLINE A GOOD DEAL OF IT
TODAY- I THINK THAT. MICHAEL
THINGS SENATOR THERE'S ALWAYS
MORE THAT CAN BE DONE THAT I
ACE THINKS THAT SINCEFROM
OCTOBER TWO NOW JUNE- WE HAVE
HAVE TAKEN UP AND COMPLETED.
SIX SEVEN OR EIGHT DIFFERENT
PROCEEDINGS THAT DIRECTLY
IMPACT HELP YES YES IS TO BE
ADMINISTERED FROM THE
GUIDELINES THAT WE JUST
APPROVED LAST WEEK. TWO
DIFFERENT IMPORTANT PROCEEDINGS
LIKE THE- THE RECENT OPENING
AND THE- IMPLEMENTATION OF THE
PROCEEDING AROUND MY
COMPLIANCE- THAT WAS DONE
ESSENTIALLY SIX MONTHS SO I
THINK THAT THAT WE HAVE THIS IS
SO WE CAN ALWAYS DO MORE I
THINK WE'VE HAD A- STRONG SENSE
OF URGENCY. AND AN IMPORTANT.
AND I MEAN PLEASE AT THE AMOUNT
OF WORK THAT WE'VE BEEN ABLE TO
ACCOMPLISH AND- I THINK IT'S
GOING TO BE VERY IMPORTANT NOW
THAT WE HOLD THE UTILITIES
ACCOUNTABLE FOR IMPLEMENTATION.
SEC SENATOR REDONE. I WAS JUST
GONNA SAY MY CRITICISM WHAT'S
NOT ON THE LEGISLATION NINE A
ONE OR TEN FIFTY FOUR JUST
AGAIN ON THE IMPLEMENTATION OF
WHAT WAS DIRECTED BY THEM AND-
THE- I THINK THE OVER- A-
ACCUSATIONS THAT THE UTILITIES
HAVE FAILED THIS. STATE IN SOME
WAY BY DOING WHAT WAS DIRECTED
TO LEGISLATION. THE CENTER
STERN. THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR
I'D I'D CONCUR WITH MY
COLLEAGUES ON THAT POINT I
THINK WE ALL NEED TO OWN THIS.
S. P. S. CHALLENGE HERE AND I
APPRECIATE YOU PUTTING THIS
OVERSIGHT HEARING TOGETHER AND
FOR THE FOCUS. BUT YOU KNOW
THERE'S ALWAYS WAYS TO POINT
BLAME DURING A CRISIS BUT I
JUST WITH COMMANDS. MR NATCHER
OVER HER LEADERSHIP AND COMING
IN DURING THE FIRE LITERALLY
AND- PROVIDING STEADY AS IN
RESOLVING AN ORGANIZATIONAL
COMPETENCE I THINK THAT. WON'T
EVER REALLY FULLY BE
APPRECIATED WHEN WE LOOK BACK
AT THIS BANKRUPTCY. I SAYS AND
HOW CLOSE WE GOT TO THE BRINK
OF A MAJOR FINANCIAL CRISIS-
THE CREDIBILITY WITH WHICH THE
PC IS FLEXED ITS AUTHORITY
UNDER THE BANKRUPTCY CODE IN.
UNDER TEN FIFTY FOUR NINE A ONE
AS WELL AS BEEN REALLY-
CRITICAL ELEMENT TO. STANDING
STRONG AND I THINK PUTTING P.
JEANNIE. IN THEIR PLACE WHICH
IS ACCOUNTABLE TO THE PUBLIC
FOR THEY ARE PUBLIC UTILITY- SO
THANK YOU FOR THAT LEADERSHIP
MY QUESTION FOLLOWS FOLLOWS ON-
SENATOR HILLS LINE OF
QUESTIONING ON NATURAL GAS
SAFETY AS WELL AS- MY
COLLEAGUES- EARLIER REGARDING-
MICRO AGREED DEVELOPMENT IN THE
SPEED OF THE PAST YEAR PROGRAM
SO FIRST OFF- ON MICRO GRACE
AND THE S. CHIP PROGRAM. I WANT
TO COMMEND YOU FOR THE
EXPEDITIOUS PRECEDING ON
THIRTEEN THIRTY NINE
IMPLEMENTATION AND REALLY ASK-
YOU HIGHLIGHTED THE S. CHIP
DEMAND AS WELL- WHICH IS REALLY
FOCUSING ALSO ON THESE THESE
FIRE ZONES- DO WE- DO WE HAVE
TO GO. A FIRST COME FIRST SERVE
ORDER OR IS THERE A MORE
STRATEGIC WAY YOU THINK WE CAN
POTENTIALLY DEPLOY THE STF
ASSETS- SO THAT THEY DO HAVE
SORT OF BROADER RESILIENCY
BENEFITS AND PERHAPS ADD TO.
DISTRIBUTION GREAT RESILIENCY
THAT COULD DOVE TAIL WITH THE
EXPEDITED MICROGROOVE
DEVELOPMENT YOU'RE LOOKING AT.
NOT SURE AT THIS THANK YOU-
CENTER VERY MUCH FOR YOUR
COMPLIMENTS I APPRECIATE THEM
VERY MUCH I HOPE I CAN STILL ON.
LIVE UP TO THOSE COMPLIMENTS IN
THE NEXT SIX MONTHS OR AT THE
EN OF THE NEXT SIX MONTHS- I
DO NOT. TURN TO MISTER RAN.
EXPLAIN RATHER HOW WE DO THE I
KNOW THIS THE APPLICATION- BUT
I'M NOT SURE OF THE PROCESS AND
IT'S FIRST COME FIRST SERVE OR
NOT. SENATOR STARTED THANK YOU
THE QUESTION. I THINK MAYBE IN
A- MORE RUDIMENTARY MANNER AND
THAT'S EXACTLY WHAT THE
COMMISSION ACTUALLY IS TRYING
TO DO WITH THE VARIOUS- BUCKETS
OF FUNDING THAT ARE AVAILABLE
UNDER- S. TRIP AT THIS MOMENT
TIME WHEN THE COMMISSION IN
JANUARY VOTED OUT- THE DECISION
TO EXPAND THE BUDGET- AS
AUTHORIZED BY SB SEVEN HUNDRED-
AND- FIND IT. YEAH ALLOCATE
THAT MONEY TO DIFFERENT-
BUCKETS OF FINDING IT WAS VERY
INTENTIONAL AND- TARGETING THE
MONEY TOWARDS THE COMMUNITIES
TOWARDS THE INDIVIDUALS-
TOWARDS THE AREAS OF THE STATE
THAT ARE GONNA BE MOST IMPACTED
BY IT- YES YES ABOUT- IT ALSO
DID PROVIDE FOR MECHANISMS
AFTER TWO YEARS TO REALLOCATE-
MONEY FROM VARIOUS POCKETS IF
IT'S NOT SPENT- THAT GIVES US
THE MECHANISM YES- WE FIND
UMBRELLA ORGANIZATIONS AREN'T
WORKING- TO REALLOCATE OVER
OTHER PRIORITIZATION- BUT FOR
JUST POINT OF REFERENCE. OUT OF
THE WHAT WE CALL THE EQUITY
RESULT. BUCKET WHICH IS- FOR-
CUSTOMERS WHO ARE MOST LIKELY
TO BE IMPACTED BY PS PS
ADVANCED- BUT ALSO NEED OTHER
EQUITY CRITERIA AND TURNS OF
ANY COM OR MEDICAL NEEDS OR
OTHER NEEDS- FACT IS THE POCKET
THAT PRESIDENT BATTER MENTIONED.
OPEN UP FOR ELIGIBILITY AND NAY
AND THE HUNDRED MILLION THAT
WAS AVAILABLE AND THAT FINE- IS
FULLY UTILIZE THAT WAS ON A
FIRST COME FIRST SERVE BUT WE
pDOLLARS AND APPLICATIONS. AND
IN THE NEXT FEW WEEKS- THE
ADDITIONAL FUNDING ALLOWED
UNDER SB SEVEN HUNDRED WILL BE
MADE AVAILABLE FOR THAT POCKET
AND I BELIEVE THAT WITHOUT
HAVING A DRINKING FOR GOING TO
LEAVE THAT FOR EXACT FUND UP TO
ABOUT SIX HUNDRED NINE. NINE
BILLION YEAH MY QUESTION IS
JUST ABOUT THAT HUNDRED MILLION
AND I KNOW MANY- SORT OF SMALL
MOM AND POP SAY NURSING HOMES
INDEPENDENT LIVING CENTERS- SIR
LESS SOPHISTICATED ENTITIES
THAT WOULD BENEFIT GREATLY WHO
AREN'T IN LINE WHERE IS THE
MORE SOPHISTICATED PLAYERS I
THINK GOT SMART AND GOT IN LINE
SO. I WOULD LOVE TO FOLLOW UP
ON HOW TO BE EQUITABLE IN THAT
EQUITY RESILIENCY BUDGET
ALLOCATION AND REALLY THROUGH
WHAT MORE WE CAN DO WITH THOSE
THAT. AND WHETHER THEY CAN BE
REPURPOSED IN THE FEW
POTENTIALLY EVEN FOR A
DISTRIBUTION SERVICES TO
SUPPORT MICRO GRID DEVELOPMENT
SO I APPRECIATE YOUR EFFORTS ON
THAT I WANT TO SO WHERE DO YOU
ACT THERE TO BE IN MICRO GREENS
DEPLOYED BEFORE. THIS P. S. T.
S. SEASON CENTER WE WERE HELP
THAT. I HAVE TO BE. DIRECT
HOWEVER I WAS MOST HELPFUL- IN
THE P. JEANNIE CASE BECAUSE
THEY- PLAN TO DO AND HAS PUT
TOGETHER AN RFP- UNFORTUNATELY
THAT WAS WITHDRAWN AND- THIS
SUBSTATION AND THE- MICHAEL
UNITS THAT THEY HAD PLANNED.
ARE LIKELY THEIR BACKUP POWER
WILL. LIKELY BE. YOURS FOR THAT
TWENTY TWENTY AND WELFARE
SEASON. AND UNFORTUNATELY I
THINK THE SAME IS TRUE IN THE
TELCO AREA THAT THAT THAT THE
BACKUP POWER. BACKUP BATTERY
GENERATION WILL MOSTLY BE
THINGS THAT WILL BE. GENERATED
BY DIESEL. DIESEL AND GASOLINE.
I THAT'S FOR TWENTY WE HAVE IN
OUR PROCEEDINGS AND IN ALL OUR
DISCUSSIONS HAVE HAVE PUT FORTH
THAT THEY HAVE TO STRIVE FOR
TOWARD- RENEWABLE ENERGY AND
THEY- IN DIFFERENT
CONVERSATIONS BOTH ON THE TELCO
SIDE AS WELL AS ON ME I USED
SIDE. ARM THERE ARE DIFFERENT
STAGES OF. ADOPTING ON
RENEWABLE AND CLEAN ENERGY
PLANS BUT I DO NOT THINK THERE
WILL WILL SEE THAT FOR WELFARE
SEASON TWENTY TWENTY
DISAPPOINTING NEWS- I WOULD ASK
YOU JUST FROM THE FUTURE FOR
CONSIDERATION OF SOME KIND
EXPEDITED UNIFORM TERROR FOR
THAT KIND OF CLEAN MICROGROOVE
DEVELOPMENT PERHAPS THAT WOULD
SPEED THINGS ALONG- THE LAST
QUESTION GOES TO THE NATURAL
GAS SAFETY ISSUE THAT SENATOR
HILL MENTIONED EARLIER- LITTLE
DIFFERENT PART OF THE SYSTEM
DOWN IN SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA AND
AS YOU KNOW- MY DISTRICT AND
BROADER LA WAS IMPACTED GREATLY
BY THE ALLEY SO CANYON BELOW
OUT. THE DATA WE'VE SEEN SHOWS
A MARKET INCREASING UTILIZATION
OF THAT STORAGE ASSET. IN LA BY
ARE COUNTING OVER 3000%
INCREASE SINCE THE WITHDRAWAL
PROTOCOL WAS CHANGED CAN YOU
COMMENT ON THE PLANS FOR
UTILIZATION OF A LEASE SO AND
REALLY WHETHER- THERE'S STILL A
COMMITMENT TO DO THE DILIGENCE
ON THAT FEASIBILITY OF CLOSE
YOUR ANALYSIS IN THE EXPEDITED
DISCUSSED. YES SENATOR AND WE
ARE- WE DO HAVE THE AMOUNT OF
MONEY HAPPENED YOU HAVE
BUDGETED AMOUNT OF MONEY THAT
THEY GOVERNOR DIRECTED LAST
FALL. AND THAT MONEY STILL AS
RAIN MAINTAINED IN THE BUDGET
TO DO IN IN A VERY- THOROUGH
ANALYSIS OF A LEASE SO- AND WE
WILL HAVE THAT UNDER WAY AS
SOON AS THE BUDGET IS APPROVED.
I MEAN TURN TO ADD TO GIVE YOU
SOME SORT SOME OF. THE
SPECIFICS I AM- I HAVE NOT SEEN
THE BACKUP. IN REGARDING THAT
NUMBER OF USAGE I'VE HEARD THAT
NUMBER AND I WAS PUZZLED BY IT.
I JUST REALIZED IN THE LAST FEW
DAYS SO AND CAN YOU BE SURE.
AND YOUR SENATOR STERN- YA ON
THE FIRST POINT IS TO KIND OF
REITERATE THE TIMING- YOU KNOW
AS AS YOU'RE VERY WHERE SINCE
YOU'VE BEEN TRACKING THIS EVEN
SINCE BEFORE YOU WERE SENATOR-
YOUNG GOVERNOR BROWN HAD- YOU
KNOW THROUGH THE CDC HAD-
DIRECTED THE P. ARE ASKED TO PC
TO LOOK AT- FEASIBILITY OF
CLOSING THE FIELD DOWN WITHIN
TEN YEARS AND COME UP WITH
SPECIFIC. THAT WHICH GOES
BEYOND WHAT- SB THREE EIGHTY-
HAD DIED AS YOU KNOW THERE BEEN
SOME I CHALLENGES AND-
CONTRACTING ISSUES FOR ALL. OF
THAT THE PC IS COMMITTED TO-
DATA ANALYSIS ON LOOKING ADD-
WHAT IT WOULD TAKE TO CLOSE THE
FUEL DOWN- YOUR WITHIN TEN
YEARS OF THE DATE THAT.
GOVERNOR BROWN HAS MADE THAT.
SUGGESTION WHICH IS TWENTY. ANY
SEVEN AND THEN ALSO AT. A
LONGER TO YOU KNOW IN THE
TWENTY FORTY FIVE AS WE CAN
LONG TERM ON A PLANE AROUND
THAT AS WELL. AS FAR AS THIS
SPECIFIC ISSUE OF THE INCREASES
OF- WITHDRAWALS YEAH A LISA
CANYON. YEAH IT SHOULD BE
EMPHASIZED THAT THE MOST
IMPORTANT- CHANGE IN OPERATION
IS IMPACTS SAFETY. IS THE
VOLUME OF GAS THAT STORE IN THE
FIELD- AND IS YOUR- AWARE-
BEFORE THE- ROB CERTAINLY SO
CANYON THE MAXIMUM CAPACITY
THAT FIELD WAS EIGHTY SIX
BILLION CUBIC FEET- SB THREE
EIGHTY REQUIRES A P. C. TO SET
A LIMIT THAT IS BASED ON- THE
MAX AMOUNT IT'S THE- NEEDED FOR
PROVIDING RELIABILITY ADD JUST
AND REASONABLE RATES SO WE LOOK
AT THAT AS A BALANCE. OF BOTH
THE ABSOLUTE REALIZE
RELIABILITY IT ALSO IMPACTS ON-
WHOLESALE AND RETAIL GAS
MARKETS. THAT IS WAS SET AT
THIRTY THREE MILLION. THIRTY
FOUR BILLION CUBIC FEET. AND AT
THIS MOMENT TIME WE HAVE NO
INTENTION OF CHANGING THAT
KAPPLE. NOT IN THE FUTURE THERE
WAS MAYBE ARTFULLY WORD PRESS
REPORTS RECENTLY THE MADE IT SO
LIKE THE YOU TO ONE TO THE
STORAGE UPSET EIGHTY SAY
BILLION CUBIC FEET AGAIN BUT
THEY WOULD NOT BE TO THAT THE
CAPITAL THIRTY. IS AS THE
WITHDRAWAL IS YES THEY HAVE
GONE THAT THREE THOUSAND
NUMBERS NOT A ON THE NUMBER OF
WITHDRAWALS BUT THE VOLUME IT'S
BEEN WITHDRAWN- OVER THE LAST
TWO YEARS COMPARED TO- THE TWO
YEARS- AFTER- NAY BEGAN
WITHDRAWING FROM THE FIELD
AGAIN- BUT THAT'S A LITTLE BIT
OF AN APPLES TO ORANGES
COMPARISON- I GIVE IN- LEAD
THAT. THE DIED THOUSAND
NINETEEN TWO THOUSAND TWENTY
WORK COLLECTIVELY HOLDER THEN
THE PREVIOUS TWO YEARS AND SO
THERE'S HIGHER GAS DEMAND
OVERALL- AND THEN THE
CHALLENGES- THAT WE'VE HAD WITH
SO CAL GAS AND A NUMBER OF
PIPELINES BENG OUT OF SERVICE.
TO REDUCE PRESSURE. THERE WERE
THANK YOU VERY MUCH WILL NOT
SENATOR DODD. THANK VERY THIS
CHAIRMAN. HE'S ARE DISAPPOINTED
THAT SENATOR WILL- BRADFORD IS
LEFT BECAUSE I WAS GOING TO
ADDRESS HIS. COMMENTS AS THE
AUTHOR OF SB NINE OH ONE. I
WANT TO REMIND- WHAT. EVERYBODY
WHAT WE WERE DEALING WITH AT
THE TIME AND HOW MUCH BACK
BLOOD THERE WAS A LACK OF
MAINTENANCE ON THE LINE. SIX
BILLION PGD AND WHY THAT WAS
SIGNIFICANT. ISSUE RELATIVE TO
THE WILD FIRES THAT DAMAGED
SENATOR MAGUIRE'S AND- MY
DISTRICT SO UNBELIEVABLY. WE
HAD- WHEN WE STARTED TALKING
ABOUT THE TYPES OF THINGS THAT
COULD BE DONE IN ORDER TO
PROTECT PROPERTY TO PROTECT
FAMILIES FROM LOSING
EVERYTHING- OWNED IN THEIR
ENTIRE LIVES. WHAT IS THIS WAS
THE POWERSHOT OFFICE AND WE
TOOK THE MODEL OF SAN DIEGO GAS
ELECTRIC. WHICH HE DONE A
FABULOUS JOB. OF IMPLEMENTING
YES YES ALL SINCE TWO THOUSAND
SEVEN. IN DOING IN A MANNER
THAT WAS RESPONSIVE. I TO THEIR
CONSTITUENTS TO THEIR
CUSTOMERS. ANY WAS RESPONSIVE
TO- YEP FRANKLY THEY DID IT-
FOR THEIR OWN LIABILITY BECAUSE
THEY KNEW THAT THEY HAD ISSUES
TO THAT THEY HAD NOT MAINTAIN
THEIR LIVES WELL ENOUGH IT'S SO
OVER THAT TIME IT'S BEEN A REAL
DE ESCALATE OZONATION- PS PS IS
IN. SAN DIEGO AS RESULT OF
DOING IT RIGHT. SO WHAT SET
FAST FORWARD WHAT'S HAPPENED
HERE. AND HOW THIS HAS REARED
ITS UGLY HEAD MOSTLY IN
NORTHERN CALIFORNIA I THINK
THERE'S SOME POCKETS IN
SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA OF PS PS IS
THAT HAVE GONE AWRY BUT YOU
KNOW BECAUSE OF CLIMATE CHANGE
A AND- THE WEATHER PATTERNS WE
HAD IT CETERA LEARN MORE. YES
VI<c.cyan>. DONE IT VIEW. WE HAD A</c>
UTILITY AND CALIFORNIA CHOSE TO
DO PSP ESSES IN A VERY
IRRESPONSIBLE WAY. VERY HERE
RESPONSIBLE WAY AND THEN AS A
RESULT OF THEM NOT IMPLEMENTING
TECHNOLOGIES THAT THEY SHOULD
HAVE IMPLEMENTED OVER THE LAST
TWENTY YEARS. THEY COULDN'T
SAID MAC COMMUNITIES SO THEY
NEEDED JUST AS FAR AS THEY WERE
CONCERNED TURN OFF THIRTY
COUNTIES. THE TRANSFER THE
LIABILITIES THEY'RE ALIVE OWN
LIABILITIES TO THEIR CUSTOMERS.
AND SO THAT'S THE REASON WE'RE
WE HAVE THE CPUC DOING WHAT
THEY'RE DOING RIGHT NOW IT I
WAS GOING TO TALK ABOUT THIS
UNTIL CENTER BRADFORD BROUGHT
IT UP. MY GOOD FRIEND BUT NEVER
THE LESS- I REALLY AM PLEASED
WITH THIS HEARING TODAY MISTER
CHAIRMAN I WANT TO THANK YOU
VERY MUCH FOR DOING SUCH A GOOD
JOB. I KNOW THE HEARING START
OVER BUT AT LEAST FOR THIS
PANEL- THE PRESIDENT BADGER-
YOU AND YOUR TEAM HAVE BEEN
DOING AMAZING JOB IMPLEMENTING
A LOT OF VERY VERY SHORT PERIOD
OF TIME THIS IS IMPORTANT WORK
I'M GRATEFUL. FOR THE WORK THAT
IS BEEN DONE I LOOK FORWARD TO-
CONTINUE TO WORK WITH YOU- LONG
INTO THE FUTURE OR AT LEAST FOR
THE NEXT FOUR AND A HALF YEARS.
THANK YOU SENATOR DODD AND TO
ADD A LITTLE HISTORICAL
PERSPECTIVE TO YOUR COMMENTS
BACK IN- BUT I THINK IT MIGHT
HAVE BEEN AROUND TWO THOUSAND
EIGHT WHEN- TESTED YOU NEED.
DID BEGIN. THE SHUT OFFS DOWN
IN SAN DIEGO. THEY WERE
ACTUALLY ASKING FOR THAT THEY
WERE BUILDING SUPPORT IN THE
COMMUNITY TO ACTUALLY DO THAT
SO. FAR UTILITIES BEST-
ACTUALLY REQUESTED TO BE
ALLOWED TO THE SHUT OFF SO. I
THINK IT IT HAS WORKED WELL FOR
SAN DIEGO. AND I THINK AS THE
JEWS BEEN DOING A GREAT JOB OF
EXECUTING BUT IT'S ALL ABOUT AS
THE COMMISSIONER STATED IT'S
ALL ABOUT EXECUTION IT'S ALL
ABOUT IMPLEMENTATION. ONE FINAL
QUESTION TO THE COMMISSION I
HAVE A COPY OF- THE TWENTY
NINETEEN ANNUAL REPORT. AND FOR
THOSE MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC
THAT DON'T HAVE A COPY OF IT IF
YOU WANT TO LEARN MORE ABOUT
WHAT THE P. YOU SEE IS TO AND I
REALLY HIGHLY ENCOURAGE PEOPLE
TO LOOK. AT THE REPORT. IT
REALLY SPEAKS TO THE WORK THAT
THE P. YOU SEE IS DOING. AND
WHEN WE ASK WHAT WHAT DOES THE
P. YOU SEE DO THE TWO BIG ARE
THEY NOT BIG ENOUGH ARE THEY
DOING THEIR JOB SH THIS
DOCUMENT IS A VERY GOOD GUY TO
REALLY- INFORM THE PUBLIC IS
BUT THE P. YOU SEE DOES EVERY
YEAR. I'M REALLY IMPRESSED WITH
THE P. USE WHAT THE P. YOU SEE
DOES EVERY YEAR BUT IN
PARTICULAR THE THIS YEAR. READ
THIS DOCUMENT IS VERY WELL PUT
TOGETHER. AND IT LIST. A LITTLE
BIT OF EVERYTHING THAT THE P.
UC'S ACCOMPLISHING THE PASTOR
AND IT'S VERY IMPRESSIVE.
BECAUSE IT SPEAKS TO A AND- A
LARGE WORKLOAD. AND A VERY
PRODUCTIVE. ORGANIZATION IN
PARTICULAR I WANT TO CALL
ATTENTION. TO US SOME. AREAS OF
WHICH I'M VERY GRATEFUL TO THE
PC. FOR OUR FOR WORKING AND IN
PARTICULAR I WANNA I WANNA
THANK THE P. YOU SEE FOR THEIR
WORK ON. ON THE TRIBAL LANDS.
OF THE TRIBAL LAND TRANSFER
POLICY. THAT WOULD POTENTIALLY
A RETURN TRIBAL LANDS TO THEIR
RIGHTFUL OWNERS IN THE CASE
WHERE. THOSE PLANS HAVE BEEN.
USED FOR THE DELIVERY OF. POWER
NO LONGER THAN NECESSARY BUT
GIVES THE TRIBES OF THE
OPPORTUNITY TO RECOVER THE LAND
THAT IS RIGHTFULLY THEIRS AND I
THINK THAT'S A VERY FAIR
POLICY. ALSO HI I WANNA. THANK
THE P. YOU SEE FOR EXPANDING
CIRCLE THE SOLAR POWER FOR MORE
CALIFORNIANS IN PARTICULAR
PROVIDE PROVIDE INCENTIVES TO
REDUCE THE COST OF PEAS. PEAVEY
OR PHOTOVOLTAIC INSTALLATIONS
FOR AFFORDABLE HOUSING. AND
MAKES IT MORE ACCESSIBLE TO
MORE CALIFORNIANS. ALSO WANT TO
THANK THE P. YOU SEE FOR THEIR
WORK IN TNC ACCESS FOR ALL
SOMETHING THAT TO AN AREA THAT
WE WORKED IN HERE. TO MAKE TNC
OPERATORS- OF MORE OF A-
SENSITIVE TO OFFERING SERVICES
WITH PEOPLE FOR WITH A BIT
DISABILITIES. AND THAT-
DIRECTOR DECISION I THINK WILL
GO A LONG WAY OF PROVIDING
SERVICES FOR PEOPLE IN THAT
AREA AND I WANT TO THANK AND
JUST MY ONLY QUESTION REGARDING
THIS DOCUMENT IS THIS DOCUMENT
AVAILABLE LINE SO THE PUBLIC
CAN REVIEW. AND I KNOW THAT
USUALLY DOES I JUST WANT TO
MAKE IT UP. CLEAR SO THAT
PEOPLE ARE LOOKING FOR THEY CAN
ACCESS IT. MISTER CHAIRMAN OF
THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR THOSE
COMPLIMENTS TO MY HARD WORKING
COLLEAGUES. YOU SEE I
APPRECIATE THEM VERY VERY MUCH
THE TRACK MULLIN POLICYI
REALLY WANT TO. TO GIVE A-
SINGULAR SHOUT OUT TO
COMMISSIONER WHOSE MINNESOTA'S.
IS A TIRELESS CHAMPION OF
TRIBAL LAND POLICY AND IS
WORKING VERY HARD OVER THE
YEARS THANK YOU VERY MUCH SIR
FOR THAT. AND YES THEY REPORT
IS AVAILABLE ONLINE AND WE
ACTUALLY HAVE PRINTED COPIES OF
IT. YOU VERY MUCH COMPLIMENTS
ON IT IT'S A SMALL GROUP OF
PEOPLE THAT WORK ON IT. AND
AFTER SAYING DID SOME OF THE
SOME EDITING MYSELF TO IT SO.
IT'S BETTER. A LOT OF WATER.
ACTUALLY DID DID SOME COPY
EDITING AND SO FORTH SO I THANK
YOU VERY MUCH MR CHAIRMAN WELL
THE THAT GET COMPLIMENTS LIKE
THE PC SO AGAIN I'M WAY I SURE
APPRECIATE IT WELL THANK YOU
THE OF THAT SMALL GROUP THAT
WORKS ON THIS REPORT THEY
DESERVE A BONUS BUT THEY PUT
TOGETHER WHICH WE CAN GIVE THE-
STATE GOVERNMENT. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH. AND THE THANK YOU
FOR. YOUR PARTICIPATION TODAY
WAS VERY PRODUCTIVE AND I
APPRECIATE IT VERY MUCH AND
VERY INFORMATIVE THANK YOU FOR
YOUR WONDERFUL ANSWERS AND YOUR
VERY THOROUGH ANSWERS TODAY
WE'RE GONNA MOVE ON TO OUR NEXT
PRESENTER WHICH IS THE- PUBLIC
ADVOCATE'S OFFICE THEY'RE GOING
TO PROVIDE THEIR ANNUAL. UPDATE
TODAY AND- TODAY. WE WILL BE-JOINED BY- ELIZABETH ECKELS SO
SHE'S- THE DIRECTOR OF THIS
OFFICER WAS FORMALLY KNOWN AS
THE OFFICE OF REPAIR. ADVOCATES
AND- BUSINESSES- ECKELS.
AVAILABLE ONLINE NOW. IN THE
FULLER SHE IS A THE CIRCLES
WELCOME WELCOME TO OUR
COMMITTEE AND- WHENEVER YOU'RE
READY TO BEGIN PRESENTING
PLEASE. THANK YOU THANK YOU
VERY MUCH CHAIRMAN HIKES AND
MEMBERS OF THE SENATE ENERGY
COMMITTEE I REALLY APPRECIATE
THE OPPORTUNITY TO BE HERE
TODAY- AS YOU KNOW MY NAME IS
ELIZABETH TACKLES AND I'M THE
DIRECTOR OF THE PUBLIC
ADVOCATE'S OFFICE. BEFORE I
BEGIN I WANT TO THANK YOU FOR
YOUR LEADERSHIP IN THESE
UNPRECEDENTED AND DIFFICULT
TIMES AND I ALSOVERY MUCH
APPRECIATE ALL THESE DAYS BRING
TODAY. I WITH ME I'M VIRTUALLY
ARE MY IDENTITY FOR ENERGY
LINDA SERIZAWA. MAKE CHIEF
COUNSEL DARMAN FOR OUR- DOCTOR
NOT SKINNER WHO'SOUR MANAGER
FOR OUR SAFETY BRANCH AND ANNA
MARIE AND JOHNSON OUR MANAGER
FOR OUR WATER. AND
COMMUNICATIONS POLICY BRANCH-
AND- I BELIEVE YOU ALL HAVE MY
REASON TATIAN- AND OUR ANNUAL
REPORT ALREADY AND IN THE
INTEREST OF TIME I'M CERTAINLY
NOT GOING TO GO THROUGH THE
SLIDES AND WANT TO MAKE THE
MOST OF YOUR TIME. AND THAT
BRIEFLY DO IS QUICKLY YOU ON
THE SAVINGS THAT WE WERE ABLE
TO ACHIEVE FOR UTILITY
CUSTOMERS LAST YEAR ACROSS
INDUSTRY AREAS ENERGY WATER AND
COMMUNICATIONS. AND THEN
PROVIDE YOU WITH A FEW SPECIFIC
EXAMPLES OF OUR WORK TO ADDRESS
THAT FINANCIAL IMPACT SIMPLE IN
NINETEEN ON UTILITY CUSTOMERS
AS WELL AS TO PROTECT CUSTOMERS
FROM WILDFIRES AND UNNECESSARY
POWER SHUT OFF. AS YOU KNOW THE
PUBLIC ADVOCATE'S OFFICE IS THE
INDEPENDENT CONSUMER ADVOCATE
AT THE CPUC. OUR MISSION IS TO
ADVOCATE FOR THE LOWEST
POSSIBLE UTILITYRATES FOR
CALIFORNIANS. CONSISTENT WITH
SAFETY RELIABILITY AND THE
STATE'S ENVIRONMENTAL HOLES. WE
PROVIDE A VOICE FOR MILLIONS OF
CONSUMERS MANY OF WHOM DO NOT
HAVE THE TIME OR RESOURCES TO
NAVIGATE THE STATE'S COMPLEX
PROCESS IT'S- LAST YEAR OUR
DEDICATED TEAM OF ANALYSTS
ENGINEERS AND ATTORNEYS FILED
NEARLY EIGHT HUNDRED PLEADINGS
IN CPSC PROCEEDINGS.
PARTICIPATED IN HUNDREDS OF
PUBLIC MEETINGS AND WORKED WITH
MANY STAKEHOLDERS TO
SUCCESSFULLY ADVOCATE FOR
CUSTOMERS BEFORE THE CPC AND IN
OTHER FORMS. AND OUR HARD WORK
PAID OFF LAST YEAR WE SAVE
CUSTOMERS MORE THAN FOUR POINT
THREE BILLION IN LOWER UTILITY
REVENUES AND AVOIDED RATE
INCREASES. MOST OF THE FOUR
POINT THREE BILLION IN SAVINGS
IS THE RESULT OF OUR ADVOCACY
IN TEN GENERAL RATE CASES I
ALSO NOTICED YEAR SEES WHICH
ARE LISTED IN MY PRESENTATION.
THE G. A. R. C. IS OUR UTILITY
REQUESTED THE CPC FOR RATE
PAYER MONEY TO OPERATE THEIR
BUSINESSES. OFTENTIMES WITH
ONLY PARTY TO EVALUATE THESE
PROPOSALS IN THEIR ENTIRETY OUR
ADVOCACY HELPS TO KEEP COSTS
DOWN BY IDENTIFYING AREAS WHERE
THE UTILITIES ARE REQUESTING
MORE MONEY THE NECESSARY TO
OPERATE THEIR BUSINESS IS
SAFELY. HOW PAY FOR AND EXPECT
STATE AND RELIABLE ENERGY WATER
AND COMMUNICATIONS SERVICES
THIS IS WHY THE PUBLIC
ADVOCATE'S OFFICE WITH THE
STRONG SUPPORT OF THE
LEGISLATURE AND THE GOVERNOR.
HAS INCREASED OUR EMPHASIS ON
SAFETY AND RELIABILITY. I'D
LIKE TO HIGHLIGHT A FEW
SPECIFIC EXAMPLES OF OUR WORK
RELATED TO PUBLIC SAFETY
SPECIFICALLY OF THE NINETEEN
WILDFIRES. FIRST WOMAN KOBE
NINETEEN PANDEMIC BEGAN WITH
QUICKLY RECOGNIZE THE
SIGNIFICANT FINANCIAL HARDSHIP
CALIFORNIA RESIDENTS WERE GOING
TO FACE WE IDENTIFIED SOME KEY
AREAS WHERE THE CPU SECRET ACT
TO PROVIDE IMMEDIATE RELIEF. WE
STARTED BY RECOMMENDING THE
DISTRIBUTION OF CLIENT MAKE
CREDITS TO RESIDENTIAL
CUSTOMERS BE MOVED UP. IN MARCH
WE FILED AN EMERGENCY MOTION
URGING THE CPC TO REQUIRE KEY
JEANNIE AND ESSIE NEED TO
DISTRIBUTE THE OCTOBER CLIMATE
CREDIT IN MAY OR JUNE- SDG NEED
REST YOU DO NEED THE TWENTY
TWENTY CLIMATE CREDIT TIME
MEAN. WAS ALREADY ADJUSTED TO
MELIORATE ANTICIPATED HIGH
BILLS. WE ALSO RECOMMENDED IN
DISTRIBUTING THE TO TWENTY
TWENTY ONE CLIMBING CREDITS IN
TWENTY TWENTY IN ANTICIPATION
OF. ADDITIONAL ECONOMIC
HARDSHIP AT LEAST THROUGH THIS
SUMMER IN BEYOND. THAT WOULD
HAVE RESULTED IN THREE MONTHS
AND EXPEDITING BILL RELIEF FOR
CUSTOMERS AT P. JEANNIE AND
ESSIE AND TWO MONTHS FOR ESTA
JEANNIE CUSTOMERS TO. AS YOU
HEARD FROM PRESIDENT THAT
YOU'RE THAT SI PC ACTED SWIFTLY
AND MOVE THE CLIMATE CREDITS
FROM THIS FALL TO EARLIER IN
THE YEAR FOR P. JEANNIE AND C.
E. C. P. C. DECLINED TO
DISTRIBUTE THAT ESTIMATED
TWENTY TWENTY ONE CLAIMING
CREDIT AT THIS TIME. WE
RECOMMENDED SIMILAR ACTIONS FOR
LIBERTY AND PACIFIC FOR WHICH
THE CPC ADOPTED LAST WEEK THE
RESULT IS THAT CUSTOMERS WILL
RECEIVE CLIMATE CREDITS RANGING
FROM THIRTY FIVE DOLLARS FOR P.
JEANNIE CUSTOMERS TO A HUNDRED
AND SIXTY SEVEN DOLLARS. FOR
PACIFIC QUIRK CUSTOMERS THIS IS
A RELATIVELY SIMPLE APPROACH
THAT GIVES CUSTOMERS SOME
FINANCIAL RELIEF WHILE NOT
CREATING AND DEBT BURDEN FOR
FUTURE CUSTOMERS. NEXT TO
FURTHER. ASSIST CUSTOMERS
SUFFERING FROM THE FINANCIAL
IMPACT OF PROBING NINETEEN WE
ADVOCATED FOR THE ENERGY
UTILITIES TO IMMEDIATELY FROM
ALL PROGRAMS THAT ADDRESS BILL
OR REAR AGES AND PREVENT HIS
CONNECTIONS. AS YOU KNOW WITH
THE LOSS OF JOBS CUSTOMERS ARE
HAVING A DIFFICULT TIME PAYING
BILLS AND ARE LIKELY TO HAVE
THEIR UNPAID BILL BALANCES
INCREASED DRAMATICALLY. LONG
BEFORE THE KOBE NINETEEN
PANDEMIC WE WERE ALREADY
ACTIVELY ENGAGED IN PREVENTING
AND REDUCING THE NUMBER OF
SERVICE DISCONNECTIONS. IN THIS
WORK IS ONLY INCREASED IN
URGENCY WITH OF COURSE THE
FINANCIAL IMPACTS OF THE COVE
IN NINETEEN. AND THAT MAKE. THE
PROPOSED PROGRAM HELPS TO AVOID
DISCONNECTIONS BY ALLOWING FOR
A BILL OR REAR EACH FORGIVENESS
AS LONG AS THE CUSTOMER WORKS
WITH THE UTILITY ON A SCHEDULE
TO PAY A PORTION OF THE REAR
AGES. THE PROGRAM ALSO BENEFITS
ALL CUSTOMERS BY REDUCING THE
AMOUNT OF DEBT THE UTILITY
WOULD HAVE TO WRITE OFF ACROSS
WHICH TYPICALLY WOULD BE
ABSORBED BY ALL CUSTOMERS. IN
MAY THE CPUC ISSUED A PROPOSED
DECISION IN THE DISCONNECTION
PROCEEDING AND WE'RE PLEASED TO
SEE THAT AND IT REARED SHOULD
MANAGEMENT PLAN IT'S ESSENTIAL
FEATURE OF THAT. PROPOSED
DECISION. IS DIFFICULT IS
CONTINUE TO MOUNT FOR CUSTOMERS
WITH URGE THE CPC TO MAINTAIN
ITS FOCUS ON ELECTRIC RATE
INCREASES AND AS YOU HEARD FROM
PRESIDENT BADGER THE INCREASES
IN ELECTRIC RATES IN BILLS IT'S
TRULY ALARMING. FOR EXAMPLE
OVER THE PAST DECADE ESTY
GENIES RESIDENTIAL AVERAGE RATE
HAS INCREASED 24% FASTER THAN
INFLATION IN P. GENIES RATES
HAVE OUTPACED INFLATION BY
TWENTY SIX PERCENT. AND NOW
WITH THE PANDEMIC MANY
CALIFORNIANS ARE EXPERIENCED
EXTRAORDINARY FINANCIAL
HARDSHIP. GIVEN THE EXPECTED
INCREASES IN COST COMING FROM
WILD FIRE MITIGATION IT'S
PARTICULARLY IMPORTANT TO
RECOGNIZE NOT ONLY THE RATE
INCREASES FROM THOSE ACTIVITIES
BUT THE COMBINED EFFECT OVER
YEARS. IT'LL BE INCREASINGLY
IMPORTANT TO HAVE CLEAR AND
TARGETED PRIORITIES THE FOCUS
ON REDUCING GHG WHILE PROVIDING
SAFE AND RELIABLE ENERGY AT
REASONABLE PRICES. IN A VARIETY
OF PROCEEDINGS MY OFFICE HAS
WORKED TO INCLUDE AN ANALYSIS
ON THE EFFECT OF PARTICULAR
UTILITY. RATES ARE PARTICULAR
YOU TELL YOUR QUEST ON OVERALL
RATES NOT JUST. IN ISOLATION
IT'S IMPORTANT TO LOOK AT THESE
THESE PROPOSED INCREASES WHEN
THEY'RE COMBINED WITH OTHER
ANTICIPATED UTILITY REVENUE
INCREASES. DO WE SEE A NEED FOR
INCREASED TRANSPARENCY IN THAT
RATE MAKING PROCESS AS WELL AS
BETTER TOOLS THE CPC TO
IDENTIFY THE TRADE OFFS IN
MAKING WHEN AN APPROVED NEW
UTILITY AND THE- TO HELP WITH
THAT WE PROPOSED. A TOOL THAT
HELPS TO CONSIDER HOW EACH
REQUEST FURTHERS. THE INTEREST
OF LOOKING FORWARD ACROSS
VARIOUS PROCEEDINGS AND HOW
THEY CAN INNER ACTED CHANGE
CUSTOMERS RATES. THE TOOL THAT
WE HAVE PROPOSED. AND THAT BOTH
THE ENERGY UTILITIES AND SI PC
SI PC CAN USE PROVIDES A SIMPLE
AND COMPREHENSIVE WAY TO SEE
HOW YES PROGRAMS AND PROJECTS
COMBINED TO DRIVE FREE. THE
TOOL IS INTENDED TO BE FORWARD
LOOKING AND RATHER THAN REVIEW
A PARTICULAR YOU CHILI PROPOSAL
IN ISOLATION ALLOWS YOU TO SEE
THE QUEUE IN A TEN IMPACTS FOR
THE COMING YEARS. NEXT TURNING
TO WILD FOR SAFETY AND
PREVENTION AS A CHAIR HI SO
MENTIONED IN HIS OPENING
REMARKS. TWO MILLION CUSTOMERS
LOST POWER DURING LAST FALL'S
PS PS EVENTS. MANY CUSTOMERS
ALSO LOST ACCESS TO
COMMUNICATION NETWORKS DURING
THESE POWER SHUT OFF. BECAUSE
MORE THAN 81% AND NINE ONE ONE
CALLS ARE MADE FROM CELL PHONES
THE RESILIENCY OF WIRELESS
NETWORKS IT'S A MATTER OF
PUBLIC HEALTH AND SAFETY. ACT
OVER TWENTY EIGHTEEN ARE SENT
US COUPLED WITH KOBE NINETEEN
HAVE HIGHLIGHTED HOW CRITICAL
AN ESSENTIAL COMMUNICATION
NETWORKS ARE FOR WIRELESS AND
WIRELINE SERVICES. WITH THE CPC
TO EXERCISE ITS AUTHORITY TO
REQUIRE WIRELESS COMPANIES TO
INSTALL BACKUP POWER IN THEIR
FACILITIES. AND TO INCLUDE ALL
MEANS NECESSARY TO ENSURE A
WIRE SERVICE IS MAINTAINED FOR
AT LEAST SEVENTY TWO HOURS FROM
THE START OF AN ELECTRICAL
OUTAGE. ESPECIALLY NOW TO THE
KOBE NINETY. THANK CALIFORNIANS
RELYING. COMMUNICATION SERVICES.
FOR ALMOST EVERY FOR TELEWORK
FOR VISIT THEIR DOCTOR
ATTENDING SCHOOL SIGNING UP FOR
GOVERNMENT PROGRAMS APPLYING
FOR JOBS AND- MOST IMPORTANTLY
THE NEED TO DIAL NINE ONE ONE
IN CASE OF AN EMERGENCY. I WANT
TO COMMEND THE CPC FOR ISSUING
PROPOSED RULES REQUIRING
COMMUNICATIONS SERVICE
PROVIDERS TO TAKE ALLMEANS
NECESSARY TO KEEP SERVICE
WORKING DURING A POWER SHUT OFF
AND OTHER DISASTERS. WE
CERTAINLY HOPE THAT AS RULES
CAN BE ADOPTED QUICKLY TO
ENSURE THE HEALTH AND SAFETY OF
CALIFORNIANS. IT'S CRITICAL FOR
COMMUNICATIONS FACILITIES STAFF
ON SITEBACKUP POWER WE CAN'T
RELY AND DEPLOY WHAT ASSETS
SECTIONS CELLS ON WHEELS
OURSELVES ON LIKE TRACKS TO
RESPOND TO WIDESPREAD OUTAGES
YEARS NO WHERE NEAR ENOUGH OF
THESE TO PLAY WELL. ASSETS TO
PREVENT. WINDS REACHING TWO
CASES NETWORK OUTAGES. FINALLY
WE'VE BEEN VERY ACTIVE IN
REVIEWING THE ELECTRIC
UTILITIES TWENTY TWENTY ONE FOR
MEDICATION PLANTS AND PROVIDING
COMMENTS IN OUR REVIEW OF THE
PLANS FILED BY THE SIX INVESTOR
OWNED ELECTRIC UTILITIES P.
JEANNIE S. C. E. . T. G. ANY
CENTER COURT WHERE VALLEY AND
LIBERTY WE IDENTIFIED THE NEED
FOR SIGNIFICANT IMPROVEMENTS IN
MANY OF THE PLANSIN PARTICULAR
WE I DONT AGAIN IF I SEVERAL
PROBLEMS WITH P. GENIES PLAN
WHICH WOULD REQUIRE PEACHY NEED
TO FILE A FULL COMPLIANCE PLAN
IN TWENTY TWENTY. ONE IS IT
SAMPLE. P. JEANNIE SHOULD BE
REQUIRED TO PROVIDE MORE
INFORMATION ABOUT ITS PLANNED
SYSTEM HARDENING EMISSIONS.
ALSO FAILED TO PROVIDE RISK
SPEND EFFICIENCY WHICH ARE A
CRITICAL TOOL TO HELP
UNDERSTAND THE OVERALL ADVOCACY
AT THE UTILITY SAFETY PROGRAMS.
THE HIGHER THE RISK SPEND
EFFICIENCY CORNER SYSTEMS
IMPROVEMENT THE MORE BENEFICIAL
IT IS TO MAKE THE IMPROVEMENTS
ARE CONDUCT THE ACTIVITY. THE
WATER IS DIVISION AND OTHER
PARTIES ALSO HAVE BEEN COVERED
SIGNIFICANT DEFICIENCIES IN THE
PLANS THEREFORE WE RECOMMEND
THAT IN TWENTY TWENTY ONE SOME
UTILITYSHOULD BE REQUIRED TO
FILE. THREE COUNTS OF PLANTS
INSTEAD OF JUST PROVIDING
UPDATES TO THEIR TWENTY TWENTY
PLANS. OVERALL THE TWENTY
TWENTY WATER MITIGATION PLANS
REPRESENT A SIGNIFICANT STEP
FORWARD IN THE OVERSIGHT OF
ELECTRIC. UTILITY OPERATIONS
AND THAT PROCESS CREATED BY THE
LEGISLATURE AND NOW BEEN
IMPLEMENTED BY UR NEW DIRECTOR
OVER THE WILD FIRE SAFETY
DIVISION IS LEADING TO
INCREASED. TRANSPARENCY HOWEVER
EVEN WITH THE EXTRAORDINARY
WORK OF THE GOVERNOR'S OFFICE
THE LEGISLATURE COLLEAGUES AT
THE CPC AND COUNSEL COUNTLESS
STATE LOCAL AND OTHER ENTITIES
CALIFORNIA CONTINUES TO A
SIGNIFICANT WILD HER AND OTHER
SAFETY THREATS. MY GOAL IS TO
CONTINUE TO PROVIDE ANALYSIS
AND INNOVATIVE THINKING TO
ACHIEVE SOLUTIONS THAT BENEFIT
CALIFORNIA AND ITS CONSUMERS WE
LOOK FORWARD TO WORKING WITH
YOU AND OTHER STAKEHOLDERS TO
ADDRESS THE CHALLENGES AHEAD.
THANKS AGAIN FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO BE HERE TODAY
AND I'M HAPPY TO ANSWER ANY
QUESTIONS YOU MAY HAVE THANK
YOU. THANK YOU VERY MUCH. AND
IF MEMBERS HAVE A QUESTIONS
PLEASE RAISE YOUR HANDS NOW.
RUBIO I JUST A THANK YOU FOR
YOUR PRESENTATION. I HAVE
WORKED IN THE PAST TO ADDRESS
KIND OF THE GROWING CONCERN
ABOUT UTILITY SHUT OFFS. AND WE
PASSED A BILL TO HELP PEOPLE
WITH A LIFE THREATENING
CONDITIONS AND- WE THERE'S
ALWAYS BEEN A TRIP THERE'S BEEN
A TREND A GROWING TREND OF
PEOPLE BEING DISCONNECTED FROM-
UTILITY SERVICE FOR. OF LACK OF
PAYMENT. AND I WANTED TO GET
YOUR- PERSPECTIVES ON THAT
ISSUE ARE THERE SPECIFIC
PROPOSALS IN YOUR OFFICE THAT
WOULD LIKE TO HELP CUSTOMERS-
STRUGGLING TO PAY THE UTILITY
BILLS SO THAT SOMETHING YOU
CONSIDERED SOMETHING YOU'VE
LOOKED AT. HI THIS IS SIX. YES
YES YES ABSOLUTELY- THAT AND
THAT IS ONE OF THE PROPOSALS
THAT THAT WE HAVE BEFORE THE PC
TO SPECIFICALLY. HAVE A DOCTOR
PLAN WHERE THE UTILITIES CAN
WORK- WITH THE CUSTOMER- SO
THAT THEY'RE AND THEY'RE JUST
THEY'RE NOT DISCONNECTED AND
THAT THE- VARIOUS- REAR AGES
THAT THE CUSTOM MAY HAVE CAN BE
PAID IN SMALL AMOUNTS GOING
FORWARD. WHICH WILL NOT ONLY
BENEFIT THAT CUSTOMER AND
PREVENT THAT CUSTOMER FROM
BEING- DISCONNECTED BUT WILL
ALSO- NOT. AND TO THE COST OF
THAT HAVE A DISCONNECTION
BECAUSE THE DISCONNECTION IS
ABSOLUTELY HORRIBLE AND TRAGIC
FOR THE INDIVIDUAL CUSTOMER AND
IT GETS A LOT OF MONEY IN AND
HASSLE TO GET RECONNECTED. BUT
IN ADDITION TO THAT- IT IF
THERE ARE A LOT OF
DISCONNECTIONS THAT ADDS TO THE
COST OF ALL OF THE CUSTOMERS
BECAUSE- IT'S ULTIMATELY THE
CUSTOMERS THAT ABSORB THOSE
THOSE COSTS SO. IT'S IN A IS
INTEREST TO DO WHATEVER WE CAN
THE PEOPLE. DID TO THEIR
UTILITY SERVICE BOTH FOR THEIR
OWN SAFETY BUT ALSO FOR THE
BROADER. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
WILL GO TO SENATOR MORE LOCK.
MISTER CHAIR AND THANK YOU MISS
ECKELS- REVIEWING YOUR POWER
POINT PRESENTATION- ON PAGE
THREE WE ARE TOLD THAT. YOU
WERE ABLE TO SAVE A FOUR POINT
JUST TRYING TO BALANCE THAT
WITH THE FACT THAT WE HAVE AND
I OWE YOU AND CHAPTER ELEVEN WE
HAVE DEFERRED MAINTENANCE COSTS
AND WE HAVE. FIRE VICTIMS THAT
NEED REIMBURSEMENT SINCE SO I'M
I'M JUST WONDERING IF IT IS SIR
PAGE THAT HELPS US. TO
UNDERSTAND THE BALANCE- SO THAT
AS WE PURSUE AFFORDABILITY WERE
NOT BEING PENNY WISE AND POUND
FOOLISH AND- I'M JUST WONDERING
IF YOU COULD HELP ME OUT. YEAH
IN IN OUR FULL REPORT WHICH
HOPEFULLY YOU HAVE THERE AS
WELL IT SHOULD EXPLAIN IN MORE
DETAIL- HOW. WHAT WAS DONE AND
WHERE SOME OF THOSE COSTS AND
IT'S COST SAVINGS WERE FOUND SO
FOR EXAMPLE JUST TO BE CLEAR-
WE STRONGLY AS AS ADVOCATES FOR
CALIFORNIA'S CONSUMERS WANT THE
UTILITIES TO INVEST IN SAFETY
AND WE WERE IN SOME OF THE
MEMBERS HERE KNOW YOU MAY BE
AWARE OF THIS TO WE WERE
INSTRUMENTAL. IN HELPING SET UP
A PROCESS WHERE PRIOR TO AND
THEN GENERATE CASES WE WOULD WE
ALL OF THE PARTIES WOULD FOCUS
ON THE VARIOUS SAFETY RISKS AND
ASSESS WHAT THE SAFETY RISKS
WORK. MOST CRITICAL TO BE
ADDRESSED RIGHT AWAY- AND THEN
WE WOULD TALK ABOUT COSTS
BECAUSE WE BELIEVED IT WAS
IMPORTANT TO SEPARATE OUT YOU
KNOW THE SAFETY FROM COSTED. TO
LOOK AT WHAT NEEDED TO BE DONE
AND THEN TALK ABOUT HOW MUCH IS
IT GOING TO TAKE TO ADDRESS ON
TO A NEW ADDRESS A SAFETY ISSUE
SO WE'RE NOT ASKING THIS THAT
THE UTILITIES TO NOT DO WORK
THAT NEEDS TO BE DONE BECAUSE
ON. FOR TO SAVE MONEY BECAUSE
THAT WOULD BE. ANYONE HAS COME
FOOLISH I WOULD AGREE WITH
THAT- BUT BUT INSTEAD THERE
THERE MAY BE WHAT WE WHAT WE
WOULD LIKE TO SEE SO FOR
EXAMPLE YOU MAY BE ONE UTILITY
WILL SAY OKAY IT'LL COST US.
THIS AMOUNT OF MONEY TO ADDRESS
THE SAFETY ISSUE AND ANOTHER
UTILITY MIGHT SAY OH IT'S GOING
TO COST US YOU KNOW X. VERSES
Y. AMOUNT AND SO WE ARE OR
LET'S JUST SAY YOU KNOW THREE
TIMES AS MUCH FOR THE SAME TYPE
OF WORK WE WOULD WANT TO
UNDERSTAND WHAT WHAT IS DRIVING
THAT DISCREPANCY SO WHY IS IT
THAT ONE UTILITY CAN DO IT SO
MUCH MORE COST EFFECTIVELY THAN
THE OTHER. FOR THE SAME QUALITY
WORK AND SO THOSE ARE THE KIND
TACTIC ENQUIRIES THAT WE LOOK
AT WE ALSO LOOK AT THINGS LIKE-
IN THE PAST SO IF WE HAVE IF WE
HAVE. IF YOU TELL IS IN AND
BEEN AUTHORIZED MONEY AND
GENERATE CASE TO DO CERTAIN
WORK- BUT THEN SOMETIMES THEY
WILL COME BACK IN THE NEXT YEAR
SEE. AND ASK FOR MONEY TO DO
THAT WORK AGAIN OUR LEASE DO
PART OF THAT WORK. AND SO WE
WILL BE ASKED. OKAY ALREADY
GAVE YOU. THAT SO ARE. YOU SEE
DEAD SO WAR WAS THAT MY NIECE
WAS IT'S AN APPROPRIATELY- YOU
KNOW WHY DO YOU NEED THIS NEW
MONEY. AND THEN WE MIGHT ALSO
LOOK AT THINGS LIKE. YOU KNOW
AT INCENTIVE PLANS ARE OR
BONUSES FOR YOU KNOW THINGS
LIKE THAT THAT WE MIGHT THINK
THAT ARE. OUT OF PROPORTION
WITH WITH WHAT SHOULD BE SHOULD
BE GIVEN- SO THOSE ARE THE
KINDS OF THINGS. THAT WE'RE
LOOKING AT WORK WERE ABSOLUTELY
NOT WANTING TO. ADD SAFETY OR
CERTAINLY TO CUT PROGRAMS THAT
CAN. ASSIST ARE. VULNERABLE
THANK YOU THANK YOUR. THANK YOU
FOR THAT INFORMATION AND THANK
YOU MISTER CHAIR I WANTED TO-
INTEREST I GET YOUR THOUGHTS ON
ON SEVENTEEN TO EVERY SAY THE
CPC APPROVED JOB THE MERGER
BETWEEN SPRINT ANDT. MOBILE.
SO I WANTED TO KNOW WHERE THE
PUBLIC ADVOCATE'S OFFICE STANCE
ON THIS ISSUE AND- WERE THERE
ANY CONCERNS THAT WERE
HIGHLIGHTED BY YOUR OFFICE. YES
THANK YOU SENATOR FOR ASKING
THAT QUESTION- WE DID HAVE
CONCERNS ABOUT THE MERGER WE
OPPOSE THE MERGER. ON LARGELY
BECAUSE OF WHAT WE SAW WERE.
ANTI COMPETITIVE EFFECTS WE ARE
MY STAFF. VERY CLOSELY AT WHAT
THE MERGER WITH DO AND-
PARTICULARLY IN AREAS FOR A
LOWER INCOME CUSTOMERS AND FOR
PEOPLE WHO ARE ON PREPAID PLANS
AND WAT WE SAW IS THAT IF
THOSE TWO COMPANIES COMBINED
THERE WOULD BE. VIRTUALLY NO
COMPETITION IN IN THOSE AREAS
AND SO THAT WASN'T A BIG REASON
WHY WE OPPOSE THE MERGE. THANK
YOU FOR SHARING. THAT TIME MR
CHECK THANK YOU GO TO SENATOR
STERN. THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR
AND TAKING RECESS TACKLES FOR-
FOR YOUR YEARS OF WORK. WHAT A
VARIETY OF FRIENDS IN YOUR
OFFICE- MY QUESTION WAS- BUILT
OFF THE YEAR TWO THOUSAND
NINETEEN ANNUAL REPORT AND
REALLY APPRECIATED THE- FOCUS-
ON THE INVESTIGATION INTO SO
CAL GASES. MISMANAGEMENT
IDEALLY SO CANYON STORAGE
FACILITY AND YOUR SUGGESTIONS
AROUND- ENERGY SAFETY CULTURE.
OVER ALL I JUST WANTED TO GET A
SENSE I KNOW THIS FEELS LIKE
AND DISTANT MEMORY FOR MANY
PEOPLE BUT IT WAS ONE OF THE
LARGEST ENVIRONMENTAL DISASTERS
IN U. S. HISTORY SO THE MEMORY
STILL RAW AND PEOPLE ARE STILL
HURTING I'M JUST WONDERING.
HAVE YOU YET. ESTIMATED V. NOT
THE HEALTH IMPACT BUT THE RATE
IMPACT IN SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA
FROM. THE FAILURES AT THAT
STORAGE FACILITY HOW MUCH HAS.
THE BLOW OUT CLOSER AND
SUBSEQUENT CONSTRAINTS IMPACTED
SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA RATEPAYERS.
YEAH SO I'M GOING TO LET MY-
BRANCH MANAGER FOR SAFETY
ATTEMPT TO ANSWER THAT
QUESTION- IT. COULD NOT DO YOU
WANT TO JUMP AND YOU WANT TO
RAISE YOUR HAND THAT YOU MIGHT
HAVE TO BE CALLED AND I'M NOT.
POSITIVE HOW THIS WORKS NO
THAT'S FINE SHE THE THEY CAN
ANSWER THE QUESTION. ARE THEY
AVAILABLE. I'M NOT. MAKE HE MAY
HAVE TO RAISE HIS HAND IN THE
CHAT SO THAT THAT. THE OTHER
FOLKS AND THE I. T. FOLKS WHEN
IN INTO THAT PAN AWAY ON ARE
YOU ABLE TO HEAR ME NOW CAN
OPENER MIKE PLEASE. IF THEY CAN
IF THEY CAN SPEAK TO. THAT ARE
YOU ABLE TO HEAR ME SENATOR YES
YES THE RIVER THAT IS CERTAINLY
INFORMATION THAT WE CAN LOOK UP
AND GET TO YOU. THANK YOU AND
ANY FOR ANY FURTHER THOUGHTS ON
OVERALL THE SAFETY CULTURE AND-
THE- YOUR VIEWS ON THE
MANAGEMENT OF THE FIELD. IT'S
SOMETHING THAT WE'RE CURRENTLY
LOOKING INTO BOTH AS PART OF
THE ONLY SO CANYON
INVESTIGATION WHICH IS ONGOING
WE'VE PROVIDED TESTIMONY. IN
THAT PROCEEDING AND WE WILL
ALSO BE VERY ACTIVELY INVOLVED
IN THE SAFETY CULTURE
INVESTIGATION- THE COMMISSION
INITIATED THAT PROCEEDING LAST
YEAR- MY UNDERSTANDING IS
THEY'VE HIRED CONSULTANTS I'M
NOT PROCEEDING SHOULD RESUME
ONCE THEY HAVE COMPLETED THEIR
REPORT. LIKELY WITHIN THE NEXT
YEAR. THANK YOU. SENATOR STERN
THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR YOUR
QUESTION AND I APOLOGIZE WE
DON'T HAVE THAT ON THE TIP OF
OUR FINGERS BUT WE WILL GET WE
WILL GET BACK TO YOU FOR THAT
WITH THAT THANKS VERY MUCH VERY
WELL THANK YOU BUT THANK YOU
VERY MUCH FOR JOINING US AND
THANK YOU FOR YOUR PRESENTATION
APPRECIATED VERY MUCH AND I
ALSO APPRECIATE. THE WORK YOU
DO ON- SAVING REPAIRS- HUNDREDS
OF MILLIONS AND BILLIONS OF
DOLLARS IS JUST SOMETHING TO
CELEBRATE SO THANK YOU VERY
MUCH FOR THE WORK THAT YOU DO.
NOW GOING TO MOVE ON TO THE
NEXT PART OF OUR AGENDA WILL BE
HEARING FROM. THE THREE LARGEST
ELECTRIC UTILITIES. ALL THREE
UTILITIES HAVE PROVIDED COPIES
pWHICH ARE AVAILABLE IN THE
SENATE. ENERGY UTILITIES AND
COMMUNICATIONS COMMITTEE
WEBSITE. ALL THIS INFORMATION
CAN BE FOUND ON. THE SENATE
ENERGY UTILITIES AND
COMMUNICATIONS COMMITTEE
WEBSITE INCLUDING. THE ANNUAL
REPORTS- SO I WE COURTS THE
PUBLIC LET'S LISTEN IN AND TO
VISIT OUR WEBSITE IF YOU WANT
TO SEE ANY OF THESE DOCUMENTS
WITH THE INFORMATION. WE'RE
GOING TO BEGIN. WITH SAID IT
WILL GAS AND ELECTRIC. WE HAVE
BRANDY AUGUSTINE ALL HE'S THE
DIRECTOR OF THE FIRE SCIENCE
AND CLIMATE. ADAPTATION
DIVISION OF THAT THIS UTILITY.
IS MISTER DOUGLAS TINO ONLINE
OTHER AREAS OKAY EAT WELL YES I
AM- THANK YOU VERY MUCH MR
CHAIRMAN- THANK YOU VERY MUCH
COMMITTEE MEMBERS- AS THE
CHAIRMAN MENTIONED.
METEOROLOGIST I GUESS YOU KNOW
THAT AFTER A FIRE SCIENCE AN-
ADAPTATION PRESTIGE JEANNIE AND
I. APPRECIATE THE OPPORTUNITY
TO COME WITH HERE TODAY. TALK
ABOUT HOW WE CONTINUE TO STRIVE
FOR CONTINUOUS IMPROVEMENT. AT
ESTY JEANNIE. HOW WE ARE
EXECUTING ON OUR WILD FIRE
MITIGATION PLAN THIS YEAR- HOW
WE ARE PREPARING FOR PS PS. AND
THEN DOING ALL OF THIS WELL
REALLY KEEPING AN EYE ON THE
SAFETY OF OUR- EASY AND THE
COMMUNITIES THAT WERE SERVING.
IN LIGHT- OF KOBE NINETEEN SO I
WOULD INVITE YOU TO FOLLOW
ALONG. AS I MENTIONED I. YOU DO
A COPY OF THE- PRESENTATION.
WANTED JUST BY TAKING A LOOK AT
THE TWENTY TWENTY FIRE SEASON
OUTLOOK- WE DID SEE SIGNIFICANT
RAINFALL FORTUNATELY IN OUR
WATER YEAR IN SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA- LAST WINTER JUST UP
UNTIL A COUPLE MONTHS AGO EVEN
WITH SOME RECORD RAINFALL. HERE
IN SAN DIEGO COUNTY IN APRIL AS
A RESULT- WE'RE NOT SEEING THE
SAME LEVEL OF DROUGHT THAT IS
CURRENTLY BEING EXPERIENCED IN
SOME OF THE NORTHERN. PARTS OF
THE STATE- AND BECAUSE OF THIS
THE OFFICIAL FIRE AGENCY
FORECAST RIGHT NOW ARE FOR
BELOW NORMAL POTENTIAL FOR
SIGNIFICANT FIRE ACTIVITIES
THROUGH AUGUST. THAT SAD GRASS
FIRES HAVE STARTED ACROSS OUR
REGION WE HAD SEVERAL- JUST IN
THE LAST FEW DAYS- THOUGH THEY
ARE STILL SAYING SMALL. ALL
THAT FAR BELOW TEN ACRES- IN
THOSE ARE BEING BECAUSE JUST ON
ROADSIDES AND- OTHER NORMAL DAY
TO DAY ACTIVITY BUT WE DO
EXPECT THOSE WILL INCREASE IN
SIZE AND FREQUENCY AS WE HEAD
THROUGH- THE UP COMING SUMMER
MONTHS- AND THEN AS WE MOVE
TOWARDS LATE IN THE SUMMER AND
THE FALL. THAT IS WHEN WE
EXPECT TO THAT ALL OF OUR FUELS
WILL AGAIN BE VERY DRY AND WE
ARE ANTICIPATING- RED FLAG
WARNINGS AS WE HEAD INTO THIS
FALL. SO AS WE- I'M WE ARE AD
WE ARE AS PREPARED AS WE'VE
EVER BEEN. WE HAVE BEEN AT THIS
NOW FOR OVER A DECADE WHERE WE
HAVE BEEN WORKING TO MITIGATE
WILDFIRE REST ACROSS OUR
TERRITORY AND OVER A DECADE AGO
WE HAD AN APPROACH WHERE WE
WOULD FOCUS ON FINDING THE
HIGHEST RISK AREA OF OUR
SERVICE TERRITORY. IN A LOT OF
CASES THAT COULD BE OLDER
INFRASTRUCTURE SOME HAD SMALLER
WIRE AND BEING A METEOROLOGIST
WE WOULD IDENTIFY THE WINDIEST
AREAS AND WE WOULD HARDEN AT
FIRST. THIS APPROACH HAS PROVEN
SUCCESSFUL- ESSENTIAL TO THE
SAFETY OF OUR REGION I MEAN WE
CONTINUE THAT APPROACH TO THIS
DAY- SO WORK NEW WILD FIRE
MITIGATION PLANS HAVE A NEW
RENEWED EFFORT. AND THIS IS
REALLY TO REDUCE OR ELIMINATE
WITH TIME THE IMPACT THAT
PUBLIC SAFETY OUR SHOPS- HAVE
ON THE COMMUNITIES THAT WE
SERVE. AND WE'RE DOING THAT IN
A FEW DIFFERENT- WAYS IN WITH A
NEW. SENSE OF PROGRAMS- ACROSS
ONE MORE WEATHER STATIONS BUT
ALL OF THOSE WEATHER STATIONS
ARE COUPLED TO NEW SECTIONAL
ICING DEVICES SO THAT WE CAN
MAKE. PUBLIC SAFETY POWER SHUT
OFF SMALLER AND MORE TARGETED-
WE ARE IMPLEMENTING MULTIPLE
GENERATOR PROGRAMS. THOSE ARE
WORKING ALONG WITH THE S. CHIP
PROGRAM AND WE'RE TRYING TO
TARGET FOLKS THAT ARE NOT ABLE.
TO TAKE ADVANTAGE OF THAT
PROGRAM SO THAT WE CAN GET.
STATE OF RATIONING THE HAN OF
HIS OF OUR- IS ALSO. TO
DECREASE THE IMPACT OF PUBLIC
SAFETY POWERSHOT OFFICE.
MICROGRAPHS ARE BEING DEPLOYED
IN VERY STRATEGIC AREAS ACROSS
OUR BACK COUNTRY AND AGAIN THAT
IS TO BRING POWER IN CHECK
AREAS WHERE MAYBE THAT-
CIRCUIT. RUNS THROUGH VERY
STRONG WINDS TO GET THERE SO WE
SECTION HONESTY AND IN THE NEWS
MIKE REGRETS TO POWER THOSE
AREAS. AND ALL OF THIS WORK IS
HAVING AN IMMEDIATE IMPACT. ON
WHAT WE ANTICIPATE WILL BE OUR
P. S. P. S. IMPACT IN TWENTY
TWENTY. OVER THE LAST SIX
MONTHS SB JEANNIE BROUGHT
TOGETHER A TEAM OF STOCK
LEADERS ACROSS THE COMPANY USER
LEADERS FROM FIRE SCIENCE TEAM
FROM THE ENGINEERING TEAM. FROM
THE CUSTOMER OUTREACH TEAM WERE
ALL GETTING TOGETHER WITH A
COMMON PURPOSE OF HOW DO WE
MITIGATE THE IMPACT OF P. S. P.
S. THIS YEAR. AND WE ARE
IMPLEMENTING SOLUTIONS- IF WE
SAW THE SAME WEATHER CONDITIONS
THIS YEAR IN TWENTY TWENTY THAT
WE SAW ARMED TWENTY NINETEEN.
WE EXPECT ABOUT A 30% DECREASE
IN THE AMOUNT OF CUSTOMERS THAT
WOULD BE IMPACTED TO THIS YEAR.
IN ADDITION TO THAT 30%
DECREASE IN CUSTOMERS IMPACTED
WE ALSO ARE ANTICIPATING IN THE
SAME OF ACT SIX LAST SCHOOLS
WOULD BE IMPACTED. THREE LAST
FIRE STATIONS IN FORTY SEVEN.
CAN SITES ALONG WITH SIX WATER
FACILITIES- AND THAT'S JUST BY
THE BEGINNING OF THIS UPCOMING
FIRE SEASON THOSE NUMBERS
INCREASE BY THE END OF THE YEAR
AND THEN CONTINUE TO INCREASE
IN THE YEARS TO COME AS WE
CONTINUE. TO BUILD OUT THIS
PROGRAM. TRANSITIONING OVER TO
SITUATIONAL WARENESS THIS IS
BEEN A FOUNDATIONAL COMPONENT
OF OUR WILD FIRE MITIGATION
PROGRAM OVER THE LAST DECADE
IT'S REALLY HELPED US
UNDERSTAND THE RISKS SO THAT WE
CAN TARGET. ARE MEDICATIONS IN
A VERY FOCUSED WAY AND WE ARE
IMPLEMENTING FIRE SAFE THREE
POINT OH WHICH IS OUR NEXT
GENERATION OF SITUATIONAL
AWARENESS TO SUPPORT OUR FIRE
MITIGATION ACTIVITIES. SOME OF
THE ENHANCEMENTS THAT WE'RE
IMPLEMENTING THIS YEAR INCLUDE
THIRTY SECOND RECORDING
CAPABILITY FROM. HIGHER WHETHER
NETWORK WOULD YOU BE PASSING
OVER TWO HUNDRED STATE IS THIS
YEAR. AS WE HEARD EARLIER FROM
THE WILD FIRE SAFETY DIVISION
WE ARE IMPLEMENTING A-
SATELLITE WILD FIRE DETECTION
SYSTEM. BEING DONE TO
COLLABORATE WITH THE UNIVERSITY
OF WISCONSIN. WE ARE LEVERAGING
TEN YEARS OF WEATHER DATA OVER
A BILLION OBSERVATIONS RIGHT
NOW TO TRAIN A AYE BASED MODELS
TO GET EXTREMELY PRECISE
WEATHER FORECAST FOR THOSE
AREAS MOST PRONE TO PUBLIC
SAFETY POWER SHOT OFF. THIS
HELPS US TO COMMUNICATE
EFFECTIVELY WITH CUSTOMERS- AND
PROVIDE THE DATA CORPORATE
AMOUNT OF COMMUNICATION- AND
SEAT BACK OR PSP S. PROCESS.
WE'RE BUILDING OUT ON THE
CAMERA NETWORKS AND SHARING ALL
OF THAT INFORMATION OF COURSE
WITH THE FIRE AGENCIES.
PARTICULAR FOCUS HAS BEEN SUCH
AN ORANGE COUNTY- WHERE WE TAX
FOR NEW CAMERAS ALREADY
INSTALLED SO FAR IN GETTING IT
THIS YEAR TO SUPPORT. BUYERS TO
RACIAL AWARENESS ACROSS THAT
COURSE OF OURS TO. WE ARE
CONTINUING TO BUILD STRONG
ACADEMIC PARTNERSHIPS WITH.
ACADEMIC INSTITUTIONS ACROSS
THE STATE SAN JOSE STATE THE
SAN DIEGO SUPERCOMPUTING CENTER
AND SCRIPTS INSTITUTION OF
OCEANOGRAPHY AND THESE
PARTNERSHIPS HAVE BEEN DESIGNED
TO MOVE FIRE SCIENCE FORWARD
ESTABLISHMENT DATA SHARE SO ANY
INFORMATION THAT WE HAVE FROM
OUR FIRE SCIENCE PROFESSIONALS
ARE AVAILABLE TO EVERY
RESEARCHER EVERY FIRE AGENCIES.
EVERY NATIONAL WEATHER SERVICE
FORECASTER ACROSS THE STATE.
BETTER UNDERSTAND THE IMPACTS
THAT CLIMATE CHANGE MAY OUT ON
FUTURE P. S. P. S.
IMPLEMENTATION AND THEN VERY
IMPORTANTLY IT'S GOING TO HELP
TRAIN THE NEXT GENERATION OF
FIRE SCIENTIST THROUGH OUR
CALIFORNIA UNIVERSITY SYSTEM TO
SUPPORT THESE ISSUES. AS WE
MOVE INTO THE FUTURE. WE ARE
NOT JUST ENHANCING OUR
SITUATIONAL AWARENESS TOOLS WE
ARE ALSO ENHANCING. OUR AERIAL
RESOURCES AND THAT SUPPORTS
BOTH P. S. P. S. E. AND FIRE
SUPPRESSION EFFORTS. WE HAVE
ADDED IN H. ONE THIRTY FIVE-
WHICH IS A IN AIRBUS TO ENGINE
HELICOPTER AND THAT COMPLIMENTS
ARTS LEAD DIRECTLY TO SERVE AND
TO REDUCE THE IMPACTS OF PUBLIC
SAFETY OUR SHOT OFFICE THIS
HELICOPTER WILL HELP INSPECT
LINES. FOR A PUBLIC SAFETY
POWER SHUT OFF AND THEN IT WILL
BE DEPLOYED AFTER THE WEATHER
HAS SUBSIDED TO HELP RESTORE
POWER IN THOSE AREAS MORE
QUICKLY WE'VE ALSO ADDED A NEW
BLACK HAWK HELICOPTER TO THE
FLEET AND THAT IS GOING TO
ELIMINATE ANY INTERRUPTION OF
RESPONSE CAPABILITY DUE TO
MAINTENANCE- ON OUR OTHER
HELICOPTERS- SO WE CONTINUE TO
DEVELOP THE AERIAL RESOURCES.
TO SUPPORT THE COMMUNITY AND
AGAIN ALL OF THESE FIRE
MITIGATION HELICOPTERS ARE ALL
AVAILABLE AND DISPATCHED BY
COUNSEL JUST SUPPRESS ANY FIRES
ACROSS SAN DIEGO COUNTY. WE
HAVE BEEN VERY SPOKE ON THE
IMPACT THAT COLGATE NINETEEN-
AND PANDEMIC IS HAVING ON OUR
OPERATIONS OUR TEAMS HAVE BEEN
WORKING VERY CLOSELY I TO BE
SAFE AND CREATE A SAFE
ENVIRONMENT NOT ONLY FOR OUR
EMPLOYEES BUT FOR THE
COMMUNITIES SO WE'VE BEEN
IMPLEMENTING HEALTH SCREENINGS
AT OUR OPERATION CENTERS. WE'VE
BEEN DEPLOYING APPROPRIATE PP
ACROSS- ALL OF OUR WORK FORCE
YOU NEEDED AND SECUESTRO SYSTEM
OPERATORS WHERE THEY'VE BEEN ON
SHIPS AND FOR A TIME WERE
LIVING IN THE PARKING LOT- OF
OUR OPERATIONS CENTER- SO
THERE'S BEEN A REAL DEVOTED
EFFORT- TO KEEPING RELIABLE AND
SAFE ELECTRICITY. FOR SAN
DIEGO- WITH REGARDS TO PUBLIC
SAFETY POWER SHUT OFF WE DID
IMPLEMENTED A COMPANY WIDE GAP
ANALYSIS TO. GO THROUGH AND DO
A SURVEY FOR EVERY
ORGANIZATION. THAT HAS PART IN
A PSP ACTS WHICH IS A LOT
EIGHTEEN DIFFERENT
ORGANIZATIONS. AND WE TAPPED.
BE ASPECT OF IT MAKE SURE. THAT
THEY WOULD BE ABLE TO SAFELY
AND QUICKLY RESPOND HEY NOW
WE'RE BUILDING TRAINING AND
EXERCISES TO TEST THAT SO ALL
EXERCISES ARE BEING DESIGNED
FOR A COMPLEX BUT RITUAL EOC
RESPONSE TO MULTIPLE INCIDENTS.
NOT ONLY THE PANDEMIC BUT ALSO
P. R. E. S. AND ALSO THE
REALITY THAT WILDFIRE CARS ON
OUR LANDSCAPE THAT. TIME OF
YEAR. OUR RIGHT NOW FOR ALL OF
THOSE SENERE. AND WE MARK. TO
DO A VERY CALM. OUT REACH WHERE
ARE DOING LIVE WEBINARS IN
WE'RE DOING THOSE EDUCATE OUR
COMMUNITIES AND WE'RE WORKING
CLOSELY WITH COMMUNITY PARTNERS
SUCH AS CAL FIRE THE FIRE SAFE
COUNCILS IN OUR COMMUNITY
EMERGENCY RESPONSE TEAMS. TO
HELP MAKE SURE THAT WE HAVE A.
COORDINATED COLLABORATIVE
EFFORT. WE ARE SOME TALK ABOUT
MY COMMUNITY RESOURCE EARLIER
AND WE HAVE BEEN LOOKING VERY
CLOSELY AT WITH SOCIAL
DISTANCING HOW DO WE ADAPT OUR
C. R. SEASON WE HAVE DONE A LOT
OF CONTINGENCY PLANNING- SOME
OF IT DOES INCLUDE THAT. THE
CLEANING AND THE SOCIAL
DISTANCING BUT THEN ALSO
DIVERTING SOME OF THE TRAFFIC
TO DRIVE THROUGH RESOURCES AND
DATING WHAT WE OFFER TO OUR
CUSTOMER WE FOUND SOLAR POWERED
ATTERY CHARGERS- WE FOUND IN
BURGERS THAT ENABLE YOU TO DRAW
A LECTURER CITY OUT OF YOUR CAR
BATTERY TO CHARGE THINGS LIKE
YOUR PHONE. AND THESE ARE
THINGS THAT WE'RE ABLE TO HAND
TO PEOPLE IN CARE PACKAGES AS
THEY DRIVE THROUGH RATHER THAN
HAVING TO BRING EVERYBODY IN
THE CASE THAT WE ARE STILL. NOT
FULLY SOCIAL DISTANCING AS WE
GET INTO THAT ALL. WE'RE ALSO
IMPLEMENTING DRIVE THRU
WILDFIRE SAFETY FAIRS IN
COLLABORATION WITH WILD FIRE
STAKEHOLDERS ACROSS THE REGION-
IN THOSE WILL BE TAKING PLACE.
ON MULTIPLE OCCASIONS AND
LOCATIONS ACROSS OUR BACK
COUNTRY- TO HELP OUR COMMUNITY
REPAIR. THANK YOU AGAIN- MISTER
CHAIRMAN FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TO
ADDRESS THE COMMITTEE- AS WE
MOVE INTO THE QUESTION PORTION-
I'M PLEASED TO JOIN ASKED THE
GENIE DIRECTOR OF EMERGENCY
MANAGEMENT- HE'S ON THE CALL
WITH US AS WELL THAT. GEAR AND
THEN ALSO ESTY GENIES DIRECTOR
OF WILD FIRE MITIGATION AND
VEGETATION MANAGEMENT ON THAT
JONATHAN ROLLED THE MERRIAM-
AND WITH THAT THANK YOU AGAIN.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH AND THANK
YOU FOR YOUR VERY INFORMATIVE-
PRESENTATION I WANT TO THANK
YOU FOR ALL THE- INVESTMENTS
ASEAN. HAS MADE. AN IN AN OF
BEING BECOMING MORE RESPONSIVE
TO WILDFIRES THEM. THIS PROGRAM
IS WORKING I'VE I'VE WITNESSED
IT I'VE- BEEN THERE TO DO KIND
OF A OBSERVE. THE VIDEOS THAT
HAVE ACTUALLY TAKEN PLACE BY
THE CAMERAS A CATCH THESE
INCIDENTS AND THE FAST
RESPONSES. THAT LEAD TO PUTTING
UP THESE FIRES AND ESTROGEN IS
DEFINITELY SERVE. AS A MODEL
FOR OTHER UTILITIES ACROSS THE
STATE PROBABLY PROGRESSIVE
COUNTRY. IF THEY HAVE AREAS
THAT ARE FACING THE THREAT OF
THESE- DEVASTATING WILDFIRES
THE WORK THAT HAS TO JUNE
NEEDED. ACT ACTUALLY HAS BEEN
EXTREMELY PIONEERING. AND I
WANT TO THANK THE ENTIRE TEAM
AS TO UNIQUE FOR ABOUT THE
RESPONSIVENESS RECORDS SO. I
DON'T HAVE ANY QUESTIONS AT
THAT AT THIS TIME. IF THERE'S
ANYONE IN THE IN THE PANEL
PARTICULAR THAT WOULD LIKE TO
HAVE QUESTIONS WILL BEGIN WITH
CENTER MORE LIKE FULL OF BY.
CENTER RUBIO. THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR. AND THANK YOU AB. MR
D'AGOSTINO I JUST ON PAGE. I
GUESS I DON'T HAVE A PAGE
NUMBER- BUT IF FOLLOWS SHORTLY
AFTER YOUR QUESTION SECTION-
WILDFIRE RISK IN ES DE GENIES
SERVICE AREA AND- THE SERVICE
TERRITORY IS REFERRED TO AS H.
FTD WHAT WHAT IS THAT ACRONYM
STAND FOR. HI FIRESTAR WRAPPED
DISTRICT- THE FIRE MAPPING
EFFORTS CAME OUT OF THE PUBLIC
UTILITY COMMISSION- AND IT WILL
RATE ACT HERE TOO. AND HERE'S
THREE- AREAS OF THE HIGH FIRES
RIGHT DISTRICT HERE THREE-
BEING THAT IT HAS THE HIGHEST
FIRES RIGHT. THANK YOU AND
THEN- THE QUESTION I HAD FOR
MISS BOETTCHER IS. I KNOW
YOU'VE BEEN REALLY GOOD ABOUT
ADDRESSING YOUR AGING EQUIPMENT
AND YOU'VE BEEN VERY PROACTIVE-
BUT- THE LA TIMES RECENTLY SAID
THAT MORE THAN TWO THOUSAND
FIRES IN THREE AND A HALF YEARS
WERE CAUSED BY THE UTILITIES. I
WOULD SUSPECT THAT A VERY SMALL
PERCENTAGE OF THAT WOULD BE. IN
YOUR AREA BUT WITH SO MUCH
GOING ON RIGHT NOW WITH
SHELTERING IN PLACE AND- I A
THE QUESTION I HAD WAS WELL IF
WE NOT ONLY HAD A SHOT FROM
PLACE BUT IF WE LOST OUR
ELECTRICITY. ARE THERE FOR
LOSING. COLD STORAGE IN AND THE
ABILITY TO RECHARGE OUR PHONES-
FOR AN EXTENDED PERIOD TIME- I
JUST CURIOUS WHAT KIND OF.
EXTREME EMERGENCY AND AS AS T.
JEANNIE HAVE BEEN AND HOW WOULD
I OBTAIN A COPY. WITH THAT I
WOULD LIKE TO INVITE- ON TKO-
ESTY GENIES DIRECTOR OF
EMERGENCY MANAGEMENT- SAID ON
MUTE AND- I JOIN AN IMPOSSIBLE.
AND RUBIO ARE ARGUED YEAR THE
DIRECTOR OVER TO SEE MANAGING
FOR SDG ANY WE HAVE A VERY
COMPREHENSIVE BLACKSTAR POLICY
I AN STD ANY BAD RETAKES THE
COORDINATION AND COLLABORATION
ACROSS. A NUMBER OF OTHER
UTILITIES AND AGENCIES TO
AFFECT THE BULLY AND SAFELY
BRING BE SYSTEM BACK UP TO BE A
CATASTROPHIC FAILURE SYSTEM
WIDE. YEAH INCLUDES IN ANNUAL.
WHERE WE GET TOGETHER WITH ALL
THE STAKEHOLDER AGENCIES AND
ORGANIZATIONS THAT ARE
NECESSARY TO DO THAT
COLLABORATION AND ACTUALLY
WATCH THAT THAT PLANNED SO THAT
WHEN WE DO IF WE DO HAVE A
SITUATION ARISE EVERYBODY KNOWS
A ROLL EVERYBODY KNOWS YOUR
RESPONSIBILITY. AND IN FACT WE
DID HAVE AN ACTUAL OF BAND IN
TWO THOUSAND ELEVEN. WHERE ANY
ISSUE HAPPENED IN NEW BUT THAT
AFFECTED MEXICO PARTS OF
ARIZONA IN OUR ENTIRE SERVICE
TERRITORY AND THAT BLACK START
POLICY CAME OUT BECAUSE
EVERYBODY WAS SO. FAMILIAR WITH
THAT DO THE EXERCISES THAT LESS
THAN TWENTY FOUR HOURS WE WERE
ABLE TO SAFELY AND EFFECTIVELY
BRING BACK THE ENTIRE SAN DIEGO
REACH- SO WE DO HAVE A POLICY
IT'S VERY EFFECTIVE- IT IS IT
IS EXERCISED ANNUALLY AND- AND
WE CAN MEET THE NEEDS OF OUR
OUR COMMUNITY SERVICE. THANK
YOU THANK YOU VERY MUCH THANK
YOU MISTER. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
CENTER RUBIO. THANK YOU I AM I
WOULD- GO BACK TO SEND DANGER
SHARED RIGHT NOW I BELIEVE YOU
SURE THAT YOU SERVE EIGHT AT
LEAST EIGHTEEN ORGANIZATIONS IN
YOUR COMMUNITY AND YOU WERE
ABLE TO USE THAT TO A TO REALLY
UNDERSTAND THEIR NEEDS AND IT
WAS VERY COMPREHENSIVE MY
QUESTION IS IF YOU CAN SHOW
SOME EXAMPLES OF WHERE YOU TAKE
THAT INFORMATION AND REALLY
TRANSLATED INTO ACTIONS TO BE
ABLE TO ADDRESS THE NEEDS. OF
BILLS ORGANIZATIONS. YES AND
THANK YOU FOR THE QUESTION THE
B. EIGHTEEN ORGANIZATIONS ARE
ACTUALLY DEPARTMENTS WITHIN SDG
AND EIGHTY. SO THAT THAT
PARTICULAR SURVEY WHICH I WAS
MENTIONING I'M WAS IN TROUBLE
TO THE COMPANY IN THE OBJECTIVE
WAS TO ENSURE THAT ALL ASPECTS
OF OUR PUBLIC SAFETY POWER
SHOPPING HOW WE- HOW WE END UP
SERVING THE COMMUNITIES WHEN
THAT HAPPENS MAKE SURE THAT ALL
ASPECTS ARE ABLE TO BE
CONDUCTED SAFELY- DURING SOCIAL
DISTANCING. WHILE WORKING
REMOTELY IN SOME CASES- SO THAT
WAS ACTUALLY THE SURVEY THAT I
WAS SPEAKING UP THERE- THAT
BEING SAID WITH OUR COMMUNITY
RESOURCE CENTERS ARE WILD FIRE
SAFETY FAIRS- IAN'S ARE ARE
OPEN HOUSES WHICH ARE TOWN
HALLS WHICH ARE NOW WILD WOMEN
OURS THIS YEAR. WE HAVE BEEN
WORKING VERY CLOSELY WITH FIRE
SAFE COUNCILS COMMUNITY
EMERGENCY RESPONSE TEAMS IN THE
FIRE AGENCIES. TO GET THEIR
FEEDBACK NOT JUST ON THE
CONTENT AND HAVING A UNIFIED
SHARED MESSAGE ON THAT GOES TO
THE BACK COUNTRY HAVE SEEN
DIEGO- BUT ALSO. ALSO ON
EXACTLY HOW WE'RE GOING TO I'M
KIND OF COORDINATE. YES THANK
YOU FOR THAT THAT'S ON THE
SUBJECT THANK YOU DO WE HAVE
ANYONE ELSE IN THE COMMITTEE
THANK YOU MISTER DAVIS TINA-
NOVEL OF. PEOPLE WANT TO. OF
WELL WITH THE SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA EDISON WE HAVE FILL
HERRINGTON HE'S THE SENIOR VICE
PRESIDENT OF A TRANSMISSION AND
DISTRIBUTION HE'S JOINED BY
JILL ANDERSON THE SENIOR VICE
PRESIDENT OF CUSTOMER SERVICE
AND- OR THE AVAILABLE OKAY
THERE THEY ARE OKAY IF YOU
COULD WELCOME AND THANK YOU
VERY MUCH FOR PARTICIPATING
TODAY AM PLEASED. PLEASE SIR
PRESENT WHEN YOU'RE READY. IS
IT YOUR A YOUR I THINK YOUR
COMPUTER MIGHT BE MUTED YOUR ON
MUTE IN ON OUR END. OKAY WE NOW.
WE CAN HEAR YOU JUST FINE OKAY
THANK YOU- THANK YOU VERY MUCH-
GOOD MORNING- CHAIR HUESO AND
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE ON
PHIL HARRINGTON'S YOU RICE
PRESIDENT OF TRANSMISSION AND
DISTRIBUTION SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA EDISON- PERCENT
CALIFORNIA'S IN AND IT IS A
PLEASURE TO BE WITH YOU HERE
TODAY I'LL BE REMOTELY- ROLE
MAKING CONCESSIONS- AND IT JUST
HAS TO GO IN NINETEEN BUT- BUT
IT IS GOOD TO BE WITH YOUR WITH
YOUR TODAY. I WANT TO THANK YOU
FOR HOLDING A HEARING AND
GIVING SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA.
EDISON THE OPPORTUNITY TO SHARE
WITH YOU. I'M ACTUALLY MADE OUT.
THIS YEAR AND YEAR ON OUR LAW
FIRM. PROGRAM THIS INCLUDES
ACTING ON THE LESSONS LEARNED
FROM LAST YEAR'S UP YES YES
EVENTS. WE PROVIDE YOUR
PRESENTATION I WILL
OCCASIONALLY REFERRED TO IT AS
WE GO THROUGH THIS BUT- BUT-
REALLY I'LL BE REFERRING TO-
THREATENED TO A NUMBER OF
OCCASIONS THE THINGS THAT ARE
IN THAT SLIDE. I WILL COVER
TODAY THE WORK WE'VE DONE OVER
LAST YEAR AGAIN BEFORE AN OFFER
A MITIGATION PLAN. I WIT ME
HERE TODAY IS- JOE ANDERSON OUR
SENIOR VICE PRESIDENT CUSTOMER
SERVICE I SHALL BE ADDRESSING
SOME OF THE PARTICULAR AREAS OF
OUR YES YES PROGRAMS. I'LL
COVER SOME OF THOSE ALSO.
INITIALLY HANDLING THE CUSTOMER
CARE ELEMENTS WHICH WHICH
EXCHANGING CONTINUE RECALL. AS
WE- AS WE FULLY DEVELOPED YES
YES PROGRAMS. NOT AT. SAFETY IS
OUR TOP PRIORITY AND IT IS A
VALUE WE LIVE DAILY- WE ARE
COMMITTED TO CONTINUOUS
IMPROVEMENT ALSO SO IT IS- IS
CLEAR AND IMPORTANT. THAT WE
USE THESE OPPORTUNITIES TO
LEARN AND CONTINUING PROGRAM.
THAT'S WHY WELL I'M HERE TO
TALK TO YOU TODAY. I AM EQUALLY
IF NOT MORE INTERESTED IN AND
WE'RE MORE INTERESTED IN
UNDERSTANDING WHAT YOUR
CONCERNS AND FEEDBACK YOU MIGHT
HAVE OUR PROGRAMS. NOW THE PSP
RESIDENTS TO TRANSPIRE LAST
YEAR POSE A HARDSHIP FOR MANY
OF OUR CUSTOMERS AND OUR
COMMUNITIES. HOWEVER WE ARE
COMMITTED TO MINIMIZE THE
IMPACT. OF THOSE EVENTS GOING
FORWARD AND MINIMIZE HE- IMPACT
TO OUR CUSTOMERS AND OUR
COMMUNITIES AS WE MOVE FORWARD
WITH THE SPS. LAST YEAR WHEN I
SPOKE TO THIS COMMITTEE- WE
TALK ABOUT THE MAGNITUDE OF
THOSE EVENTS WE HAVE FIVE
MILLION CUSTOMERS OR METER
ACROSS OUR SERVICE TERRITORIES.
OF THOSE. ROUGHLY A HUNDRED
TWENTY TWO THOUSAND WERE
IMPACTED WHICH EQUATES TO
ROUGHLY 2% OF OUR CUSTOMER
BASE. NOW WHEN WE COMPARE THAT
TO A WILDFIRE RISK AREA- OVER A
THIRD OF OUR TERRITORY USING
HIGH FIRE RISK AREA SO WE GET
SIGNIFICANT- NOW WE MADE A
NUMBER PROGRAM IMPROVEMENT
SINCE WE LAST SPOKE AND WE WILL
BE SENDING A TIME- TO. IN TIME
TO TALK ABOUT THOSE. AND THE
COVER A WIDE RANGE OF
ACTIVITIES FROM- SITUATIONAL
AWARENESS- TO MORE AGGRESSIVE
HARDENING OF CERTAIN PARTS OF
OUR CIRCUITS. OPERATIONAL
IMPROVEMENTS SAID INCLUDE
SOMETHING WE CALL SWITCHING
PLAYBOOKS- THAT ENABLES US IN
PSP EVENTS TO MEN FIVE
MINIMIZING IMPACT AND SCOPE OF
THOE EVENTS. AND WE TAKE YOU
IN NASA DRAMATIC STEPS IN THE
CUSTOMER CARE AREAS INCLUDING
IMPROVEMENTS ARE WEBSITE-
INFORMATION FLOW INFORMATION
SHARING ACROSS OUR COMMUNITIES
AND WITH OUR KEY STAKEHOLDERS.
NOW AT IF WANT TO COMPARE AND
STEP BACK TO WHAT IS OUT ON ME.
IF WE LOOK SIMILAR PATTERNS AND
WE HAD LAST YEAR- WE WOULD SEE
REDUCTION 30% INTEREST IN THE
SAME NUMBER SAN DIEGO GAS
ELECTRIC SAW. THE NUMBER OF
CUSTOMERS IMPACTED BY PSP S.
VANCE. NOTHING FOCUS ON THOSE
ONE HUNDRED TWENTY TWO THOUSAND
CUSTOMERS WE WOULD EXPECT OUT
OF AT LEAST TWENTY TWO THOUSAND
THOSE TO NOT BE TEST ALL IPSP
US OF AND- AGAIN IN SIMILAR
WEATHER. WEATHER CONDITIONS SO
PRETTY SIGNIFICANT IMPROVEMENT
AND WE'RE NOT STOPPING THERE
WERE GONNA CONTINUE TO WORK
HARD TO MAKE THE STUFF. UNLESS
A PACKAGE OR CUSTOMERS. THAT
WHILE THERE WERE LESSONS
LEARNED AGAIN WE'VE BEEN
TALKING ABOUT THIS TODAY- THE
CUSTOMER SERVICE OPERATIONS
FROM. LAST YEAR'S EVENT SHOW
THAT WE'RE. ON THE RIGHT TRACK
WHEN IT COMES TO.
INFRASTRUCTURE HARDENING AND R.
O. MANY. FOR SOME OF THE
NUMBERS I CITED BEFORE THERE
ALSO SOME OF THE INSPECTION
RESULTS WE SAW AFTER PSP A
SPENCER CARD. A RECENT MONTHS
WE'VE ALSO ADDRESS THE
TREMENDOUS IMPACT THE CODE
NINETEEN IS GOING TO HAVE. OR
COULD HAVE. ON BOTH OUR
WORKFORCE AND OUR CUSTOMER
BASE- MUCH- MUCH LIKE THE OTHER
UTILITIES WHAT WE HAVE DONE IS
SEQUESTER WORKFORCE IS TO MAKE
SURE THAT. THEY'RE SAFE AND
ABLE TO DO THEIR JOBS ARE WE
DONE THINGS INCLUDING STAGGERED
SHIFTS ISSUED PERSONAL
PROTECTIVE EQUIPMENT CHANGED
OUR WORK PRACTICES- AND WORK
CLOSELY WITH OUR COMMUNITY
PARTNERS AS WE KNEW OUT AGES
DURING. THE THIRD HOLE A
CRITERIA SO WE HAVE WORKED HARD
TO KEEP TO YOUR CRITICAL WALLS
ARE MITIGATION WORK. IN THE
SAME TIME MINIMIZE THE IMPACT
THESE OUT OF JUST HAVE OUR
CUSTOMERS AND OUR COMMUNITIES-
AND THIS ALSO GOES INTO
PERSPECTIVE YOU KNOW WHAT WE'LL
BE DOING WHEN THE SPS OFFENSE
HAPPENS. YOU'LL BE ABLE TO TALK
A LITTLE BIT MORE. ABOUT THINGS
WE DON'T SPECIFICALLY. UNITIES
AND HOW. OF PULLING INTO. A
EVENTS ALONG WITH GOVERNOR. IN
OUR THANK YOU. AND THAT'S THE
CURRENT CAN DO REALLY BEING THE
P. S. P. S. WILL BE PART OF
OUR- WAY OF DEALING WITH
EXTREME EVENTS. FOR THE
FORESEEABLE UTURE- NOW WHAT
WE'RE FOCUSED ON MINIMIZING IT
WE BELIEVE IN CREDIT AND THE
CONTINUED INVESTMENT-
IMPROVEMENT STORE GREG- THINGS
LIKE COVERKING DOCTOR
SPECIALIZING DEVICES. ALL THOSE
WE CRITICAL TORE MITIGATION
EFFORTS AND PARTICULARLY THIS
REDUCING THE IMPACT FUTURE YES.
AND THE ONGOING WORK IS-
REFLECTED OUR TWENTY TWENTY
MALL FOR MEDICATION PLAN AND
ALSO IN OUR EYES YOUR C. WHICH
IS NOW PENDING BEFORE THE
COMMISSION. NOW AS WE HAVE BEEN
DOING THE WORK THIS LEGISLATURE
AND OUR REGULATORS EXCEPT FOR
US WE'RE ALSO FINDING WAYS TO
DO MORE. S. IS TWENTY EIGHTEEN
WE INSTALLED MORE THAN SIX
HUNDRED FIFTY MILES COVER
CONDUCT. WE'VE INSTALLED SEVEN
HUNDRED WEATHER STATIONS SO FAR
WITH PLANS TO INSTALL MANY MORE.
WE ALSO INSTALL HUNDRED SIXTY
HIGH DEFINITION CAMERAS THEY
ARE VERY SIMILAR. TO THE ONES
THAT BRIAN JUST MENTIONED-
THOSE TWO OR SHARE WITH OUR
FIRST RESPONDER COMMUNITY AID
US IN RESPONDING TO FIRES WHEN
THEY OCCUR. AND HELPING OUR
FIRST RESPONDERS THAT
INFORMATION DESPITE THOSE FIRES
QUICKLY AND EFFECTIVELY. OUR
TWENTY TWENTY PLANS GOING TO
BUILD ON WHAT WE'VE DONE SO FAR
TWENTY NINETEEN IN THE YEARS
PRIOR. THAT WERE SIGNIFICANTLY
STEPPING UP DEPLOYMENTS THINGS
LIKE COVER CONDUCTOR GOING TO
MOVE SWIFTLY DELIBERATELY- TO
REDUCE WILDFIRE IN. THE IMPACTS
OF PS PS. ACOSTA MURS IN
ADVANCE OF THIS YEAR'S FIRE
SEASON. WE DID MENTION WE
ALREADY HAD ONE OF AND WHAT WE
DID STAND UP IN PREPARATION FOR
A LOT HARDER THAN. WE DO NOT
HAVE TO BE ENERGIZED. NUMBER
TWENTY TWENTY PLAN WE PROPOSE
THREE POINT EIGHT BILLION
DOLLARS. INVESTED OVER THE NEXT
THREE YEARS. TO REDUCE THE
CHANCE OUR EQUIPMENT ARE LIKE
WHAT WOMEN. IS THE CAUSE OF THE
FIRE. NOW IT ALSO- COLLATERAL
IT WILL IMPACT AND REDUCE THE
AMOUNT OF THE S. P. S. WE HAVE
OVER THAT TIME FOR. SOMEONE
HIGHLIGHTS OF THE CORE AREAS IN
OUR WATER MITIGATION PLAN.
STANDS FINDS FIVE THREE
SIXTEEN- THIS IS JUST A
SAMPLING THERE'S A LOT OF
DETAIL ON THE SIDES ENCOURAGE
EVERYONE TO LOOK THREE DOES.
EVER SINCE. SEC KNOWLEDGES AND
MANY OTHER PROGRAMS FROM WHAT I
WANT TO TALK ABOUT. SOME OF THE
CORE ONES HERE TODAY. THIS IS
ALL BAY. AND PRESS. ON FOUNDER
FOR THIS IS RISK MODELING. THAT
WE USE TOOLS THAT WE HAVE THE
TARGET AWHILE FARM RELATIONS
EFFECTIVELY. AND TARGETS AND
HELPS US- DECIDE WHAT THINGS TO
DO FIRST. THESE TOOLS LEVERAGE
MACHINE LEARNING. AND HIGH
LEVEL DATA ANALYTICS- HELP US
PREDICT THE PROBABILITY
WITNESSES FOR EXAMPLE- WE ALSO
LOOK AT THE WORLD HISTORICAL
FIRE INFORMATION. AND WHAT WE
EXPECT TO SEE AS A WILDFIRE
CONSEQUENCE YOU MAY HAVE HEARD
OF THE REACTS MODELING- THIS
ENABLES MORE PRECISE. SWORD
THIS IS OF ALL SIGNIFICANTLY
OVER THE LAST COUPLE OF YEARS.
AND TO GIVE YOU AN EXAMPLE. AT
ONE POINT. WE WERE TARGETING
HIGH FIRE AREA MITIGATION SUCH
AS COPPER CONDUCTOR. A CIRCUIT
LEVEL. SERVICE MAY BE SEVERAL
MILES. OF MILES. WE NOW TURN IT.
ON SPAN. SPANS OF. THREE
HUNDRED FEET. SO MUCH MORE
PRECISION AND WHEN WE DEPLOY.
THESE RISK MITIGATION. ANOTHER
EXAMPLE YOU RISK. RISK
ANALYTICS. WE'RE DOING IS ARTS.
USUALLY OUT LAST YEAR WE
INSPECT 1% OR AND HIGH RISKY.
NOW WE THOUGHT THERE WAS A
BECAUSE WE HAVE HAD A COPPER IS
OUTSIDE OF THE ROUTINE
INSPECTIONS THAT WE HAVE DONE
HISTORICALLY AND THOSE THAT
WE'VE AUGMENTED FOR FIRE
PREVENTION. OVER THE HISTORY OF
OUR OPERATIONS. THIS YEAR WE'RE
GOING TO DO IS TARGET THE
HIGHEST RISK CIRCUITS THAT ARE
IN THAT CATEGORY I'M GOING TO
DO THAT BOTH ON THE GROUND AND
IN THE AIR USING DRONES
HELICOPTERS. NOW WHAT THIS
MEANS IS FOR COMPLIANCE
PURPOSES IN THE PAST
DISTRIBUTION EQUIPMENT WOULD BE
INSPECTED EVERY FIVE YEARS
TRANSMISSIONS WOMEN WOULD BE
INSPECTED EVERY THREE YEARS.
THIS HIGH RISK OF WHAT WE
EXPECTED EVERY YEAR AND NOW ON
THE GROUND AND BY AIR THIS IS A
TREMENDOUS STEP UP IN THE
AMOUNT OF INSPECTIONS WERE
DOING AT THE DATA WERE SO YOU
HELP US TO. BETTER MEDICATIONS
AND MORE EFFECTIVE THE SPS
DEPLOYMENT. NOT A TECH FRONT AS
HE DEPLOYING. TO DETECT FAULTS
BEFORE THEY OCCUR. DISTRIBUTION
FALLS. ANTICIPATION FOR EXAMPLE
IS USING DATA ANALYTICS TO
PROTECT FALLS. IN ADVANCE OF
THEIR OCCURRENCE BASED ON
SIGNATURES WERE SEEING ON THE
LINES AND TAKE ACTION BEFORE
THEY OCCUR. OTHER WORDS FOR
SMOKERS. WHEN YOU DO THAT AGAIN
YOU'RE REDUCING THE CHANCES
FIRES AND EVEN IMPROVING THE
OPERATIONS OR SYSTEM. DURING
PSP S. OFFENSE. DOWNTURN OF
INFRASTRUCTURE HARDENING WE
CONTINUE REFINE AND TARGET
SECTIONAL ICING AS A KEY
COMPONENT OF OUR PROGRAM.
ESTARá CLEAN THIS IS BEEN A
CORE ELEMENT OF OUR GREAT
MONETIZATION ELEMENTS IT HAS
BOTH RELIABILITY PS PS.
BENEFITS TO US SO WE'VE BEEN
DOING THIS FOR YEARS BUT IT'S
STILL A PROGRAM WE'RE TARGETING
MORE MORE OF IT BASED ON
LEARNING THAT WE'RE SEEING FROM
PSP SSETS. THAT CONTINUES TO
BE A CAR OR PROGRAM. BUT OUR
PROGRAM THE MORBIDITY TO AS A
CORE ELEMENT OF OUR
INFRASTRUCTURE HARDING IS COVER
CONDUCTOR INSULATION NOW OVER
THE LAST TWO YEARS INSTALL FIVE
HUNDRED MILES OF THIS BUT WE'RE
TARGETING SEVEN HUNDRED MILES
FOR THIS YEAR WITH THE REST OF
TARGETED FORTY FIVE HUNDRED
MILES OVER THE NEXT THREE YEARS
THAT AGAIN THIS ELIMINATES THE
REST OF MOST- EMISSIONS FROM
OUR LINES AND IT'S VERY COST
EFFECTIVE I'M USING A RISK
ANALYTICS TO TARGET THE HIGHEST
RISK SEGMENTS OUR SYSTEM. IN
OUR FOCUSED ON COST EFFECTIVE
SOLUTIONS LIKE COVER CONDUCTOR.
WE'RE ALSO LOOKING AT
UNDERGROUND AS A MEANS OF
REDUCING RISK FROM WILDFIRES
ARE LOOKING SELECTIVE CRITERIA
THINGS SUCH AS EXCESSIVE P. SPS
ADVANCE ONLINE OR LIMITED
EGRESS. IN A CERTAIN AREAS WERE
UNDER BROWN IS A BETTER
SOLUTION AND WE'LL MOVE
FORWARD. AND WE'RE DOING
ANALYTICS AND MANY FOR SOME
SEGMENTS HONOR CIRCUIT FOR
DEPLOYMENT TWENTY TWENTY ONE.
NOW FOR A MORE- IT'S A
TRADITIONALLY- VEGETATION
MANAGEMENT IS STILL KEY COURSE
OF OUR PROGRAM AS WE LOOK AT
SOURCES OF IGNITIONS
PREDOMINANTLY FOR SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA EDISON THERE WHEN
OBJECTS COME INTO CONTACT WITH
OUR LINES SOME OF THOSE ARE
VEGETATION SO INCREASING OUR
CLEARANCES AND REMOVING TREES
WHO A NEW PROGRAM THAT WE
DEVELOP THE LAST COUPLE OF
YEARS WHICH IS A HAZARD TREE
MANAGER PROGRAM REDUCING THE
THREAT OF IGNITIONS ALSO
CREATING BASICALLY- FIRE BREAKS
AROUND OUR POLLS COUPLE HOLD
CLEARING BRUSH SO THAT'S A
PROGRAM WE HAVE SIGNIFICANTLY
RAMPED UP TO REDUCE THE CHANCES.
OF OUR EQUIPMENT BECAUSE YOU.
FINALLY WITH RESPECT SITUATE
AWARENESS. AGAIN I MASON SIXTY
WEATHER'S. HI DEVON CAMERA.
ALSO THE SEVEN HUNDRED WHICH
WHETHER SPACES WE JUST ALL
INSTALLED BY THE WAY BY THE END
OF THE YEAR WE EXPECT WILL HAVE
THE DENSEST. WEATHER NETWORK.
IN THE COUNTRY SO WHEN YOUR
INFORMATION NETWORK IN THE
COUNTRY WILL USE THAT DATA. AND
YOU JUST WEATHER STATIONS WILL%
INSTALLFOR THE REMAINDER OF
THIS YEAR IN THE COMING YEARS.
TO INFORM OUR ANALYTICS AND ARE
MODELING OUR WEATHER MODELING
HELP US MAKE GOOD DECISIONS
BOTH ON WHERE WE DEPLOY
INFRASTRUCTURES. AN IMPORTANT
FOR THIS PROCEEDING HOW WE
DECIDE WHEN AND HOW AND HOW
LARGE. PSP IS ENTITIES. NOW
IMPORTANTLY ARE TWENTY TWO PLAN
INCLUDES THE MEASURE TO
TRANSPARENCY PUBLIC IN ORDER
STAKEHOLDERS. AND THEY'LL
UNABLE ARE REGULATED TO MONITOR
OUR PROGRESS HER PERFORMANCE.
WE JUST TRANSPARENCY BETWEEN
AETOLIAN A REGULATOR IS
CRITICAL. NOW WILL LEAD TO AN
UNDERSTANDING CLEAR
UNDERSTANDING OUR PROPOSED
MEDICATIONS AND INVESTMENT
CIRCLES REDUCING THE REST AND
PROTECTING CUSTOMERS FROM
UNNECESSARY COSTS THE END OF
THE DAY BECAUSE OUR OBJECTIVES
SO YOU FOR LIBEL AND AFFORDABLE
OUR WE NEED TO MITIGATE MALL
HIGHER RISK. AT THE SAME TIME.
AND WE'VE BEEN AT THE FOREFRONT
OF WILD FIRE MITIGATION FOR
MANY YEARS NOW. NOW AFTER THE
DEVASTATING DEVASTATING CARBON
TO TWENTY SEVENTEEN RENDON TOOK
A PROGRAM ARE REALLY SAFETY
RESOURCES PLAN. AND THIS WAS IN
THE ADVANCE OF THE MORE
COMPREHENSIVE- WILDFIRE
MITIGATION PLANS THAT WE KNOW
OF TODAY. BUT AT THAT TIME FOR
THOSE WERE DEVELOPED WE DECIDED
WE NEEDED TO MOVE EXPEDITIOUSLY
TO REDUCE THE THREAT OF
WILDFIRES ON OUR LIVES. THIS IS
WHAT LED TO THE INITIAL
DEPLOYMENT OF COVER CONDUCTOR
AND ALSO REFINED EVEN MORE
SECTION LIES AND- INVESTMENTS
SITUATIONAL AWARENESS. NOW
ABOVE AND BEYOND APPROACH TO
THIS REFLECTS OUR SENSE OF
URGENCY OUR SENSE OF MISSION.
THIS REALLY IS JOB ONE FOR
SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA AND ITS-
AND ITS REFLECTION OF THE
SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA. EDISON MEN
AND WOMEN WHO DEDICATED
COUNTLESS HOURS AND EFFORTS.
CONTINUE TO DO SO- AS WE
CONTINUE TO MONITOR AND MODIFY
OUR PRACTICES AND OUR
PROCEDURES. TO MITIGATE AND
REDUCES THE GOVERNMENT. AND WE
WERE APPRECIATE IT. TO SPEAK
YOU HERE TO. LOOKING FOR.
FEEDBACK ON OUR PROGRAM. AND
WHAT WE'RE DOING WE ALSO WANT
TO THANK YOU AND CALLING TO ME
W. LOCAL FORTY SEVEN FOR. TO
GET ALL THIS WORK DONE I ALSO
WANT TO THANK OUR FIRST
RESPONDER COMMUNITY. I'VE BEEN
WORKING WITH- CLOSELY TO HELP
US AND FORM WHAT WE DO. IN OUR
QUEST TO REDUCE THE THREAT OF
WILDFIRES. NOW LOOK FOR YOUR
QUESTIONS ARE PROGRAM WHAT
WE'RE DOING LIKE TURNS OVER
NOW. JOE ANDERSON TO TALK IN
MORE DETAIL ABOUT OUR PS FOUR
VS PS PROGRAMS AND YOU PROMISE
WE MADE IN THE CUSTOMER.
SERVICE IN OUR. FOR CUSTOMER
SUPPORT. THANK YOU. THANK YOU
SPELL. MANY HEAR ME YES GREAT
SOUND GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIR AND
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE I'M
JILL ANDERSON I AM THE SENIOR
VICE PRESIDENT FOR CUSTOMER
SERVICE AT SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA
EDISON I JUST WANT TO START OUT
SAYING THAT YOU WE ABSOLUTELY
UNDERSTAND THAT CUSTOMERS ARE
COUNTING ON OUR POWER NOW MORE
THAN EVER AS MANY PEOPLE BEFORE
ME TODAY HAVE MENTIONED YOU
KNOW WE ARE COMMUNICATING WITH
OUR CUSTOMERS SAID
DISCONNECTIONS FOR NON PAYMENT
OF AND TEMPORARILY SUSPENDED.
WE'RE ALSO CONTINUING CRITICAL
WORK ONLY WHERE IT'S NEEDED FOR
PROTECTING THE PUBLIC IN
HARDENING THE GREATEST STILL
HAS TALKED ABOUT AND OF COURSE
WHAT WE'RE HERE TODAY TO TALK
ABOUT OUR PUBLIC SAFETY
POWERSHOT ARE. STILL MENTION WE
HAVE FIVE MILLION CUSTOMER
ACCOUNTS AND LAST YEAR IN THE
MOST YOU KNOW THE LARGEST PS PS
EVENTS THAT WE HAD A LESS THAN
ONE HUNDRED THOUSAND CUSTOMERS
WERE IMPACTED NOW IF YOUR ONE
OF THOSE CUSTOMERS YOU NEXT 2%
OF THE CUSTOMERS WE SERVE AND
THAT DOESN'T GIVE YOU A LOT OF
COMFORT BECAUSE ANY CUSTOMER
THAT EXPERIENCING A POWER
OUTAGE IT'S OBVIOUSLY YOU'RE
VERY IMPORTANT AND VERY
IMPACTFUL FOR THEM AND WE
RECOGNIZE THAT. WHICH IS WHY
WE'RE WORKING VERY HARD TO
MINIMIZE THE FREQUENCY AND THE
IMPACT OF THESE EVENTS WE'RE
ALSO ESTABLISHING EVEN STRONGER
PARTNERSHIPS AND RELATIONSHIPS
WITH LOCAL AND STATE
AUTHORITIES COUNTY AND STATE
LEADERSHIP AND EMERGENCY
MANAGEMENT OTHER FIRST
RESPONDERS. OUR YES WE BEGIN
LOOK AT. EVENT WE DO OUT REACH
WITH PARTNER THREE DAYS IN A
TALK ABOUT ANY POTENTIAL
CONCERNS THEY MIGHT HAVE WITH
PUBLIC SAFETY AND WE- NEED TO
COMMUNICATE WITH THEM OUT IN
ADVANCE. ALSO ALL OF THIS IN
ADDITIONAL COORDINATION IN THE
FORECAST DATA THAT WAS TALKED
ABOUT THAT'S HELPING AS IT BE
BETTER ABOUT SERVING OUR
CUSTOMERS. IT'S A WE REACH OUT
TO CUSTOMERS THAT ARE AT RISK
FOR A POSSIBLE DE ENERGY
STATION FORTY EIGHT HOURS IN
ADVANCE. AND I WANT TO TALK
JUST FOR THE NEXT MINUTE ABOUT
FOUR KEY AREAS WHERE WE
LISTENED TO YOUR FEEDBACK WE
LEARN FROM OUR EXPERIENCES AND
WE'RE ADOPTING OUR APPROACH FOR
TWENTY TWENTY. AND THOSE FOUR
AREAS ARE ABOUT COMMUNICATION
ABOUT BACKUP POWER THE CUSTOMER
CARE ITSELF AND THEN COMMUNITY
PARTNERSHIPS. SO THE FIRST ONE
AND I WOULD SAY IT'S DEFINITELY
THE BIGGEST LEARNING FOR US.
WAS LESS YEAR WAS THAT WE
REALLY NEEDED TO PROVIDE MORE
INFORMATION TO CUSTOMERS IN
MORE CONVENIENT WAY. AND SO
WE'VE RESPONDED TO THIS BY
EXPANDING NOTIFICATION NOT JUST
TO CUSTOMERS THAT OUR ACCOUNT
HOLDERS BUT NOT ACCOUNT HOLDERS
ARE YOU MIGHT HAVE THREE OR
FOUR PEOPLE LIVING IN A HOUSE
THAT ONLY ONE OF THEM IS. AN
ACCOUNT HOLDER AND SO WE'VE
DONE THINGS LIKE EXPANDED OUR
USE OF SOCIAL MEDIA PLATFORMS
LIKE NEXT DOOR WE'RE OFFERING
MULTIPLE IN LANGUAGE OPTIONS IN
MAKING IT EASIER FOR CUSTOMERS
TO GET MORE FREQUENT UPDATES ON
OUR WEBSITE WE'RE ALSO MAKING
OUR SITE ITSELF MORE RELIABLE
FOR INCREASED VOLUME THAT WE
EXPERIENCED LAST YEAR AND WE'RE
EXPECTING IN THE FUTURE. AND
EVEN SOME OF THE TECHNOLOGY
THIS BILL MENTIONED LIKE THE
CAMERAS WE MAKE THAT AVAILABLE
TO THE PUBLIC TO TRY TO SHARE
IT BE AS- TRANSPARENT AS
POSSIBLE. THE SECOND AREA-
WHERE WE RESPONDED TO CUSTOMER
FEEDBACK IS AROUND BACK UP
POWER SOLUTIONS IN PROVIDING.
REALLY A VARIETY OF NEW REBATES
TO HELP. YOU KNOW ADDITIONAL
CUSTOMER GROUPS GOING INTO
TWENTY TWENTY IN THE SEASON.
ESPECIALLY OUR MOST VULNERABLE
POPULATION. WE HAVE NOW IS
FULLY SUBSIDIZED BACKUP BATTERY
POWER PROGRAM THAT'S FOR OUR
INCOME QUALIFIED CUSTOMERS.
THAT ARE CONSIDERED CRITICAL
CARE WHICH MEANS THEY'RE USING
LIFE SUSTAINING OR LIFE
SUPPORTING EQUIPMENT AT HOME.
WE'RE ALSO EXPANDING OTHER
SERVICES THAT WE PROVIDE TO
CUSTOMERS DURING PSP EVENTS
YES. YES EENTS LIKE. YOU KNOW
WHAT WE'RE DOING WITH OUR
COMMUNITY RESOURCE CENTERS IN
THE COMMUNITY VEHICLES THAT
WERE TALKED ABOUT EARLIER. THE
THIRD AREA ONE TALK ABOUT IS ON
THE CUSTOMER CARE PLANS THAT WE
HAVE DEVELOPED ALL THE WAY DOWN
TO THE CIRCUIT LEVEL. AND SO
HERE WE'RE LOOKING HOW WE CAN
APPLY SPECIFIC SOLUTIONS TO
MEET WHATEVER THE UNIQUE
COMMUNITY NEEDS ARE AND LIKE
SOME EXAMPLES YOU KNOW W COVER
FIFTY THOUSAND SQUARE MILES SO
IT'S A LOT OF DIVERSITY. IN THE
COMMUNITIES IN THE PEOPLE THAT
WE SERVE. IN SOME OF THOSE
AREAS CUSTOMERS ARE VERY
DEPENDENT ON WELL WATER FOR
EXAMPLE THAT'S IN OUR ACTED IN
AGUA DULCE COMMUNITIES. OTHER
WORLD COMMUNITIES HAVE OTHER
ESSENTIAL SERVICES THAT ARE
HIGHLY DEPENDENT ON SO WE'VE
BEEN DEVELOPING PROGRAMS LIKE A
NEW REPEAT PROGRAM FOR
CUSTOMERS TO HAVE A GENERATOR
THAT IS FOR WELL WATER. POWER
BACK. AND THEN THE LAST AREA TO
COVER IS HOW WE'RE CONTINUING
TO ENGAGE OUR COMMUNITIES. BUT
ESPECIALLY OUR MOST VULNERABLE
POPULATIONS SUCH AS THOSE WITH
ACCESS TO. NEEDS THROUGH
PARTNERSHIPS WITH INDEPENDENT
LIVING CENTERS COMMUNITY BASED
ORGANIZATIONS. AND OTHER LOCAL
COUNTY SERVICES- YOU KNOW AS A
RESULT OF WE'VE BEEN DOING A
LOT OF OUR REACH A LIVE STREAMS
IN VIRTUAL COMMUNITY MEETINGS.
AND WE FOUND THAT CLOSE 280% OF
THE CUSTOMERS THAT ENGAGED IN
THOSE MEETINGS WITH US IN THE
LAST FEW WEEKS. HAVE SAID THAT
THEY BETTER INFORMED ABOUT WHAT
I SEE IS DOING TO REDUCE THE
RISK WHILE CRIER. AND SO BASED
ON THIS THE WORK THAT WE'VE
DONE IN TWENTY NINETEEN THE
LESSONS THAT WE LEARNED AND-
CONTINUE TO LEARN AND
ENGAGEMENT WITH YOU AND- SEE IF
YOU SEEN OUR CUSTOMERS. IN
WE'RE CONFRONTING I BELIEVE
WE'RE CONFRONTING THIS FIRE
SEASON WITH NEW TOOLS AND
TECHNOLOGIES AND- AND REALLY
IMPORTANTLY YOU'RE JUST BETTER.
FOR HOW WE CAN MANAGE THE
DISTRACTIONS THAT OUR
CUSTOMERS. YOU KNOW OUR
CUSTOMERS EXPERIENCE WHEN WE
KNOW THAT HE CONCERN FOR
PUBLIC SAFETY REQUIRES US TO DE
ENERGIZED. SO I WANT TO THANK
YOU FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TO BE
HERE AND- YOU KNOW JUST TO
REITERATE AS BILLS THAT WE KNOW
HOW IMPORTANT THIS ISSUE AND-
IT IS. ASSN THE COMMUNITIES
THAT WE SERVE AND- AND WE
CONTINUE TO BE COMMITTED TO
LISTENING AND LEARNING AND
IMPROVING SO. I'LL ADD TURN IT
BACK OVER TO YOU TO SEE WHAT
KIND OF QUESTIONS WE MIGHT BE
ABLE. THANK YOU VERY MUCH KNOWS
VERY. AFFORDABLE INFORMATIVE
PRESENTATION. WE HAVE A
QUESTION BY SENATOR STERN.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR AND
THANK YOU TO THE. OUR TESTIMONY
OUR WITNESSES- MY FOLLOW UP
QUESTION WAS ABOUT. AND THE
BACKUP GENERATOR PROGRAM AND I
KNOW THAT THE TARGET NUMBER
THAT I SAW IN THE WILD FIRE
MITIGATION PLAN WAS TWENTY FIVE
HUNDRED CUSTOMERS I RECOGNIZE
THAT ONLY 2% OR SO OF AS SEIZE
TERRITORY WAS REALLY HIT BY
THIS P. S. P. S. BUT- WHOSE
ABOUT HALF MY DISTRICT SO IT
FEELS A LOT BIGGER THAN TWO
PERCENT- SPECIALLY WHEN YOUR
GRANDMOTHER IS CALLING YOU
ASKING- TO GET- RESCUED AND
PICKED UP WHEN SHE CAN'T GET
HER MEDICINE REFRIGERATED SO.
THIS IS PERSONAL BUT I
APPRECIATE THE PROGRESS YOU'VE
MADE I'M JUST WONDERING WITHIN
THAT. THAT TWENTY FIVE HUNDRED
CUSTOMER UNIVERSE THAT YOU'RE
REALLY TRYING TO GET. THOSE
CRITICAL BACKUP RESOURCES TO-
MAN SO THAT THEY DON'T HAVE TO
TRY TO RIG UP A DIESEL
GENERATOR IN THEIR HOUSE OR
SOME OTHER. D. I. Y. WAY OF
GETTING KEEPING THEIR POWER ON
HOW MANY PEOPLE. THAT WOULD
OTHERWISE BE ELIGIBLE FOR
MEDICAL BASS LINE OR CRITICAL
CARE BUT MAYBE HAVEN'T FOUND
OUT ABOUT THOSE PROGRAMS ARE
HAVE BEEN SIGNED UP. HOW MANY
OF THOSE FOLKS- WON'T BE
INCLUDED IN THIS TWENTY FIVE
HUNDRED. CUSTOMER TARGET
UNIVERSE IN OTHER WORDS ARE YOU
GOING BEYOND JUST THOSE WHO
HAVE SIGNED UP FOR THE PROGRAMS
OR IS THIS ONLY ELIGIBLE FOR
PEOPLE WHO HAVE TAKEN THOSE
EXTRA STEPS TO SIGNING UP FOR
THINGS LIKE MEDICAL BASELINE.
SORRY SO I CAN ADDRESS THAT SO.
WE ARE TARGETING THE POPULATION
THAT WE HAVE AWARENESS OF THAT
ARE IN NEED AND SO WE'VE GOT TO
I GOT THE NUMBERS HERE WE'VE
GOT NINETY THREE THOUSAND
CUSTOMERS ACROSS OUR SERVICE
AREA THAT OUR MEDICAL BASELINE-
AND OF THAT WE'VE GOT ABOUT
TWENTY FOUR THOUSAND OF THOSE
THAT ARE IN HIGH. RISK AREAS.
WHEN WE SUBSET OF THOSE
CUSTOMERS THE ONES THAT ARE
USING EQUIPMENT FOR LIFE
STATING OR SUPPORTING NEEDS. IN
OUR HAD HIGHER RISK AREA IT'S
JUST ABOUT JUST UNDER FIVE
THOUSAND AND THEN THE PROGRAM
THAT WE'VE DESIGNED AS YOU
POINT OUT TARGETS TWENTY FIVE
HUNDRED. THAT'S THAT
INTERSECTION OF CUSTOMERS THAT
HAVE IDENTIFIED AS MEDICAL BASS
LINE WITH THAT CRITICAL
COMPONENT AND ALSO CUSTOMERS
THAT ARE CONSIDERED INCOME
QUALIFY SO THERE OF INCOME
LEVELS THAT MAKE THEM YOU KNOW
IT BE ABLE TO ACCESS THE MOST
GENEROUS AND SUPPORTIVE CREATES
INCENTIVES. BUT YOUR QUESTION
ARE WE ARE WE ONLY ACHIEVING
YOUR REACHING THE CUSTOMERS
THAT WE KNOW OF AND YES WE ARE
AND THAT'S WHY ANOTHER
COMPONENT OF THE WORK WE'RE
DOING IN OUR REGION IS TO MAKE
SURE THAT WE HAVE. AT YOUR
CUSTOMERS ARE AWARE OF THESE
PROGRAMS AND WE'RE CONTINUING
TO ENROLL CUSTOMERS YOU JUST ON
THE EXAMPLE OF THOSE INCOME
QUALIFIED PROGRAMS OVER THE
LAST TWO MONTHS WE'VE MORE THAN
DOUBLED OUR NORMAL ENROLLMENT
RATE CUSTOMERS INTO IN
QUALIFYING. ROUNDS AND AS WE
REACH OUT TO CUSTOMERS ABOUT
OUTAGES OR THESE OTHER
INCENTIVES WE ARE ASKING
PROACTIVELY DO YOU KNOW ABOUT
MEDICAL BASS LINE DO YOU MEET
THIS CRITERIA SO THAT WE CAN
ENROLL CUSTOMERS. AND THE LAST
POINT IS THAT WE'VE ALSO ONLY
HERE IT NEEDS TO BE REQUIRED
DOT KNOWS TO JUSTIFY THE
ENROLLMENT IT IN ALL OF THE
CHALLENGES RIGHT NOW WE STAY AT
HOME IN PEOPLE. UNDERSTANDABLY
NOT WANTING TO GO BURKE ROUTINE
DOCTOR'S APPOINTMENTS WE WAIVE
THAT CRITERIA TEMPORARILY WHICH
IS ALLOWED US TO CONTINUE. TO
INCREASE. AT THANKS THAT. WE
OWE YOU ASSIST IN THAT AT REACH.
TO WE WANT MAKE SURE FIND OUT
HE'S YOUR TOUGH REACH PEOPLE OF
FOLKS WHO MAYBE AREN'T ON THE
INTERNET THERE. BEEN ANY CAN BE
DRIVING BY A BILLBOARD SO I
WOULD HOPE THAT. YOU YOU CAN
INTERFACE WITH COUNTY AS MUCH
AS POSSIBLE ESPECIALLY WHEN WE
LOOK AT OUR AYE HSS CUSTOMER
BASE. WITHIN LA COUNTY ALONE I
THINK WORD OVER HALF A MILLION
PEOPLE ON AYE HSS SO NINETY
THREE THOUSAND VERSES. SIX
HUNDRED THOUSAND. I THINK WE'VE
GOT SOME WORK TO DO BUT- STAND
READY TO HELP IN THAT EFFORT.
THE LAST QUESTION WAS JUST DO
YOU HAVE A- I'M SORRY IF I
MISSED THIS IN THE PRESENTATION
BUT IS THERE. A SORT OF TARGET.
IN IN TERMS OF. A DECREASE
UTILIZATION OF TS TS. THIS
WILDFIRE SEASON THAT THAT
EDISON IS SHOOTING FOR- I
BELIEVE WE HEARD THE 35%
NUMBER. THAT OUT OF P. GENIE IS
THERE A SIMILAR SIR TO DOWN
SCOPING THAT YOU ALL ARE AIMING
FOR. YEAH HELLO SENATOR AND
THIS IS FULLER DOING AND-
THANKS FOR THE QUESTION- THIS
IS AN AREA THAT WE ARE FOCUSED
ON MONITORING HOW WE'RE DOING
THE NUMBERS THAT I CITED- OR
EXPECTATION BASED ON SIMILAR
WEATHER CONDITIONS IS LAST YEAR
AGAIN ROUGHLY. A 30% DECREASE
IN THE FINE PRINT- OF THE SPS
ADVANTAGE FOR IMPACT OR
CUSTOMERS- WE DON'T HAVE A
TARGET FOR THAT BECAUSE AGAIN
IT'S SO WEATHER DEPENDENT- AND
DEPENDS ON VERY LOCAL
CONDITIONS- OF THE PROGRAMS WE
PUT IN PLACE REALLY ARE ARE
GETTING TWO LINES AND THOSE THE
CNET GELS IT TALKED ABOUT WHICH
IS THE ROLE OF. YES YES AND OUR
MILLION PACKS OUR CUSTOMERS AND
THE THINGS THAT I WAS SPEAKING
OF EARLIER- HAVING TO DO WITH
MORE SECTIONAL ICING- PART IN
THE GRADE AND REALLY WELL WHEN
I DO WANT TO POINT OUT IS- WE
TO PUT TOGETHER A CROSS COMPANY
TEAM- TO ADDRESS THE PSP
RESIDENCE- THAT WE'RE EXPECTING
TO SEE THIS YEAR- DATA THAT WE
ACTUALLY STOOD UP. INCIDENT
MANAGEMENT TEAM- WITH A COUPLE
OF INCIDENT. TO MARSHAL THE
RESOURCES OF SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA EDISON TO MAKE SURE
THAT WE'RE FOCUSED ON FINDING
SOLUTIONS AS QUICKLY AS WE CAN
AND PUTTING IN THE FIELD SO WE
CAN MINIMIZE THE IMPACT. SO
MANY I HAVE A NUMBER FOR YOU
BUT WE PUT IT MANY MANY IN
PLACE AND CONFIDENT THAT WE ARE
TRIGGERED. ARE CUSTOMERS
ABILITY I WAS VERY CLOSE. TAX
RETURNS WILL BE LOOKING TO GO.
THE WE DON'T HAVE A CHART OVER.
HELLO MISTER HURRY TO GET NEAR
ME. I DO OKAY I WANTED TO
REVIEW FOR. I WON IN THIS LINE
OF. FOR SECOND. TIME I'M GOING
ASK THE COMMITMENT TO. PLEASE
INDULGED AS A CHIU. IN IN IN
AND SING CAJUN SO THE TOP
NATION CRY. AT TWELVE FORTY WE
WILL HAVE AMERICANS THE WHY.
JOE IN ANIMAL OF SILENCE- THIS
MOMENT IS. EXPECTED TO LAST
EIGHT MINUTES AND FORTY SIX
SECONDS TO HONOR THE MEMORIES
OF GEORGE FLOOR FLOYD. AHMAD
ARMORY BRIANNA TAYLOR AND A SO
MANY OTHER AFRICAN AMERICANS
TRAGICALLY KILLED AND WRITE
RACIALLY CHARGED INCIDENTS. OUR
OUR COUNTRY IS A CONFRONTING A
PAINFUL NEW RECKONING OF A
SYSTEMIC RACISM. BUT TODAY AND
JOINING THIS WE HAVE THE
OPPORTUNITY TO SUPPORT THE US
LOOKING WITHIN AND SEEING HOW
WE CAN- CHANGE IN OUR SYSTEM TO
ENSURE THAT NO LIFE IS LOST IN
THE FUTURE. AND IN THESE
INCIDENTS PLEASE- PLEASE JOIN
ME AND TAKING A MOMENT. TO
REFLECT ON HOW PRECIOUS LIFE IS
AND WE WILL- INTER A TAKE
MINUTES FORTY SIX SECONDS
MOMENT OF SILENCE.
THANK YOU
MEMBERS OF WILL RESUME OUR
MEETING WILL COME BACK. TO
SENATOR STERN SENSOR STERN AND
YOU WANTED TO YOUR LINE OF
QUESTIONING. MR HARRINGTON'S-
ANSWER WAS SUFFICIENT I'M HAPPY
TO MOVE ON THANK YOU VERY MUCH
AND- WILL NOW COME TO CENTER
MORAL. THANK YOU RICHARD JUST
UP FOR MISTER HERRINGTON ON
PAGE SIX. AND MY FIRST QUESTION
IS JUST TO EXPLAIN THE ACRONYMS
YES SIR P. SMAP R. E. M. P. AND
G. R. C. YOU MAY WANT TO YOU
YOURSELF MISTER HERRINGTON.
SORRY ABOUT THAT. YES SIR IS
THAT ARE MORE LIKE ON THE-
AGREE SAFETY RESOUND
RELIABILITY PROGRAM JUST YEARS
IN OUR P. HERE SEE IS THE
GENERAL RATE CASE- S. MAP IS
SAFETY. YEAH SAFETY NAPPING IN
A LINE AND SHOULD BE NAPPING.
AND RELIABLE PROCEEDING I
ACTUALLY HAVE TO SAY THE
AUDITOR'S THE BACK INTO THE
DECK THERE IS A I'LL CALL IT A-
A KEY TO ALL THE ACRONYMS. FREE
WEB PAGES THAT BECAUSE I DIDN'T
FIND IT IF IT. WENT TO COLLEGES
FOR THAT. JUST FORGIVE ME FOR
NOT A THEM MEMORY NO. IT SAYS
WE SHOULD- MAKE SURE THOSE ARE
NOT- NOT TOO HARD TO
UNDERSTAND. I AM CURIOUS MISTER
HERRINGTON- WHAT HAS OCCURRED
WITH SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA EDISON
IN THE AREA OF A CHOIR
INSURANCE WITH THE RECENT.
WILDFIRE EPISODES OF LATE.
THANK YOU SENATOR- I REALLY
DON'T HAVE ANY MATERIAL RIGHT
NOW I KNOW THAT THE MARKET HAS
BEEN- A TOUGH FOR THE LAST
COUPLE OF YEARS I THINK THAT'S
SOMETHING THAT WE CAN GET YOU
APPLIED TO- THROUGH OUR
SACRAMENTO OFFICE MORE
SPECIFIC- ANSWER TO THAT
QUESTION BECAUSE THE C. P. U.
C. BEEN SENSITIVE TO THESE
RISING COSTS. ARE WE HAVE
INCLUDED DOES- IN OUR I REQUEST
FOR FUNDING AND- GENERATE CASE-
WE- MADE IS THE FACTOR FILING
WHICH IS OF FILING FOR.
ADDITIONAL ADDITIONAL REVENUES
TO ACCOMPLISH- OR TO-
COMPENSATE FOR UNEXPECTED COSTS
THAT WHEN THIS SITUATION FIRST
ROSE. AND THEY HAVE BEEN.
PROPERLY SUPPORTIVE OF RECOVERY.
THERE WAS AN EARTHQUAKE
YESTERDAY I THINK- CENTERED IN
THE KERN COUNTY AREA WAS- DID
WAS THERE ANY IMPACT ON YOUR-
AREA. THANKFULLY THERE WAS NO
IMPACT. IT HAS A FIVE POINT
FIVE MAGNITUDE EARTHQUAKE THANK
YOU FOR ASKING. IF THERE WERE A
SEVERE EARTHQUAKE AND POWER
WERE. ELIMINATED DOUG. IS THAT
INCLUDED IN YOUR- EXTREME
EMERGENCY PLAN. YES SENATOR IS-
IN FACT- THAT WAS THE SCENARIO
THAT WE LAST- HAD A COMPANY
WIDE OR NOT COMMITTEE WHITE-
BUT- BUT ANNUAL DROLL WITH OUR-
PUBLIC SAFETY PARTNERS AND
STATE REGULATORS IN STATE AND
FEDERAL- FEDERAL PARTNERS SO
THAT WAS WE CALL FULL SCALE
EXERCISE. ON AND SO WE DO PLAN
FOR THAT AND- WE'VE KNOCKED ON
OUR GOAL FOR THIS YEAR CO
WOULD- AS A POSTPONED THAT
WE'RE STILL LOOKING AT. OUR
PLAN FOR DOING THAT BUT- FIRST
QUAKES ARE PART OF OUR ALL
RISK- EXERCISE PLAN. IN THAT
SCENARIO. HOW HOW LONG WERE.
THE ELECTRIC LIGHT. THIS BUT AB
ONE WEEK TWO WEEKS I WANT TO
TELL YOU SENATOR- HAVE TO GET
BACK TO THE DRILL I DON'T
REMEMBER EXACTLY HOW LONG WE
KIND OF COMPRESSED TIME FRAMES-
BUT CERTAIN AREAS ARE MANY
DAYS- WITHOUT ELECTRICITY-
DEPENDING ON THE DAMAGE AND THE
CONCENTRATION OF THE DAMAGE-
OTHER RESTORING YOUR QUICK. AND
KEEP AND IF A MEMBER OF THE
PUBLIC WANTED TO GET ACCESS TO
YOUR EXTREME- EMERGENCY PLAN IS
AVAILABLE YES OUR OUR MERCY
PLANS ARE ARE SUBMITTED TO-
LEAST COMMISSION ANNUALLY.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MISTER
HERRINGTON THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR. THANK YOU WERE CENTER
RUBIO. THANK YOU I AM YEAH I
WANT TO ASK A QUESTION AND- DO
YOU HAVE DRIVE THROUGH FEAR
SEIZE. NOW I CAN ANSWER THAT
YES WE DO AND ACT WE USE THEM
FOR THE FIRST TIME I THINK THIS
LAST WEEKEND IT WAS MENTIONED
EARLIER BY YOU SEE HOW WE HAD
AN EVENT WE DIDN'T DO ANY DE
INTERNALIZATION BUT- WE DID GO
THROUGH. YES YES- EVENT WITH
NOTIFICATIONS TO CUSTOMERS AND
WE HAD BOTH A COMBINATION OF A
COMMUNITY RESOURCE CENTER WHERE
CUSTOMERS WERE ABLE TO COME ON.
AND BE YOU KNOW FOLLOWING
APPROPRIATE SOCIAL DISTANCING
PART OF HEALTH AND WE HAD IT
WHERE CUSTOMERS COULD STAY IN
THEIR CAR. AND WE COULD
PROVIDE- RESOURCES TO THEM
WITHOUT THEM GETTING OUT OF HER
CAR. THANK YOU FOR A LIBRARY
THE SHADE. THANK YOU ANYONE
ELSE OKAY THANK YOU VERY MUCH
I'D LIKE TO THANK THE
PARTICIPANTS FROM FROM S. C. E.
FOR JOINING US TODAY AND
THEY'RE VERY COMPREHENSIVE-
PRESENTATION THANK YOU VERY
MUCH NOWWE WILL HEAR FROM
PACIFIC GAS AND ELECTRIC WE
HAVE DEBBIE POWER SHE'S A VICE
PRESIDENT. OF ASSET RISK
MANAGEMENT COMMUNITY WELL FIRE
SAFETY WE ALSO HAVE MATTHEW
BENDER HE'S THE DIRECTOR OF
REGULATORY STRATEGY COMMUNITY
WHILE FIRE SAFETY PROGRAM AND
WELFARE PLANS- DO WE HAVE THEM
AVAILABLE WITH US TODAY YES I
SEE THEM THERE. LET'S GET A
LITTLE SOUND CHECK THERE AND-
HAVE. RIGHT HERE A NEW DATA YOU
MIGHT ONE I'M ON MUTE YOUR
COMPUTER LET'S TRY THAT AGAIN.
HELLO CAN YOU HEAR ME YES NOW
WE CAN HEAR YOU THANK YOU VERY
MUCH. WELCOME THANK YOU GOOD
AFTERNOON CHARLIE SO AND
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE MY
NAME IS DEBBIE HOW I AM VICE
PRESIDENT CHENEY'S ASSET AND
RISK MANAGEMENT AND COMMUNITY
WHILE CRIER SIXTY PROGRAM I AM
JOINED TODAY BY MAC TENDER THE
DIRECTOR OF ELECTRIC OPERATIONS
REGULATORY STRATEGY AND
COMMUNITY WHILE OUR STATE. OUR
PROJECT MANAGER OFFICE I WISH
YOU YOUR- TO PROVIDE YOU WITH.
A DEDICATED. SETTING TO PRESENT
MY- I'M ASSUMING RESPONSIBILITY
IS THE SAFETY OF OUR SIXTEEN
MILLION CUSTOMERS AND THE
COMMUNITIES THAT MISTER. BEFORE
I BEGAN I WOULD LIKE TO
ACKNOWLEDGE THE TRAGIC LOSS OF
LIGHTS THAT OCCURRED WITHIN OUR
WORKFORCE IN A HELICOPTER
INCIDENT EARLIER THIS WEEK. WE
ARE COOPERATING WITH ALL
INVESTIGATING AUTHORITIES AND
WHILE WE DO NOT HAVE ALL THE
DETAILS ON WHAT HAPPENED OR
WHY. WE ARE COMMITTED TO
LEARNING FROM THIS DEFENSE AND
OUR FOCUS ON KEEPING OUR
CUSTOMERS COMMUNITIES AND
WORKFORCE SAY. TODAY WE WILL
PROVIDE AN UPDATE ON THE
IMMEDIATE AND COMPREHENSIVE
ACTIONS WE ARE TAKING TO
UPGRADE OUR INFRASTRUCTURE
MONITOR FIRE THREATS IN REAL
TIME. AN INSTITUTE NEAR WILD
FIRE SAFETY MEASURES. AROUND
FIRE MITIGATION PLAN OUTLINES
THREE MAIN OBJECTIVES. REDUCING
WILD FIRE IGNITION POTENTIAL
REDUCING WILDFIRE SPREAD
THROUGH IMPROVED SITUATIONAL
AWARENESS AND REDUCING THE
IMPACTS OF PUBLIC SAFETY
POWERSHOT. I'LL DISCUSS THE
PROGRESS WE'VE MADE SO FAR IN
TWENTY TWENTY AND ALSO KEY TO
NEWS RESPONSE TO KOBE. AND THAT
RELATIONSHIP TO OUR WILD FIRE
AFTER. IF YOU HAVE THE
MATERIALS AND FROM ALONG MUCH
LINE. I'D LIKE TO FOCUS ON THAT
WE ARE TAKE AS PART OF OUR-
WHILE FOR SAFETY. TO HELP BURKE.
UNITIES SAFE. OURMAYBE PLANNED
WAS TO THE CPC EARLIER THIS
YEAR. I'LL START THE STEPS THAT
WE'RE TAKING TO REDUCE THE RISK
OF CATASTROPHIC WILDFIRES FROM
ELECTRICAL EQUIPMENT. BY
MITIGATING THE NUMBER CAUSES OF
THE IGNITION. OUR ENHANCED BUT
MANAGE IS MEETING AND EXCEEDING
STATE MEDITATION AND FIRE
SAFETY STANDARDS REDUCING THE
NUMBER OF TREES AND LIMBS THAT
COULD FALL. WORKING AND
SHORELINES WERE IMPROVING OUR
ASSET MANAGEMENT BY CONTINUING
TO NAVAL DEVICES CLOSERS THAT
ALLOW OPERATORS TO REMOTELY
PREVENT ONLINE FOR ME. AFTER A
FAULT. REMINDED AREN'T SEXY
PROGRAM USING LESSONS LEARNED
FROM OUR TOTAL SYSTEM EXPECTED
INSPECTION THAT TOOK PLACE IN
TWENTY NINETEEN. IT FURTHER
UPGRADING AND STRENGTHENING OUR
ELECTRIC SYSTEM IN THE HIGHEST
FIRE RISK BY INSTALLING MORE
pTHE STRONGER AND MORE RESILIENT
HOLES AND COVERED POWER LINES
ALONG WITH TARGETED UNDERGROUND.
WE WILL CONTINUE TO USE PS YES
DURING THE YEAR FIRE RISKY
GESTIONES REDUCE. EMISSIONS
MOVING ON TO SITUATIONAL. NEXT
WE'RE CONTINUING TO INSTALL
REAL TIME MONITORING AND
SITUATIONAL AWARENESS TOOLS SO
WE CAN BETTER UNDERSTAND HOW
SEVERE WEATHER IN OUR SYSTEM
I'M PRO ACTIVELY RESPOND TO
POTENTIAL THREATS. THE FURTHER
OUR WEATHER FORECASTING
CAPABILITIES THE GENIE IS
BUILDING OUR OWN NETWORK OF
WEATHER STATIONS TO MONITOR AND
FORECAST WEATHER CONDITIONS.
ALONG WITH IMPROVED WEATHER
FORECASTING MODELS THESE
IMPROVE OUR ABILITY PROJECT FOR
EXTREME WILD FIRE WEATHER COULD
OCCUR SO WE CAN RESPOND QUICKLY
AND APPROPRIATELY TO KEEP OUR
CUSTOMERS SAY. WE'RE ADDING
APPROXIMATELY FOUR HUNDRED NEW
WEATHER STATIONS THIS YEAR IN
ADDITION TO THE SIX HUNDRED AND
SAW THROUGH THE END OF TWENTY
NINETEEN. WE WILL HAVE A TOTAL
OF THIRTEEN HUNDRED NEW WEATHER
STATIONS TWENTY TWENTY. THAT'S
ABOUT ONE STATION EVERY TWENTY
SECOND MILES IN OUR HIGH HIGHER
RISK AREAS. WHEN INSTALLING TWO
HUNDRED NEW HIGH DEFINITION
CAMERAS IN HIGH PRIORITY AREAS
FOR A TOTAL OF THREE HUNDRED
THIRTY FIVE. TWENTY WITH THE
TARGET OF SIX HUNDRED BY TWENTY
TWENTY TWO. ULTIMATELY LED US
VISUALLY MONITOR OVER 90% OF
THE HIGHER HI FIRED RISK AREAS
OF OUR SERVICE TERRITORY. OUR
WHILE TIRE SAFETY OPERATIONS
CENTER ESTABLISHED IN TWENTY
EIGHTEEN MONITORS POTENTIAL
WILDFIRE ACROSS OUR SERVICE
AREA IN REAL TIME IN
COORDINATION PREVENTION AND
RESPONSE EFFORTS. THE CENTER
LEVERAGES A SATELLITE FIRE
DETECTION SYSTEM THAT TAKES
FIRE STATUS DATA FROM SIX
DIFFERENT SETTLEMENT. MOVING ON
TO SLIDE FIVE WHICH IS ABOUT
REDUCING THE IMPACTS OF YES YES
THE BANDS. I'D LIKE TO TALK
BRIEFLY ABOUT OUR PUBLIC SAFETY
POWER SHUTTLE PROGRAM. WE
LEARNED A LOT FROM THE P. S. TS
SEASONS IN TWENTY NINETEEN WE
ARE CHANGING THE PS YES PROGRAM
THIS YEAR MAKING MEN'S SMALLER
SHORTER AND SMARTER TO KEEP
CUSTOMERS AND COMMUNITY SAFE
DURING TIMES OF SEVERE WEATHER
AND HIGH WILD VIRUS. THIS TOOK
FULL. THE RISK CAST WHILE
DURING YOUR FIRE WHETHER WE NOW
TURNING OFF POWER TO PROTECT
AGAINST DEVASTATING WILDFIRES
WITHOUT ACTION ALSO JUST WRITE
LINES PRESENTS ON PUBLIC SAFETY
RISK. OUR FIRST GOAL IS THAT
ANY NEW PS YES EVEN WILL AFFECT
ONE THIRD FEWER CUSTOMERS THAN
A COMPARABLE WOULD HAVE LAST
YEAR. WE WILL REDUCE CUSTOMER
IMPACTS THROUGH IMPROVED
METEOROLOGICAL DATA FOR CASTING
SAFELY MINIMIZING TRANSMISSION
IMPACTS AND BY PLACING
DISTRIBUTED GENERATION
SUBSTATIONS AND OTHER LOCATIONS
THE SUPPORT ISOLATED POCKETS OF
CUSTOMERS WHO ARE STATE TO
OPERATE INSIDE. WIDER DE
ENERGIZED. WE ARE INSTALLING
OVER SIX HUNDRED ACTUALIZING
DEVICES TO ALLOW US TO MANAGE
TO CREATE AND SMALLER MORE
FLEXIBLE SECTIONS. AS NOTED BY
MS PETERSON WE ADJUSTED OUR
APPROACH TO THESE DEVICES
EARLIER THIS YEAR WHICH DELAYED
INSULATE HOWEVER WHAT MAKING.
REST ON THAT. TODAY AND
MONITORING IT ON A WEEKLY BASIS.
THIS WILL LET US MANAGE YES YES
HE BOUNCE MORE SURGICALLY TO
FAX YOUR CUSTOMERS WE ARE ALSO
PLANNING TO USE NEW SEXUAL
LASSEN SPECIALIZATION DEVICES I
AM IN THE HUMBOLDT BAY
GENERATING STATIONS SO THAT WE
CAN KEEP ABOUT SIXTY THOUSAND
YOU'RE MY CUSTOMERS JOSH IT'S
NEARBY YES YES. YOU CAN JUST
WRITE INCOMING TRANSMISSION
LINES. SEC WE'RE SEEKING TO CUT
RESTORATION TIMES IN HALF.
RESTORED POWER WITHIN TWELVE
DAYLIGHT HOURS AFTER THE SEVERE
WEATHER HAS PASSED WE ARE
NEARLY DOUBLING ARE CONTRACTED
HELICOPTER SLEEP DURING THE
ADVANCED FROM THIRTY FIVE LAST
YEAR SIXTY FIVE THIS YEAR SO
THAT WE CAN MORE QUICKLY
INSPECT FOR DAMAGING HASTERT'S
AFTER SEVERE WEATHER AND
RESTORE POWER TO KEEP YOU. AS
SOON AS THEY FLEE. WE WILL USE
TO FIXED WING AIRCRAFT WITH
INFRARED CAMERAS. TRANSMISSION
LINES AT NIGHT SO WE CAN SPOT
ANY WEATHER CAUSED DAMAGES OR
RE ENERGIZED AND DAMAGED THE
FINE SINNERS. FINALLY WE'RE
WORKING TO PROVIDE CLEARER AND
MORE ACCURATE COMMUNICATIONS
AND ADDITIONAL RESOURCES THE
CUSTOMERS AND COMMUNITIES
BEFORE DURING AND AFTER YES YES
YOU MAN. AS A MATTER WILD FIRE
MITIGATION PROBLEMS WE HAVE
PROVIDED DETAILS REGARDING THE
WORK WE CONDUCTED IN TWENTY
NINETEEN AND ARE TARGETS FOR
TWENTY TWENTY AND THE WORK THAT
WE HAVE COMPLETED THUS FAR. WE
REALLY APPRECIATE THE
PARTNERSHIP WITH THE I. D. E.
W. AND THE DEDICATION OF THEIR
MEMBERS THE MEN AND WOMEN OF
OUR COMPANY IN HELPING TO GET
THIS WORK PERFORMED DURING THE
TROUBLE AND TIME. AS YOU CAN
SEE WE ARE CONTINUING TO MAKE
PROGRESS ON A WILDFIRE
PREVENTION EFFORTS AND WE HAVE
PLANS TO MEET THE TARGETS WE
INCLUDED IN THE WILD FIRE
MITIGATION PLAN. THE LARGEST
IMPACT OF THESE EFFORTS THE
CURRENT PANDEMIC IS OUR
APPROACH TO THE COMMUNITY
RESOURCE CENTERS. WE ORIGINALLY
PLANNED FOR HER OVER TWO
HUNDRED HARDENS C. R. C. SIGN.
FOR THE TWENTY TWENTY PS
SEASON. BUT CLOSELY RELATED
SHUTDOWNS MADE MANY OF THOSE
THANKS AND ACCESSIBLE. TO US WE
ARE STILL WORKING TO PREPARE
MANY HARDENED SITE AND WE WILL
SUPPLEMENT THOSE WITH OTHER
KIND OF C. R. C.'S INCLUDING A
TEMPORARY SIDE. OPEN AIR TANKS
AND MOBILE VEHICLE BASED
FACILITIES TO TAKE COMMUNITY
SUPPORT TO WHERE OUR CUSTOMERS
ARE IN A- SAFE WAY. MOVING ON
THE SLIDES. WE ARE LISTENING
AND QUIRK RATING FEEDBACK FROM
LOCAL STATE AND TRIBAL
OFFICIALS AND WILD FIRE SAFETY
EXPERTS AS WE PRIORITIZE AND
IMPLEMENT WILDFIRE SIXTY WORK.
AFTER LAST YEAR'S PST PST VANS
WE MET IN PERSON WITH MORE THAN
THIRTY SIX COUNTY AND TRIBAL
OFFICES OF EMERGENCY SERVICES.
YES YES LISTENING SESSIONS. WE
ARE NOW CONDUCTING ADDITIONAL
VIRTUAL MEETINGS AND
COORDINATION EFFORTS RELATED TO
WILD FIRE SAFETY YES. WE ARE
WORKING WITH THE PS PS ADVISORY
COMMITTEE MADE UP OF
REPRESENTATIVES FROM COUNTY
TRIBES THE LEAGUE OF CALIFORNIA
CITIES AND THE CALIFORNIA STATE
ASSOCIATION OF COUNTIES TO GET
FEEDBACK ON OUR PLANS. WE ARE
HOLDING WORKING SESSIONS WITH
COUNTY IN TROUBLE OFFICES OF
EMERGENCY SERVICES TO FURTHER
PARTNER LOCAL. PARIS WELFARE
SEE. YES YES YOU CAN. AS OF YET
HELLO TWENTY OF THESE COUNTING
LEVEL SESSIONS WITH MORE
SCHEDULED. WE NOW. THE P. S.
PSP BUT EXERCISES OVER THE
SUMMER WE WILL INVITE COUNTY
OFFICIALS. MOVING ON TO
CUSTOMER ENGAGEMENT. WE HAVE
BEEN COMMUNICATING TO OUR
CUSTOMER SINCE MARCH ABOUT WILD
FIRE SAFETY AND PREPARING FOR
PSCS IMMENSE THIS OUT WHICH HAS
INCLUDED DIRECT ENGAGEMENT WITH
CUSTOMER GROUPS INCLUDING THE
PEOPLE WITH DISABILITIES AND
AGING ADVISORY COUNCIL CRITICAL
CUSTOMERS AND OTHER KEESE KEY
STAKEHOLDERS. WE HAVE BEEN
HOLDING WEEKLY WEBINARS WITH
CUSTOMERS STILL KISSING ON
LOCAL PROJECT PROGRESS IN
INITIATIVES WE PLAN TO CONDUCT
IN PERSON EVENTS BUT HAD TO.
OUR APPROACH YOU TO COME IN
CONCERNS. WE ARE USING A
VARIETY OF CHANNELS TO REACH
CUSTOMERS INCLUDING EMAILS
LOCAL MEDIA UT REACH SOCIAL
MEDIA AND DIRECT CONVERSATIONS
WITH KEY STAKEHOLDERS. THESE
ARE EVENTS HAS BEEN STRONG WITH
AN AVERAGE OF NEARLY FOUR
HUNDRED PARTICIPANTS HER WOMEN
ARE. LINE NINE IN OUR CODE
RESPONSE I WANT TO TAKE A
MOMENT TO ADDRESS PLANNING WITH
REGARDS TO PST PST VANS AND A
CO CANNOT HIM DOWN. SINCE EVEN
BEFORE THE OFFICIAL OF THIS
PANDEMIC WE'VE BEEN FOCUSED ON
ACTIONS TO ENSURE THAT THE
ENERGY GRID REMAINS SAFE. AND
RELIABLE. WE ARE DETERMINED TO
DO EVERYTHING POSSIBLE TO
ADDRESS THE IMPACT OF THE
COLBERT NINETEEN PANDEMIC AND
THE THREAT OF CATASTROPHIC
WILDFIRES. OVERRIDING GOAL IS
TO ENSURE PUBLIC SAFETY. FOR
OUR WORK WILD FIRE RISK
REDUCTION WORK HAS REMAINED
PRIORITIZE AND LARGELY ON
TRACK. THROUGHOUT THE STACK
DEMINT. WE UNDERSTAND THE
IMPORTANCE OF KEEPING THE
LIGHTS ON ESPECIALLY GIVEN THE
STAY AT HOME WORKERS AND SO
MANY PEOPLE ARE ALSO WORKING
FROM HOME. THEREFORE WE
MODIFIED OUR WORK PLANS AND
SCHEDULING TO MINIMIZE CUSTOMER
OUTAGES IN RECOGNITION OF
CUSTOMERS SHELTERING AT HOME.
MOST ASPECTS OF OUR CUSTOMER
ENGAGEMENT IN AT. INCLUDING
CONVERTING ALL IN PERSON
SESSIONS ONLINE VIRTUAL MEETING.
WE ARE WORKING CLOSELY WITH THE
CALIFORNIA HOSPITAL ASSOCIATION
AND HOSPITAL CANCER NORTHERN
AND CENTRAL CALIFORNIA TO
IDENTIFY HOSPITALS CURRENTLY
SUPPORTING NINETEEN RESPONSE I
HEARD THE HAVE A LITTLE HIGHER
LIKELIHOOD OF EXPERIENCING YES
YES. WE ARE DEVELOPING GREAT
BASS AND OTHER SOLUTIONS TO
ENSURE THAT THOSE HOSPITALS
REMAIN UNDER JOHN'S IN THE
EVENT OF A BROADER YES YES HOW
MUCH. WE ARE TALKING WITH
CUSTOMERS AND COMMUNITY
ADVISORY GROUPS LIKE ARE PEOPLE
WITH DISABILITIES AND AGING
ADVISORY COUNCIL TO UNDERSTAND
OUR CUSTOMERS AND COMMUNITIES
ARE NAVIGATING THIS PANDEMIC.
THIS HELPS US ADJUSTER PROGRAMS
TO SERVE THEM BETTER. WE
IDENTIFY ACCESS SOCIETALLY
IMPORTANT FACILITIES AND
WORKING TO KEEP THEM IN SERVICE
DESPITE YES YES WHEN USING
TEMPORARY GENERATION AND
CAREFUL GREAT SEXUAL
MOLESTATION. WE ARE UPDATING
OUR COMMUNITY RESOURCE CENTER
STRATEGY TO OFFER SMALLER OPEN
THEIR SITE AND MOBILE SITES
WITH DANCE IF STAY AT HOME AND
PHYSICAL DISTANCING
DURING YES YES EVEN. AND WE'RE
WORKING HARD TO KEEP OUR WORK
FOR STATION HAPPY FOR THE LONG
HAUL SO THEY CAN FOR HER
CUSTOMERS TODAY AND STILL BE
STRONG AND AVAILABLE TO EXECUTE
ALL OF THE CHALLENGING TASK.
THAT MAY LIE AHEAD DURING FIRE
SEASON. THE BOTTOM LINE IS THAT
OUR EFFORTS AND FOCUS REMAIN ON
OPERATING OUR SYSTEM SAFELY
REDUCE WILD VIRUS WHILE
MINIMIZING TAXES YES YES ON OUR
CUSTOMERS. WE ARE READY FOR
WILDFIRE SEASON AND READY TO
EXECUTE YES YES EVEN. IF NEEDED.
WE LOOK FORWARD TO CONTINUED
PARTNERSHIP WITH THE
COMMUNITIES WE SERVE AS WE ALL
AND JUST AND RESPOND TO THESE
UNIQUE CONDITIONS. CONCLUSION
WE ARE COMMITTED TO WORKING
TOGETHER P. JEANNIE GOVERNMENT
AND ALL CALIFORNIANS TO A
DOCTOR ELECTRIC SYSTEM TO THE
GROWING THREAT OF WILDFIRES
WHILE ALSO HELPING OUR
CUSTOMERS PREPARE FOR PUBLIC
SAFETY OUTAGES. WE KNOW HOW
MUCH OUR CUSTOMERS RELY ON
ELECTRIC SERVICE AND WE ARE
COMMITTED TO HELPING THEM BE
INFORMED. AIRED AND TO STAY
SAFE DURING OUTAGES RELATED TO
SEVERE FIRE WEATHER EVENTS. WE
WILL- WE WELCOME FEEDBACK FROM
THIS BODY AND I'M HAPPY TO
RESPOND TO QUESTIONS YOU MAY
HAVE ABOUT P. GENIES WILD FIRE
MITIGATION WORK. YES YES
READINESS. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
AND BEFORE WE GO INTO QUESTIONS
ARE ONE WOULD MAKE ONE MORE
ANNOUNCEMENT FOR THOSE
PARTICIPATING VIA TELEPHONE OR
COMPUTER FOR ALL INDIVIDUALS
WISHING TO PROVIDE PUBLIC
COMMENT THE PARTICIPANT. TOLL
FREE NUMBER AND ACCESS CODE IS
POSTED ON OUR COMMITTEE
WEBSITE. IT WILL BE DISPLAYED
ON THE SCREEN AND I WILL
ANNOUNCE IT- ONCE AGAIN NOW-
THE TODAY'S PARTICIPANT NUMBER
IS ONE. EIGHT FOUR FOUR TWO
NINE ONE SIX THREE SIX FOUR.
AND THE ACCESS CODE IS. SEVEN
EIGHT THREE SIX SEVEN FOUR
FIVE. WE'LL GO TO QUESTIONS NOW
AND I WANT TO ASK ONE QUESTION
DEALING. WITH THE BANKRUPTCY
AFFECTING PNG PIGEON A
CURRENTLY. THAT I WANTED TO
ASK- WILL WITH THE BACK OF
GROUP C. B. AN IMPEDIMENT TO
PIGEON USABILITY PREPARE FOR
THIS YEAR'S WILDLIFE WILDFIRE
SEASON. WOULD YOU HAPPEN TO
KNOW THAT. WE HAVE WHILE I AM
AN EXPERT IN THE WILD FIRE
MITIGATION PLAN AND OUR
PREPARATIONS FOR WILDFIRE
SEASON I HAVE NOT BEEN-
IMMERSED IN THE BANKRUPTCY
ISSUES FACING THE OMPANY AND
I'D BE HAPPY TO HAVE OUR
SACRAMENTO OFFICE. AND FURTHER
UPDATE AT THE CONCLUSION OF
THIS MEETING BUT DUE TO
CURRENTLY AS A AND THE ROLE DO
YOU FEEL YOU HAVE THE RESOURCES
NECESSARY TO PUT. EUGENIE FOR
ACTUAL. OF WEALTH SEASON. I
HAVE TO PROVIDED TO RESOURCES
THAT I NEED TO EXECUTE ON THIS
YEAR'S PLAN SO I WOULD SAY YES.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH WE'RE GOING
TO MOVE ON TO SENATOR HILL
SENATOR HILL GIVE US A- THANK
YOU. AND THE THANK YOU VERY
MUCH FOR THE INFORMATION AND
THE GOOD WORK THAT YOU'VE BEEN
DOING OVER THE LAST- SIX MONTHS
OR SO TO PREPARE FOR THIS
COMING COMING YEAR IN YOU RAISE
THE ISSUE OF THE- COMMUNITY
RESOURCE CENTERS IN THE
REPRESENTATION AND- THAT
CERTAINLY WAS A MAJOR CRITICISM
LAST YEAR'S PRESCIENT IN
DISTRICT THAT I REPRESENT. WITH
CHALLENGES OF WAITING FOR
PERSON MANY CASES TRYING TO SEE
WHEN THEY WOULD BECOME UP AND
RUNNING AND- IN SHOW THE YOU
MENTIONED THAT YOU HAD TWO
HUNDRED SURE SHE'S PLANNED FOR
THIS COMING FIRE SEASON AND YET
WITH COVERT AND WE UNDERSTAND
THAT DOES A CHALLENGER YOU
CHALLENGE UP YOU OUGHT TO MAKE
THE- WHEN A- IS. OF THEIR AREA
TENSION. HOW ARE YOU ARE YOU
STILL PLANNING FOR TO HER IS
THE ROLL OUT STILL GOING FOR
THOSE COVERT RESPONSIBLE SITES
AND DO YOU HAVE THEM SITUATED
OUTLINED PLANNED AND I GUESS
THAT'S THE CONCERN IS THAT-
UNDERSTANDING THE CHALLENGES OF
COVERT WILL YOU STILL BE ABLE
TO IMPLEMENT THOSE SHE'S IN THE
IN THE- RIGHT TIME AND MANNER
THAT. WHEN THEY WILL BE
NECESSARY. SO WHEN WE
CHALLENGES SPECIFICALLY WITH
CODE RED ON. IDENTIFYING AND
YOU GETTING INTO PLACE THE
HARDENED C. R. C.'S WE HAVEN'T
DROPPED THAT EFFORT THAT'S
GOING TO CONTINUE BUT
RECOGNIZING THAT WE'RE RUNNING
OUT OF TIME YEAH FIRE SEASON IS
UPON US THAT'S WHY WE'VE WAITED
TO ALSO INCLUDE YOU KNOW THE
TAX AND THE MOBILE RESOURCES TO
MAKE SURE THAT WE'RE SUPPORTING
OUR CUSTOMERS AS BEST AS WE CAN
BUT NO WE HAVE NOT STEPPED AWAY
FROM THE HARDENED C. R. C.
SITES. AND I GUESS MY QUESTION
ISN'T THAT THE HARDENS. MUCH AS
IT IS PERHAPS MAKING SURE THAT
YOU HAVE THE- SPACE THE
LOCATIONS IDENTIFIED. INDIAN
AVAILABLE. ALTERNATE LOCATIONS
THAT YOU MAY HAVE TO IMPLEMENT
IF WE- GO IF NEEDED AND WANTED
DIFFICULT IT IS STILL A CONCERN.
BUT I GUESS IT'S TRUE YOU HAVE
THAT THE NUMBER OF SITE STILL
AVAILABLE AND- WHETHER THEY'RE-
INSIDE AND ISOLATED THAT WAY OR
CROUCHED BUT SURE MAKE SURE
THAT THE PLAN IS MOVING FORWARD
IN THE JAW AT. ENOUGH YOUR- TO
GET YOU. I'M JUST. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU SENATOR YES WE ARE
AHEAD WITH THE FOR THE COMMUTER
RESOURCE CENTERS AND WE ARE.
WITH COUNTY ON A SPECIFIC
LOCATION THAT WOULD BE BEST FOR
THEIR- FOR THEIR RESIDENTS IN
OUR CUSTOMERS. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH. IF YOU. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH HELLO TO LATER DO WE HAVE
ANY OTHER QUESTIONS FROM THE
COMMITTEE. CENTER MCGUIRE.
THANK YOU SO MUCH MISTER CHAIR
OF FIRST AND FOREMOST I WANT TO
SAY THANK YOU TO MISS POWER FOR
MAKING YOURSELF AVAILABLE- AND
TO BE A TO PROVIDE INFORMATION
IT MEANS SO MUCH MISTER I'M
GONNA JUST GO THROUGH A FEW
QUESTIONS TO AT THE DISCRETION
OF THE CHAIR. IN TALK LITTLE
BIT ABOUT WHAT I WAS. HAD
QUESTIONED THE PRESENT ABOUT
YOUR OWN. SO MISS POWER IF YOU
CAN JUST DISCUSS THE 33% TARGET.
AND HOW LIKELY YOU ARE TO HIT
THAT TARGET WITH ALL OF YOUR
MAKER GREASE ALL YOUR SECTION
IDEATION I HEARD THE UPDATE I
HAVE THE NUMBERS RIGHT HERE
BUT- HOW LIKELY ARE YOU TO HIT
THAT OVERALL GOAL FOR THIS YEAR.
THANK YOU AND- WITH A SIMILAR
WET WEATHER EVENTS FROM LAST
YEAR JUST THE BACKDROP ON THIS
WE MODELED. ARE WORSE EVEN FROM
LAST YEAR OUR WORST WHETHER
YOU. LIKE I SEE AN SCG ANY WE
BROUGHT ALL OF THE EXPERTS
TOGETHER TO UNDERSTAND. WHAT IS
IT THAT WE CAN DO TO MAKE
THINGS EVEN. RESULT
DIFFERENTLY- GIVEN THE SAME
WEATHER CONDITIONS IN
SUBSEQUENT. AND THE SEXUAL IS
DEVICES THE TEMPORARY
GENERATION- THAT'S ACTUALLY XIN
DEVICES AND THE- SWITCHING
DEVICES ON THE TRANSMISSION.
ARE THE COMPONENTS THERE DEREK
WANTING TO HELP US TO DISSECT
THE GRADED AND IN. CASE YOU
ASKED MURSI'S POSSIBLE WE ARE
TRACKING THOSE EFFORTS ON A
WEEKLY BASIS AS I MENTIONED
EARLIER AND- IN STRENGTH WERE
GETTING MORE RESTORE. TO MAKE
SURE THAT WE FULLY EXECUTE ON
PLAN AND I AM- CONFIDENT IN OUR
ABILITY TO REDUCE. BACK TO OUR
CUSTOMERS AGAIN COMPARED TO
INVENT SIMILAR TO LAST YEAR BY
ONE THIRD. OKAY IT'S GREAT SO
IF WE CAN DO YOU DO A LITTLE
BIT OF A DEEP DIVE INTO THAT
SO- THE PUBLIC UTILITIES
COMMISSION- WHEN IT WAS WHEN I
WAS ASKED OF BY PRESENT A
BACHELOR AND HER STAFF THE WORD
IF MISS PETERSON KEPT SAYING IF
THEY DO X. Y. Z. SO. WHERE IF
YOU'RE IN A TEN POINT YOUR AREA
OF BIGGEST CONCERN AS WE MOVE
INTO POWER SHUT OFF SEASON IS
IT THE ISSUE OF CONNECTING ALL
OF THOSE GENERATORS IS IT
COMPLETING THIS ACTUALIZATION
SO IT SEEMS LIKE YOU'RE MAKING
MORE PROGRESS ON THAT. IN IN
OTHER AREAS CAN YOU TALK TO US
ABOUT THOSE CONCERNS AS YOU
MOVE FORWARD WE GET CLOSER
POWER SHUT OFF WHERE THERE IT
CAN TURN ABOUT. MEETING THAT
GOAL. I'M YOU. EONS WE'RE
TRACKING TO MAKE SURE THAT THIS
DOES NOT OCCUR TO BE REALLY
HONEST SEXUALIZED IN DEVICES
ARE THE AREA THAT WE ARE FOR
THIS BEHIND BEHIND WHERE WE
INTENDED BUT WE HAVE A TO GET
US THERE ARE TRACKING IT VERY
CLOSELY- THE TEMPORARY
GENERATION WE USE TEMPORARY
GENERATION AND TO REDUCE
IMPACTS OUR CUSTOMERS AS PART
OF THE PROJECT WORK PERFORMED
AND THAT'S AN AREA THAT I HAVE
CONFIDENCE IN- NEAR THE C. P.
COM. OF IF WE CAN ACCESS ON THE
PLAN AND I THINK ABOUT THE IF
THERE AND WE'RE WORKING TO PLAN
ON IT WE'RE GOING TO BE
CONDUCTING THREE EXERCISES THE
SUMMER TO MAKE SURE ALL OF OUR
TEAMS. NO AND ARE ABLE TO.
FULFILL THEIR ROLES AND
RESPONSIBILITIES IN THE IN IN
MANAGING THE EIGHT THAT. WE'RE
EXERCISING WITH OUR COMMUNITY
PARTNERS IN THOSE THREE
DIFFERENT EVENTS AND THE
PREPARATION AND THE TRAINING TO
BE ABLE TO DELIVER THAT- WE
HAVE THE STEPS IN PLACE AND
WE'VE GOT TO WORK THROUGH IT.
WHEN I THINK ABOUT WHAT'S
HAPPENED THIS SPRING- YOU KNOW.
WE HAD. THE NINETEEN
LIMITATIONS AND WE'VE WORKED
THROUGH THAT WE'D EVEN PRACTICE
OUR EMERGENCY OPERATIONS-
RESPONSIBILITIES. THAT WE'RE
GOING TO WAS CALVIN. REMOTELY
WE DONE NOT REMOTELY WE SET UP-
TEMPORARY SITE SINCE THE
QUESTOR CRUISE SO THEY WERE
ABLE TO OPERATE RED. EVEN IF WE
HAVE- SICKNESS ISSUES. IN SOME
OF OUR CURRENT OPERATING
CENTERS- WE ARE DOING
EVERYTHING THAT WE CAN TO BE
PREPARED AND I'M CONFIDENT THAT
WE'LL BE THERE. LIKE TO BE ABLE
TO IF THROUGH THE CHAIR IF IT'S
ALL RIGHT I'D LIKE TO BE A TO
TALK ABOUT- TECHNO SILVA- AND
I'LL PARAPHRASE HERE IN PLEASE
FISH FACT ME IF YOU THINK MY
PARAPHRASING IS INCORRECT BUT-
BRINGING ON A NEW CONSULTANT.
WHO WORKS WITH OTHER UTILITIES
AND ALSO WORKS WITH CAL FIRE TO
BE ABLE TO PREDICT- FIRE
BEHAVIOR. AND WHAT A POTENTIAL
SPARK NAY BE BASED OFF OF THE
WEATHER CONDITIONS THE TERRAIN-
AND- WHERE YOU WOULD SEE THAT
POTENTIAL FIRE IF IT WAS CAUSED
BY UTILITY. HOW MUCH IS THIS
GOING TO PLAY INTO YOUR
PREDICTING WHEN IT COMES THE IN
THIS MODELING INTO SHUTTING OFF
COMMUNITIES THIS NEW MODELING.
THE COMPANY NOW THAT YOU'RE IN
CONTRACT WITH WHAT HOUSE IS
GOING TO CHANGE THE GAME
COMPARED TO LAST YEAR. THANK
YOU. I THINK IT'S RATHER TECHNO
SILVA IN OUR FOR CASTING
CAPABILITIES FOR EVENTS LAST
YEAR WE HAD IF YOU THINK ABOUT
A COMPUTER SCREEN AND YOU THINK
ABOUT ALL OF THE PIXELS IN THIS
COMPUTER SCREEN THINK ABOUT
THAT ACROSS OUR SERVICE
TERRITORY. LAST YEAR OUR CORE
CASTING CAPABILITY WAS IN THREE
BY THREE CLIMATE- PIXELS SO
ABOUT NINE SQUARE KILOMETERS-
THE ADVANCEMENT THAT WE HAVE
UNDERTAKEN IN OUR MODELING
CAPABILITIES WHICH INCLUDES
TECHNO SILVA- AMERI CORPS
CREATING AND OUR SYSTEMS WERE
ALREADY STARTING TO SEE THE
STOCK. TWO BY TWO. SO OUR
ABILITY TO I'M MORE ACTUALLY
FOR THE WEATHER IN AS THEY
PERTAIN TO OUR OUR RED IS
SIGNIFICANTLY IMPROVED OVER
LAST YEAR. SO I'M GONNA ASK YOU
TO HELP TO FIND THAT OUT SO FOR
ISOLATE PEOPLE WHAT IS THAT
MEAN AND WHAT CAN WE EXPECT IN
REGARDS TO THE FORECASTING.
WHAT THAT MEANS IS ARE
FORECASTING IS ABOUT 0% MORE
PRECISE THAN IT WAS LAST YEAR.
AND IS OUR ABILITY TO- FOR CAPS
THOSE WEATHER CONDITIONS WITH
IN- THE GEOGRAPHY OF OUR
TRANSMISSION SYSTEMS AND OUR
DISTRIBUTION SYSTEMS THIS IS
GOING TO BE MORE ACCURATE. AND
WHAT THAT ALLOW US TO DO IS
START THE ENTIRE SCOPE OF THE
ANY BANDS. SMALLER THAT'S
EXACTLY WHAT'S GOING TO HELP US
MAKE THE EVENTS SMALLER AND
THAT'S THAT STARTS FROM DAY ONE
WITH THE FORECAST. I'D LIKE TO
JUMP TO THE ISSUE OF THE NORTH
COAST AND THE CHALLENGES THAT
WE SAW. LAST YEAR I
UNDERSTANDING- ABOUT WHAT
YOU'RE SAYING IN REGARDS TO
DAYLIGHT HOURS IN GETTING-
COMMUNITIES BACK UP AND RUNNING
IN A QUICKER TIME PERIOD. SO
THERE WERE SOME COMMUNITIES
THAT WERE OFF BETWEEN TEN AND
FOURTEEN DAYS BECAUSE ONE POWER
SHUT OFF. BLOOD INTO ANOTHER.
CAN YOU MAKE A COMMITMENT TO
YOUR SERVICE TERRITORY TODAY
THAT THAT WON'T HAPPEN THAT
YOU'RE GONNA BE ABLE TO AVOID
THOSE DOUBLE WHAMMY POWER SHUT
OFFS WHERE ONE BELIEVES IN TO
ANOTHER AND I AND I I'M
SPEAKING SELFISHLY BECAUSE-
LAKE MENDOCINO CINEMA IN A
SMALL PART OF MARINE ALSOP
ANYWHERE BETWEEN TEN AND
FOURTEEN DAY POWER SHUT OFF CAN
YOU MAKE SOME ASSURANCES THAT
THAT WON'T HAPPEN THIS YEAR.
SEC THAT'S TOUGH. BECAUSE THAT
WAS DRIVEN BY THE WEATHER
EVENTS WHAT I CAN TELL YOU IS-
ONCE WE HAVE THE ALL CLEAR.
FROM THE WEATHER EVENT WE HAVE
THE HELICOPTER SO THEY MENTION
WE HAVE THE SIX STRING WING
AIRCRAFT THAT I MENTIONED. WHO
CAN THEN CONTROL THE LINES I
UNDERSTAND WE HAVE ISSUES THAT
NEED TO BE CORRECTED BEFORE WE
CAN RETURN CUSTOMERS THE
SERVICE. WHAT I WOULD ALSO
MENTION IS THAT- VERY IMPACTFUL
SO THE NORTHERN COAST LAST
YEAR- AND SOMETHING THAT WE
CHANGE THIS YEAR AS WE HAVE-
ENABLED THE HUMBOLDT BAY
GENERATING. STATION ISLAND. I
IN CAPE OF EVEN THOUGH THERE
MAYBE TRANSMISSION IN PACKS UP
AWAY FROM THE COAST LINE THAT
AFFECTS THAT AREA. THE HOME
WILL BE GENERATING STATION WILL
BE ABLE THE ISLAND AND- MANY OF
OUR CUSTOMERS AND OUR. SO
THERE'S STILL A POSSIBILITY
THAT WE MAY SEE. THE WIND POWER
SHUT OFF BLEEDING TO ANOTHER
THIS YEAR OBVIOUSLY- WHAT I'M
HEARING YOU SAY IS YOU NEVER
WANT THAT TO HAPPEN BUT THERE'S
STILL POTENTIAL FOR THAT. I
GUESS WHAT I'M SAYING IS WE
DON'T WANT THAT TO HAPPEN WE
HAVE PLANS FOR THAT NOT HAPPEN
BUT WE CANNOT CONTROL THE SPEED
AT WHICH THE WEATHER FRIENDS
COME THROUGH. SO I PROMISE JUST
HERE JUST TWO MORE QUESTIONS SO
A FOLLOW UP ON THAT SO CAN YOU
GO A LITTLE DEEPER ON IF WE-
ARE IN A SITUATION WHERE WE'RE
LOOKING AT AN EXTENDED POWER
SHUT OFF. THE EXPENSE TO
BUSINESS THE CHALLENGES TO
SCHOOLS- I CAN KEEP GOING DOWN
THE LINE ABOUT COMPENSATION FOR
CUSTOMERS ON THAT. CAN I ASK
FOR CLARIFICATION WHAT YOU'RE
ASKING THE MY QUESTION IS IF
WE'RE LOOKING AT OF A POTENTIAL
TEN TO FOURTEEN DAY. SHUT OFF
WHICH- I'LL BE HONEST WE CAN'T
HAVE ANOTHER TWO WEEK SHUT OFF
IN THE STATE AIDES WERE IN
TWENTY TWENTY IT'S SIMPLY NOT
ACCEPTABLE. SHOULD CUSTOMERS
WHAT CUSTOMERS HAVE THE ABILITY
TO BE A RECOUP THEIR BUSINESS
LOST THEIR FOOD LOS EXEDRA. AND
AS WE MOVE FORWARD HERE INTO
POWER SHUT OFF SEASON. I'M YEAH
WE RECOGNIZE THE HARD JUSTICE
CAUSED BY BEING WITHOUT POWER
WE ALSO LIVE IN OUR
COMMUNITIES. HOWEVER I CAN'T
STRESS ENOUGH THAT PSCS IS
DRIVEN BY SAFETY AND PROTECTION
OF OUR COMMUNITIES FOR TRAFFIC
WILD FIRES. BEGIN WE UNDERSTAND
THE HARDSHIP DISCUSSES AND AS
SUCH WE'RE DOING EVERYTHING WE
CAN TO LIMIT ITS IMPACT. TO OUR
POPULATIONS. OKAY FOR YOU KNOW
GETTING ANSWER THAT ONE THAT'S
THAT'S FINE SO I THINK THAT
LOOK I HEAR YOU IN REGARDS TO
POWER SHUT OFF IS BASED OFF OF
SAFETY. AND BY THE WAY HIS PAL
BUT PLEASE DON'T DIRECT MY
DON'T DON'T TAKE MY COMMENTS
BEING DIRECTED TO YOU MISS
POWERS BEEN MORE THAN GRACIOUS
IN HER TIME- SITTING DOWN
ANSWERING QUESTIONS AND TRULY
GRATEFUL AND WHOEVER IS IN NET
SEAT HAS AN INCREDIBLY
CHALLENGING JOB. IT'S BEEN A
CULTURE AT THE UTILITY THIS IS
NOT A MISS PALS FAULT.
UNDERSTANDING SHE IS A VERY
DIFFICULT JOB NOW THAT WHERE
SHE IS NOW IN FRONT OF THE
COMMITTEE HAVE AN ANSWER BUT I
WANT TO GO A STEP FURTHER ON
THAT ISSUE OF. YES THIS IS A
SAFETY ISSUE BUT LET'S BE
CANDID THIS CORPORATION IS
BEHIND IN HAS BEEN BEHIND IN
VEGETATION MANAGEMENT AND
SPECIALIZATION IN DEVELOPING
TEMPORARY MICHAEL GRADES. THIS
WAS USES A BLUNT INSTRUMENT
LAST YEAR BECAUSE THERE IS NO
OTHER TO WHEN YOU'RE TO ABOUT
BECAUSE THE CORPORATION HAD
FALLEN BEHIND YEARS YEARS AND
BILLIONS OF DOLLARS IN KEEPING
THEIR INFRASTRUCTURE MODERNIZE
IN SAFE SO. WE CAN CONTINUE TO
SAY THIS IS A SAFETY-
INSTRUMENT AND AT THE SAME TIME
THOUGH BUT NORTH CALIFORNIA
RESIDENTS WITH FOR YOUR
CUSTOMERS REPEATING THESE
CUSTOMERS ARE. FEELING NEGATIVE
IMPACTS BECAUSE OF THE LACK OF
INVESTMENT BY THE CORPORATION-
OVERTIME SO I JUST WANNA MAKE
THAT CLEAR MY LAST SIDE. IS ON-
COMMUNITY RESOURCE CENTERS AND
I KNOW THEIR HELP IN A LOT OF
TIME ISSUE. YOU CAN YOU GO
THROUGH MORE TIME ON ISSUE I
HOW YOUR- RAIN FOR THE SOCIAL
DISTANCE SCENE AND WHAT TYPE OF
CONTINGENCY PLANS WERE YOU HAVE
IN PLACE TO BE ABLE TO MEET
COUNTY DEMANDS. IF WE'RE GOING
TO NEED TO BE ABLE TO GET
ADDITIONAL RESOURCE CENTERS
PROPPED UP BASED OFF OF THE
CORONAVIRUS. SURE SO THE FIRST
THING WE WOULD ALL LIKE THE
HARDENED YOU KNOW SEE OUR
SEASIDE SO EVERYBODY KNOWS
WHERE THEY ARE AND- YOU KNOW
THERE. THEY'VE GOT THE
GENERATION ASSOCIATED WITH
THEY'VE GOT COOLING AT CENTER
AND THAT WOULD BE IDEAL- AS WE
WORK YOU KNOW THROUGH THE
CALVET SITUATION RECOGNIZING
WE'RE GONNA HAVE TO HAVE SOME
TENNIS. KEEPING THEM OPEN AIR
AS A PROGRAM- HAVING MOBILE
UNITS THAT WE CAN MOVE AROUND
AND SERVE CUSTOMERS AND THE
CURRENT- SAFE WAY IS WITH ALL
OF THE REQUIRED PROTECTIONS
THAT ARE THAT ARE. BEING
SPECIFIED BY THE VARIOUS
COUNTIES- AND THE COMMUNITIES
THAT WE SERVE. IF THERE'S MORE
INFORMATION THAT YOU WANT HERE
I CAN I CAN HAVE OUR SACRAMENTO
OFFICE FOLLOW UP WITH YOU
DIRECTLY WITH MORE DETAILS.
THAT'S GREAT I GUESS THE I'D
LOVE TO BE A FOLLOW UP ABOUT
THE FLEXIBILITY RIGHT SO WE ARE
THE CURRENT VIRUS CHANGES IT
SOMETIMES A WEEK BY WEEK. AND
HOW WE'RE GONNA BE ABLE TO DEAL
AND ADAPT IF AND WHEN WE NEED
TO BE ABLE TO GET ADDITIONAL
RESOURCES IN. AT EIGHT TIMES A
DAY A FEW DAYS NOTICE I THINK
THAT'S CAN BE CRITICAL
OBVIOUSLY THE STATE IS FACING
THAT THROUGH THE OFFICE OF
EMERGENCY SERVICES- AND I KNOW
THAT SOMETHING THE P. GENIES
GONNA HAVE MY LAST QUESTION AND
I'LL PUT THIS BACK TO THE
CHAIR- MISSPELLED YOU STILL
BELIEVE IT'S GOING TO TAKE TEN
YEARS. TO COMPLETELY MODERNIZE
YOUR SYSTEM- THIS DEVELOP ALL
THE SECTIONAL IS ATION-
ADVANCING MODERNIZATION
MEASURES THAT YOU NEED TO
WITHIN YOUR GRADE AND THE
VEGETATION MANAGEMENT DO YOU
BELIEVE IT'S STILL GONNA TAKE A
DECADE. I THINK IT'S
INTERESTING WHEN YOU THINK
ABOUT A DECADE. OUR COMMITMENT
THIS YEAR IS TO MAKE ANY PS PST
VANS THAT WE HAVE TO CALL THIS.
YEAR SHORTER IN DURATION OUR
AND SMARTER AND HOW WE CALL
THOSE AND WITH- WITH THE PLANS
THAT WE'VE PUT INTO PLACE I
WORK FOR EVERY YEAR MISLI
IMPROVING AND SO WHEN WE SAY
TEN YEARS FROM NOW WHAT'S IT
GONNA LOOK LIKE. I HOPE IT'S
MORE LIKE WHAT SAN DIEGO GAS
AND ELECTRIC BUT AS YOU KNOW
VERY SHORT VERY PRECISE ROLE IN
OUR CUSTOMERS ARE RESTORED AND
ONE LIVING ON AND I THINK
THAT'S WHAT THE WHOLE
STATEMENTS IS VERY MINIMAL
IMPACT FROM THESE EVENTS NOT
CIRCLE FOR YOUR FORMER CEO SAID
IT'S GONNA TAKE A DECADE TO BE
A TO GET TO WHERE YOU WANT TO
BE ABLE TO GO WHEN IT COMES THE
MODERNIZATION WHEN IT COMES A
SPECIALIZATION. WHEN IT COMES
TO THAT TATIAN MANAGEMENT DO
YOU STILL BELIEVE IT'S GONNA
TAKE A DECADE. I THINK WE'RE
GONNA TO BE CONTINUOUSLY
IMPROVING OUR SYSTEM OVER THAT
DECADE- BUT I ALSO BELIEVE THAT
THE IMPACTS FELT BY OUR
CUSTOMERS WILL CONTINUE TO
DECREASE. OKAY SO ON A TRY ONE
MORE TIME SO. YOUR PREVIOUS CEO
LAST YEAR WAS IN FRONT OF THIS
COMMITTEE. AND HE SAID THAT
IT'S GOING TO TAKE A DECADE TO
BE ABLE TO GET TO WHERE THE
CORPORATION NEEDS AGO WHEN IT
COMES OF MODERNIZATION.
FICTIONALIZED ASIAN INVITATION
MANAGEMENT. DO YOU STILL
BELIEVE IT'S GOING TO TAKE A
DECADE TO GET THERE. I DON'T
KNOW WHAT BILLS INTENSE WAS
WHEN HE SAID A DECADE. AGO I
THINK WE WILL BE CONTINUING TO
INVEST IN OUR SYSTEM. FOR MANY
YEARS. AND THAT'S RALLY THEN
THE WHAT I WOULD SUGGEST AND
AGAIN THIS IS NOT AT ALL AT ANY
DISRESPECT IN THIS TOWN THIS
CALL HAS BEEN WONDERFUL TO BE
TO WORK WITH MISTER PATTERSON
IT'S BEEN WONDERFUL TO WORK
WITH. BUT I WOULD SUGGEST IS
THAT- WHOEVER'S LEFT IN THE
BOARD AT PACIFIC GAS ND
ELECTRIC GO BACK AND CHECK THE
RECORD GO BACK AND TAKE A LOOK
AT PRESS CLIPPINGS AND SEE WHAT
THE FORMER CEO SAID CAN YOU
TAKE A DECADE TO BE A TO GET
THERE CALIFORNIANS DESERVE
BETTER. IT NEEDS TO BE THAT
DRAMATICALLY REDUCED AND WE
NEED TO CONTINUE TO EXPEDITE
THE VEGETATION MANAGEMENT THE
MODERNIZATION THIS
ACTUALIZATION WITH POWELL THANK
YOU SO MUCHFOR YOUR TIME
MISTER CHAIR THANK YOU VERY
MUCH FOR ALLOWING ME TO ASK THE
QUESTIONS VERY GRATEFUL THANK
YOU VERY MUCH OKAY WILL THAT
BRINGS US TO THE END OF THE
PROGRAM AND I WANT TO THANK ALL
THE PARTICIPANTS. FOR JOINING
US TODAY AND WE'RE IN. ONLY
HAVE MORE. SORRY BOB DON'T
LEAVE YET WE HAVE MORE
QUESTIONS A LITTLE LATE TO
IDENTIFY THEMSELVES WILL BEGIN
WITH STATE CENTER DOLLY THEN
FOLLOWED THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIRMAN I ALSO JUST WHAT HAD A
FEW QUESTIONS FOR MS PALAWAN
HELLO- I WANNA DID- WHAT MY
COLLEAGUE- FROM THE SECOND
HISTORY MISTER WIRES TALKING
ABOUT AS FAR AS THE FRUSTRATION
LEVEL OF- NON COMMUNICATION I
YES MORE THAN ANYTHING WITH THE
RESIDENTS OF MY DISTRICT WHO
WERE WITHOUT POWER FOR
SOMETIMES I WANTED I HAVE A
COUPLE QUESTIONS NUMBER ONE-
WHAT IS IT. WE HEARD FROM THE
pWAS AS C. E. WHAT IS OF WHAT IS
THE- GINNY TERRITORY LOOK LIKE
AS FAR AS DROUGHT. AND THE
MEDITATION THE DRYNESS I GUESS
NUMBER ONE- AND THE NUMBER TWO
QUESTION ALL THIS ASKING REAL
QUICK HERE IS THAT- WHAT ABOUT
THE- MAGNITUDE OF THE- P. S.
P.'S IS THEY'LL- HAVE BEEN ABLE
TO. REDUCE THEM DOWN IN SIZE
BECAUSE YOU PUT IN THERE THE
CORRECT AMOUNT OF SWITCHES TO
BE ABLE TO SHUT DOWN YOUR GRID
IN SMALLER- AREAS THEN IT WAS
IT IN THE PAST WHERE WE OUT
WITH WHAT WHAT'S THAT WOULD
TAKE A LOOK LIKE THIS SEASON.
SURE THANK YOU SO FIRST ON. THE
DROUGHT AND THE DRYNESS. I
THINK WE ALL KNOW WE HAD RAIN
WHICH LAST WEEK WHICH I WAS
CELEBRATING JUST JUST TO TELL
YOU THAT- THE NATIONAL WEATHER
FORECASTS ARE SAYING THERE
COULD BE OFFSHORE WIND EVENTS
WERE REALLY LOOKING AT JUNE
RIGHT NOW FROM A DROUGHT FIRST
PERSPECTIVE- IN CALIFORNIA IS
CONSIDERED- THIS IS A MORE DRY
YEAR. AND FROM A HIGH FIRE
DISTRICT PERSPECTIVE ABOUT 50%
OF THE P. JEANNIE SERVICE
TERRITORY IS CONSIDERED- HI
FIRE THREAT. I'M MOVING ON TO
THE MAGNITUDE OF THE EVENTS
FROM LAST YEAR AND THE
DISTRIBUTION SEGMENTS- AND THE
SEGMENTATION WORK THAT WE'VE
DONE WE'VE INSTALLED MORE THAN.
EVER OVER TWO HUNDRED
SEGMENTATION DEVICES AND OUR
PLANS ARE TO JUST INSTALL MORE
THAN FIVE HUNDRED AND NINETY
TWO DEVICES BEFORE THE
BEGINNING OF HARD CIDER SEASON.
AMBER SO SEPTEMBER IS OUR IS
THE- GOAL OR THE TARGET THAT
WERE TRACKING TO. AND THE
INSTALLATION OF THE BY. IS WHAT
MUCH MORE ISOLATED BULL TO
IMPACT YOUR CUSTOMERS THAN WE-DID LAST YEAR THAT COMBINED
WITH OUR TEMPORARY GENERATION.
WILL ALLOW- COMMUNITIES WHO ARE
NOT SEEING THE WEATHER
CONDITIONS- I THE HIGH THE HIGH
WIND CONDITIONS- IT WILL ALLOW
SOME OF THOSE COMMUNITIES TO
STAY WITH AND POWER AND THE
COMMUNITY AREAS WHILE ISOLATING
THE FOLKS WHO LIVE OUT MORE IN
THE FURTHER OUT IN THE HIGH
FIRE IT'S RIGHT. I HOPE THAT
ANSWERS YOUR QUESTION YES THANK
YOU I KNOW THAT. AS THE GENIE
IS THE POSTER CHILD FOR YOU
KNOW HARDING THEIR GRID AND I
KNOW THAT YOU TO THE PGA FOLKS
ARE. BEHIND AND I KNOW AND I
REALIZED IT AS THE GENIE STILL
DOES PSP'S. THE GOAL FOR I HOPE
FOR YOUR YOUR ORGANIZATION IS
TO- NEAR THOSE DOWN- AND GET
THERE QUICKER THAN THAN A
DECADE AS MY COLLEAGUE WAS
TRYING TO PUSH ON BECAUSE- OUR
COMMUNITY JUST CANNOT WITHSTAND
THAT THOSE MANY DAYS WITHOUT.
HUGE NOW OBVIOUSLY WE WANT TO
BE SAFE. AT THE SAME TIME BUT
WE NEED TO BE ABLE TO
COMMUNICATE BETTER ARE YOU NEED
TO BE ABLE TO COMMUNICATE
BETTER- WITH THE YOUR
RATEPAYERS IN THE PEOPLE OF THE
YOU SERVICE- TO MAKE SURE THAT-
SO THEY KNOW WHAT THE HECK'S
HAPPENING OUT THERE. AND
ABILITY TO BE ABLE TO GET
GENERATORS IN THE STATE WHEN
THERE'S A P. S. P. IS- IS NOT
THERE NOT AVAILABLE AND SO I
JUST WANT TO SHARE THOSE WITH
YOU THE FRUSTRATIONS THAT WE- I
CAN'T TELL YOU HOW MANY CALLS
WE HAD. DURING THE P. S. P.'S
ACTOR AND I KNOW THAT. YOU'RE
GONNA TELL ME THAT WE NEED TO
BE SAFE AND I AGREE WITH YOU
THERE THAT WE DON'T NEED
CAMPFIRES- BUT WE NEED TO. GET
THE PACE AND SCALE THERE-
SOONER THAN LATER. THANK YOU.
OKAY GO AHEAD PLEASE CONTINUE
THE QUESTION BUT- BUT WAS A
MOMENT THAT WAS APARTMENT SO
STRUGGLING TO RESPOND TO IT.
OKAY CENTER MORE LIKE MEASURE
THANK YOU MISS POWER OF THIS
YEAR'S BEEN REAL INTERESTING
COVERED NINETEEN AND NOW FLOWGEORGIAN. AND I SEE YOUR TITLE-
INCLUDES RISK MANAGEMENT SO YOU
HAVE TO LOOK AT EVEN MORE THAN
JUST. WEATHER SITUATIONS AND
WILDFIRES SO YESTERDAY THERE
WAS AN EARTHQUAKE IN RIDGECREST
FIVE POINT FIVE I SEE THAT'S IN
YOUR TERRITORY I WONDER IF
BIRTH QUAKES ALSO FOLLOW- I
GUESS FALL INTO THE CATEGORY OF
A P. S. P. S. OPPORTUNITY- A
MAYBE YOU COULD EXPLAIN- WHAT
OCCURRED WITH THE EARTHQUAKE
AND YOUR COMPANY. AND THEN THE
SECOND QUESTION WOULD BE WHAT
IS- CENSOR YOUR ARM IN THAT
CATEGORY NOW WHAT WHAT WORSE
COULD HAPPEN- BUT YOU'RE
QUICKLY CERTAINLY HEAD- BUT
WHAT WHAT MY TEACHER BLACKS ONE
POLICY BE FOR AN EXTREME- EVENT
AND DO YOU AND DO YOU IS YOUR
PLAN AVAILABLE. THERE IS A LOT
IN THAT QUESTION SENATOR THANK
YOU- SUFFERS FROM THE EVENT
YESTERDAY- I'M I'M REALLY
THANKFUL THAT WE DID NOT
EXPERIENCE ANY DAMAGE AS A
RESULT OF THAT EARTHQUAKE
EVENT. AND YES WE DO- EXERCISED
EARTHQUAKES IT'S PART OF OUR
COMPANY EMERGENCY RESPONSE
PLAN- AND WE EXERCISE OUR
READINESS TO BE ABLE TO RESPOND
TO EARTHQUAKE EVENTS ON A I
THINK IT'S AN ANNUAL BASIS AND
WHEN YOU THINK ABOUT THE BLACKS
MIND KIND OF EVENT WE'VE BEEN.
EXPANDING THIS YEAR WITH
EVERYTHING THAT HAS GONE ON.
YOU DON'T LARGE MAGNITUDE
EARTHQUAKE COATED NINETEEN M.
P. S. P. S. ARE ALL IN- IN THE-
CONSIDERATIONS THAT WE HAD AND
SOME OF THE EXERCISES THAT WE
CONDUCTED VIRTUALLY. DURING THE
NINETEEN AND OUR EMERGENCY
OPERATIONS CENTER WHICH IS IN
FACT VIRTUALLY. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH THE COMMISSION. THANK YOU
ANYONE ELSE BEFORE WE CONCLUDE.
OKAY THANK YOU VERY MUCH AND
AGAIN I WANT TO THANK THE
PARTICIPANTS FOR THE FOR
JOINING US TODAY AND FOR THEIR
PRESENTATIONS- WE WILL NOW MOVE
ON TO THE PUBLIC COMMENT PART
OF OUR OF PROGRAM. DUE TO
CONSTRAINTS REGARDING THE
LENGTH OF HEARINGS TECHNOLOGY
CONSIDERATIONS AND NEW CLEANING
PROTOCOLS COMMITTEES WILLIS TO
TIME LIMITS ON TESTIMONY
ACCORDINGLY EACH PERSON WHICH
IS BIG BASS PICK FOR A TOTAL OF
TWO MINUTES ALSO WE HAVE ROOMS
THAT HAVE BEEN SET ASIDE FOR
PUBLIC COMMENT NOBODY- IS IN
ANY OF THEM BUT- I DON'T KNOW
IF WE HAVE IDENTIFIED IN THE
COLORS. FOR ALL INDIVIDUALS
WISHING TO PROVIDE PUBLIC
COMMENT THE PARTICIPANT TOLL
FREE NUMBER AND ACCESS CODE. IS
POSTED ON OUR COMMITTEE WEBSITE
IT WILL BE ALSO- DISPLAYED ON
THE SCREEN. AND I WILL ANNOUNCE
IT AGAIN TODAY'S PARTICIPANT
NUMBER IS ONE. EIGHT FOUR FOUR.
1-116-364-1844 TWO NINE ONE.
SIX THREE SIX FOUR. AND THE
ACCESS CODE IS SEVEN EIGHT
THREE. 1-345-783-6745 ONE MORE
TIME. SEVEN EIGHT THREE SIX
SEVEN FOUR FIVE DO WE HAVE ANY
COLORS IN THE QUEUE FOR PUBLIC
COMMENT. AND WE WILL GIVE IT A
SECOND SEE IF ANY CALLS FROM
MEN. HI WE DON'T DISCOVERED HER
FIGHT YOU KNOW AND- WE DON'T
WANT PARTS I JUST WANNA LET YOU
KNOW WE HAVE ONE PARTICIPANT
CUED UP FOR EVERYBODY ELSE
SIMPLY PRESS ONE ZERO. TO PUT
YOURSELF IN Q. THANK YOU. AND
JUSTWANT TO VERIFY NOBODY IS
IMMUNE IN ANY OF THE ROOMS.
NOBODY IS AN ANY OF THE ROOMS
WE HAVE ONE CALLER. OPERATOR
COULD YOU PUT THAT COLOR
THROUGH. ABSOLUTELY ONE TWENTY
THREE. PLEASE GO AHEAD LINE
TWENTY THREE YEAR OLD BUT.
HELLO THIS IS ALLEY TRAIL WITH
REIMAGINE POWER ON THANK YOU
ALL FOR THAT PRESENTATION TODAY
I REALLY JUST WANT TO
UNDERSCORE THE IMPORTANCE OF
MICHAEL GRADE IN WILD FIRE
MITIGATION YEAH YEAH IMPACT
MITIGATION AND REALLY LOOKING
TOWARD COMMUNITY RESILIENCY AS
WELL AS TRUTH THE PAIN ABILITY
ADDRESSING OUR ECONOMIC THE
FINAL AN ENVIRONMENTAL. WE NEED
TO FOCUS ON CREATING A MY
PROGRESS. AS PART OF TRACK TWO
OF THE BEAUTY PROCEEDING
IMPLEMENTING AT THIRTEEN THIRTY
NINE. IT IS WRITTEN IN THE
STATUTE THAT THAT IS WHAT NEEDS
TO BE DONE TO COMPLETE APATHY
BANG AND REALLY STRONGLY
ENCOURAGE EVERYONE TO FOCUS ON
THAT AS PART OF TRACK TO. THE
WE CAN DEPLOY MICHAEL GRANT
WIDE KNEES AND EXPEDITIOUSLY
ACROSS THE ENTIRE STATE. THANK
YOU ALL. THANK YOU AND
APPRECIATE VERY MUCH YOUR
PARTICIPATION DO WE HAVE ANY
OTHER COLORS. QW LINE OVER LIKE
TWENTY SEVEN PLEASE MY TWENTY
SEVEN YOU ARE OPEN. GOOD
AFTERNOON MY NAME IS MERRY
RELEASED HER UP I'M THE
COORDINATOR AT THE RECLAIM OUR
POWER UTILITY TO CAMPAIGN- WE
AND OUR COALITION THE
LEADERSHIP IS MADE UP OF THE
BIGGEST ENVIRONMENTAL JUSTICE
ORGANIZATION. AND LOCAL CLEAN
ENERGY ADVOCATES IN NORTHERN
CALIFORNIA INCLUDING- OVER
SEVENTY FIVE ENDORSERS CHORE
COALITION IN OUR PRINCIPLES FOR
UTILITY JUSTICE FIFTY THREE
WHAT'S SO THANK YOU FOR HAVING
THIS HEARING- LEARNING A LOT
ABOUT THE DIFFERENT- PROGRAMS-
AND PLAYERS THAT ARE IN PLACE.
WE ARE STILL VERY CONCERNED-
AND DON'T TRUST HE NEED TO BE
ABLE TO EXECUTE WHAT WHAT THE
COMMUNITY NEEDS- DURING THIS
TIME TO INSURE BATES- DELIVERY
OF OUR ELECTRICITY- AT THAT
UTILITY TO CAMPAIGN GOAL ARE
THREEFOLD WE'RE SUPPOSED TO ANY
P. JEANNIE BAIL OUT. WITH OUR
PUBLIC FUNDS- WHICH YOU WE WANT
TO DEMOCRATIZE OUR ENERGY
SYSTEM THAT WE HAVE AN ABILITY
TO- DECIDE WHAT HAPPENS WITH
OUR COMMUNITY AND THREE WE WANT
AT REIMAGINE AND REBUILD THE
ENERGY SYSTEM THAT WE HAVE NOW
WE CAN GET OUT OF PRIVATE.
CORPORATIONS CAN. WITH THE
FIRST PART AROUND ON OPPOSING
THE P. JEANNIE BAILOUT WE SEE
THAT ALL THESE PROGRAMS THAT
WERE TALKED ABOUT TODAY AND
THEN AT OTHER TIMES THE DAMAGES
ARE. BY PRIVATE CORPORATIONS
EUGENIE AND SHOULD BE PAID FOR
BY THEN AND NOT THE PUBLIC AND
THE INCREASE- HOP ON PUBLIC
HEALTH AGENCIES AND FIRE
DEPARTMENTS AND OVERSIGHT
AGENCIES SHOULD BE PAID FOR BY
Q. GENIE AND THE HIGHER USE
THAT ARE POPPING THESE DAMAGES
AND NOT. INCREASING. THE RATE.
AFTERWARD WHO HAD NO ROLE IN
CAUSING THE- DAMAGES BY PRIVATE
CORPORATION UNDER OUR SECOND GO
AROUND DEMOCRACY OR AN TO. SO
ARE OUR STATE LAW ON AND BY
JUSTICE UNDER THE ON THE LIKE
EXPERIENCE IS AN URGE. THE URGE.
AT THE END YOU OF UNITY AND
DESPITE WHAT HAVE GEORGE. AND
SO WE HAVE THINK SO LISTA THAT
WE FROM HE KNEW AT THAT GIVING
IT. THE DOING WORK DON'T
ACTUALLY KNOW THE NEEDLE MAKING
THAT. FROM COMMUNITY THE
WORKERS HOW DECISION MAKING
ROLES ABOUT WHAT PUBLIC SAFETY
MEANS A LOT THAT WE DON'T WANT
TO BE NOTICED WE WANT TO BE
PART OF THE DECISION MAKING
AND- IN OUR TESTIMONY THAT THE
T. Q. D. LAST WEEK AND OVER
SEVERAL HEARING- ONE OF THE
BODIES THAT THEY TEACH YOU
DEEPLY- ACTIVATE AN AUTHORIZED
TO BE PART OF. OF THE DECISION
MAKING AN OVERSIGHT AND HE'S
UNION THE REORGANIZATION PLAN
IS A DISADVANTAGED COMMUNITY
ADVISORY GROUP SO WHAT ROLE.
LIKE THAT- PLATE AND- AND
HELPING. TO DECIDE HOW MAKE
SURE OUR COMMUNITY THEIR STATE
LOCATE VERY MUCH. AT THE YOU
FOR WE'LL HAVE GONE WITH OVER
THE TWO MEN BUT WE. MAR BECAUSE
THANK YOU THANK YOU VERY FOR US
FOR COMMON. AND AN- I ANYONE
ELSE ON THE LINE. OKAY VERY
WELL IT UP AT THIS TIME I WANT
TO THANK ALL THE INDIVIDUAL
SUPPORT PARTICIPATE IN THE
PUBLIC TESTIMONY TODAY IF YOU
WERE NOT ABLE TO PROVIDE
COMMENTS TODAY PLEASE SUBMIT
YOUR COMMENTS OR SUGGESTIONS IN
WRITING TO THE SENATE COMMITTEE
ON SENATE ENERGY UTILITIES AND
COMMUNICATIONS OR PLEASE VISIT
OUR WEBSITE. YOUR COMMENTS ARE
AND SUGGESTIONS ARE VERY
IMPORTANT TO US WE CAN'T RUN
THE STATE WITHOUT YOUR
PARTICIPATION AND WE WANT TO
INCLUDE YOUR TESTIMONY IN THE
OFFICIAL HEARING RECORDS AS
WELL THAT IS VERY IMPORTANT FOR
PROCESS SO PLEASE PARTICIPATE
THANK YOU WE APPRECIATE YOUR
PARTICIPATION THANK YOU.
EVERYONE FOR YOUR PART PATIENTS
IN COOPERATION TODAY- THIS WAS
AN EXTREMELY INFORMATIVE
HEARING I'M GLAD WERE PROPOSED
IN AN ONLINE FOR PEOPLE REVIEW
AND IF PEOPLE WANT TO REVIEW
THAT THIS COMMITTEE HEARING A
FUTURE OCCASION A WILL BE
POSTED ONLINE FOR PEOPLE TO
REVIEW AT THEIR CONVENIENCE WE
HAVE CONCLUDED THE AGENDA. THE
SENATE COMMITTEE ON SENATE
ENERGY UTILITIES AND
COMMUNICATIONS IS NOW ADJOURNED
HAVE A NICE DAY AND PLEASE STAY
SAFE EVERYONE.